Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wann hast du zuletzt über deine Ernährung nachgedacht?
Gestern, würde ich sagen.
Also dieses Kleid-Einstiegsthema können wir schnell abhandeln. Die Leute wurden gefragt, was kaufen sie? Die Antwort war Essen. Und die weiteren Erklärungen sind, die Leute kaufen weiterhin primär nach Geschmack.
Ah ja.
Und deswegen, und das hab ich jetzt nur auf dem Schirm, weil meine Tochter gerade ihre erste sozusagen Studienarbeit schreibt, in der man so mal die Formalier einhalten soll zum Thema Tierwohl in Deutschland, Konsumentenverhalten und was hat es mit konventioneller und biolandwirtschaft auf sich. Und im gleichen Zuge, wie der Ernährungsreport kam, hat unser Alois was auch immer, der schwarze Bäcker oder wie er hieß, Fleischhahn, gesagt, der Stallumbau wird jetzt doch nicht mit einer Milliarde gefördert.
Ach so.
Weil die Leute, denen ist ja egal, wo das Schwein herkommt.
Ja, aber ich glaube, den Leuten ist ja auch ein bisschen egal, so selbst, wie sie sich so...
Den Leuten ist alles egal.
Ja, ich stelle immer wieder fest, dass Menschen sich ja in unsinnige Lokalitäten begeben und dort zum Beispiel einem akustischen Lärm ausgesetzt sind, der eigentlich unerträglich ist und da soll man auch was essen und was trinken. Das kann ich nicht begreifen. Und dann ist das auch noch so was, wo man sagt, gut, will man das wirklich essen. Also das ist, das Qualitätsbewusstsein scheint mir nicht nur gering zu sein, wenn man sagt, wie sollen eigentlich Tiere leben, sondern auch man selbst steht sich da im Wege, steht dem Genuss im Wege. Und das ist nicht immer nur eine Frage von Geld. Also wir wissen natürlich, Menschen, die wenig Geld haben, haben gar nicht die Möglichkeit, sich gesund zu ernähren oft. Das ist natürlich ein Riesenproblem. Aber ich merke einfach bei vielen Leuten, wo es nicht ums Geld eigentlich geht, dass sie sich Dinge zumuten, bei denen ich sage, gut, ich würde es freiwillig nicht essen. Und das hat auch gar nichts mit Geld zu tun, weil es oft auch teuer ist. Oder ich hatte jetzt gerade so einen Auftritt in dem Filmmuseum in Düsseldorf, da an der Black Box, da habe ich einen Vortrag gehalten und wurde dann anschließend noch in so einer Räuberhöhle geführt, wo man, ich glaube, man sagt in Düsseldorf Altkneipe dazu. Und das war wirklich sowas von unwürdig und laut und stickig. Ich musste den Mantel noch acht Stunden danach draußen lüften, weil er nach Fett gestunken hat und Bier. Und dann denke ich mir auch, warum tun sich Menschen das an? Warum nicht einfach das Leben genießen? Ja.
Aufforderung für alle. Falls ihr euch im Restaurant unwohl fühlt, fragt doch mal nach der Stallordnung, ob das damit vereinbar ist, was man hier erlebt.
Und liebe Restaurant- und Kneipenbetreiber, man kann einen in jeden Raum akustisch optimieren. Wenn man das schön haben will, kostet das ein paar tausend Euro. Wenn man das nicht schön braucht, sondern es soll einfach nur funktional sein, dann geht das schon fast mit ein paar hundert Euro. Ja, da gibt es solche Platten, die kann man oben an der Decke festmachen. Und dann ist gut. Dann muss man nicht sich gegenseitig anbrüllen. Das ist etwas, was man wunderbar einrichten kann. Und ich verstehe nicht, warum das nicht geschieht.
Apropos, lasst mich kurz schildern. Ja, die Restaurants werden gerade auf Optik getrimmt und nicht auf Akustik. Wahrscheinlich, weil man zu sehr auf Laufkundschaft achtet, der einfach sagt, lock mal mit einem tollen Foto hier noch ein paar Leute rein, damit sie dann akustisch einfach den Overflow erleben. Vielleicht ändert sich das ja nochmal, wenn der Schiff zum Video geht, dass man die Leute nicht versteht, wenn sie im Restaurant ihr Video aufsprechen. Aber das wird dann zunächst der Kritik führen in anderen Belangen. Wir hatten ja über das akustische Phänomen Notre-Dame gesprochen letztes Jahr. Ich war jetzt in Barcelona und habe die Sagrada Familia besucht, weil sie ist jetzt die höchste Kirche der Welt. Und spektakulär, ich kann das sehr empfehlen. Also die Kirche ist von Gaudi, sie ist ungefähr 150 Jahre jetzt im Bau. Und der Innenraum ist fertig. Und der Innenraum besteht aus Säulen, die wie Bäume funktionieren und damit ein Blätterdach. Und es gibt keine Gemälde, keine sonstigen Sachen. Da hängt so ein Balldach hin, aber einfach nur so, um mal zu zeigen, wir sind eine Kirche. Also Jesus Christus gibt es hier schon, aber er hängt sozusagen völlig, also er ist nur irgendwo fest, sondern er hängt im Innenraum. Und Gaudi hat gesagt, es gibt nur einen Maler und es ist die Sonne selbst, das heilige Licht und so, soll dann da reinscheinen. Und selten so ein funktionierendes Konzept gesehen, muss ich sagen. Na ja. Es tut mir ein bisschen leid, dass der Gaudi diese Idee nur hatte und das Resultat nicht sah. Aber ich finde, wir sollten uns jetzt alle für ihn freuen, dass es geklappt hat und uns das mal anschauen. Also fahrt mal dahin und es lohnt sich besonders, hat unser Guide gesagt, im Winter. Weil in Barcelona ist sowieso immer hell. Wir hatten auch einen wolkenlosen Tag. Und dann kommt die Sonne ganz flach und die ganze Kirche ist bunt. Also es ist wirklich alles bunt. Unglaublich. Im Osten geht die Sonne auf, da ist dann alles blau gebohrt neu. Und dann wandert sie rüber auf die Seite der Passion. Du kommst da rein und denkst, alles brennt. Also wirklich gut. Richtig gutes Konzept. Das neue Notre Dame muss ich natürlich nochmal hören. Kann man da nicht einfach so hinfahren. Da braucht man ja einen Termin, wo man weiß, da wird dann auch die Orgel gespielt. Aber ja, Kirchen abklappern in Europa, perfekt. Ich werbe weiterhin dafür. Museumisierung Europas. Lasst doch die Amis die Schlüsseltechnologien machen. Und die Chinesen. Wir haben ja morgen in Düsseldorf Termin, um über KI zu reden. Wir werden auch mal ein paar Investitionsentscheidungen durchdenken, die da so hören gerade.
Ja, machen wir. Nur ganz kurz für die, die jetzt nicht da sein können, denn das war dann ruckzuck ausverkauft. Das wird dann für die Salon-Abonnenten auch veröffentlicht werden als Podcast zum Nachhören. Genau, eine Woche später. Dieser Podcast wird unterstützt von Procon. Was ist Procon? Procon ist eine Energiegenossenschaft. Wir wissen Genossenschaften. Da schließen sich Bürger zusammen, um ein großes Ziel zu verfolgen und es gemeinsam zu erreichen. Und bei einer Energiegenossenschaft liegt der Zweck meist entweder in der Energieerzeugung oder im Handel von Energie. Es gibt sehr viele Energiegenossenschaften in Deutschland. Und Procon ist eine besonders große Genossenschaft. 40.000 Mitglieder vertreten es Procon in Deutschland, Polen, Finnland und Spanien. Procon setzt auf Wind-Onshore, auf Speichertechnologien, PV und Biomethanen. Und mit dem Kauf von Genossenschaftsanteilen liefern die Mitglieder wichtiges Eigenkapital für den Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien. Bereits mit 50 Euro kann jeder Mitglied werden und somit dann ein bisschen die Energiewende selbst in die Hand nehmen. Man kann natürlich auch Mitgliedschaften verschenken.
Ja, und wenn das nicht mal eine gute Idee ist, an jemanden, der schon alles hat, während man selber nicht mal eine gute Geschenkidee hat, dieses Jahr einfach ein ganzes Windrad verschenken. Ihr habt dann Anteile an Procon, wenn ihr für 50 Euro da einsteigt. Euch gehört genauso viel Stimmrecht über die Windräder wie jedem anderen, die 40.000 Mitglieder, egal wie viel man reinbringt. Die anderen holen nur mehr Rendite raus, aber ihr seid genauso Teil dieser sehr großen Gemeinschaft mit einer sehr guten Idee. Und ihr könnt damit richtig auftrumpfen und pralen. Stellt euch vor, wie ihr unterm Weihnachtsbaum sitzt und der Onkel erfährt, dass er ein Windrad bekommt. Da erspart sich auch jede andere Diskussion über, wer ist hier der Beste. Das ist die Idee, die wir gerne weitertragen. Wir danken Procon sehr dafür, diesen Podcast zu unterstützen, also auch euch.
Und man hat natürlich als Mitglied dann auch Zugang zu vergünstigtem Strom. Und in den letzten Jahren wurden erfolgsabhängige Dividenden in Höhe von drei bis fünf Prozent ausgezahlt. Es kann sich also lohnen.
Alle Informationen zu Procon in unseren Show Notes, also greift mal in eure Hosentasche.
Ich habe etwas fürchterliches getan.
Oh nein.
Ich habe mir drei Sendungen angehört, in denen Ferdinand von Schirach zu Gast war.
Und jetzt bist du klüger.
Leider nein.
Du denkst nochmal deine Moral, Ethik und Achtungsbedingungen.
Möchte ich gar nicht, nein. Okay. Denn ich habe mich gefragt, also ich bin ja nicht einfach so darauf gekommen, man sieht den ein oder anderen Clip, aber ich wollte nochmal so den deutschen Diskurs nachspüren. Und ich dachte, ich brauch so jemanden, der eigentlich den deutschen Diskurs, der auch sehr stark ein Boomer-Diskurs ist und sehr stark ein, ja, von den großen Medienhäusern und dem öffentlich-rechtlichen geprägter Diskurs ist. Und ich wollte wissen, wer vertritt eigentlich diesen Diskurs, dann auch mit so einem leichten intellektuellen Anstrich, in Personalunion. Und es ist Ferdinand von Schirach.
Ist das unser Herr Hegemon?
Es ist ja der Herr Hegemon, zumindest für sehr viele noch. Leider, füge ich gleich hinzu. Und wir werden uns dem jetzt widmen. Es gibt sehr, sehr viele Clips. Es wird mitunter fürchterlich, aber das größte Leid habe ich ja schon getragen, nämlich all die Sachen, die mir angehört habe. Hier ja nur die Auslese. Zunächst einmal gehen wir aus dem November hinaus in den September. Und hören uns dort Schirach bei Lanz an. Es geht um das Thema Israel Nahost. Und Lanz will da noch mal wissen, weil Schirach das erst so abwärt ist. Das ist gar nicht sein Thema. Da will er nicht so drüber reden. Er redet aber dann doch laufend darüber. Und Lanz fragt nach.
Nochmal Nachfrage. Wenn so viele namhafte Völkerrechtler sagen, das ist ein Genozid, der da stattfindet, nicht meine Meinung. Ich bin kein Jurist, aber ich trage das vor. Was geht Ihnen dann durch den Kopf? Also müssen wir sozusagen irgendwann auch aus diesem Dilemma, in dem deutsche Politik da auch steckt, raus, weil wir klar formulieren müssen, dass wir sehr wohl an der Seite Israel stehen, aber nicht an der Seite dieser Regierung, die zum Beispiel solche Bilder, wie das, was Sie da hinten sehen, letzten Endes auch produziert hat. Also ist es legitim, wenn man das hört, was Sie gerade geschildert haben, dass man eine ganze Bevölkerung sozusagen kollektiv bestraft?
Herr Lanz, Sie fragen den Falschen. Sie werden von mir nichts dazu hören, weil jemand, der meinen Nachnamen trägt, für die nächsten 500 Jahre dazu nichts zu sagen hat.
Wow, harter Einstieg.
Das ist ja erst einmal etwas, was man so stehen lassen kann. Jetzt kann man sich fragen, müsste man nicht... Nein, ich will es ja mal auf der individuellen Ebene erst klären.
Ich heiße Schulz. Weißt du, was das alles bedeutet?
So, also die Schirachs mit der Nazi-Vergangenheit, deshalb will er sich dazu nicht äußern. Jetzt kann man ja sagen, das ist eine individuelle Entscheidung. Die kann man auch kritisieren, indem man sagt, müsste man sich nicht gerade, wenn man diesen Namen hat, fragen, ob nie wieder, das auch bedeutet, dass überall dort, wo Menschenrechte verletzt werden, man seine Stimme erhebt. Aber gut, dass man das mal dahingestellt. Man könnte es ja... Nein, ich will nur nochmal die individuelle Ebene. Das ist die individuelle Ebene. Und dann gibt es dabei noch die andere Ebene. Sollte generell der deutsche Diskurs so sein. Und das ist genau das, was wir jetzt erleben werden, dass Schirach ja nicht sagt, ich sage dazu nichts, Punkt, tschüss. Wir reden über was anderes, sondern er sagt, eigentlich abstrahiert er dann von seiner individuellen Situation und seinem individuellen Entschluss und sagt, ich hätte eigentlich gerne den deutschen Diskurs so, dass da jetzt nicht drüber geredet wird, weil es ja die Vergangenheit gibt, die Deutsche.
Also ich bin gleich gespannt, was sich hier entfaltet, aber schon bei diesem ersten, so wenn er jetzt anmerkt, jemand der meinen Namen trägt, also den Namen eines Täters, eines Massenmords, der industriell durchgeführt wurde, wir wissen alle, worum es geht, Holocaust, diese große historische Einmaligkeit. Und dann wird die Schlussfolgerung daraus gezogen und deswegen sage ich dazu nichts, also welche Lehre trägt er denn aus den Erfahrungen mit diesem Namen, der Aufarbeitung und so weiter, dass man zu Massenmord schweigt?
Nein, seine Lehre ist generell, dass er glaubt, jetzt nichts mehr zu kritisieren zu können, wenn es um den israelischen Staat und die israelische Regierung geht, womit er natürlich eine merkwürdige Verbindung erstellt, nämlich dass er jetzt sagt, alle Juden identifiziere ich mit der israelischen Regierung. Und das ist ja offensichtlich falsch, sondern sonst könnte man ja sagen, ich kann ja die israelische Regierung trotzdem kritisieren, warum auch nicht, auch wenn es den Holocaust gegeben hat. Nicht gerade deswegen. Er macht aber diese Generalität, dass er sagt, nein, deshalb, und das ist für ihn alles gleich. Und das heißt aber auch, deswegen ist also Israels Regierung nicht zu kritisieren, weil es den Holocaust gab. Und du sagst ihr zurecht, nee, man müsse eigentlich genau den umgekehrten Schluss ziehen. Und das ist aber ja typisch für die deutsche Debatte, für eine bestimmte deutsche Debatte, dass man sagt, nee, das machen wir jetzt so auf keinen Fall. Und das sind ja dann auch permanente Widersprüche, in die man sich begibt, vor allem dann, wenn man ja doch anfängt, die ganze Zeit darüber zu reden. Also ich will sagen, wenn jetzt jemand individuell sagt, das ist nicht mein Thema, Punkt, dann muss ich das akzeptieren. Man hat ja keinen Äußerungszwang. Aber wenn man dann trotzdem die ganze Zeit darüber redet, was jetzt gleich passiert, dann muss man sagen, ja, aber so kann man auf jeden Fall nicht darüber reden.
Ich mache jetzt seit zehn Jahren Podcasts so, und ganz lange galt für mich, und das habe ich auch so im Podcast gesagt, auf Haben Podcasts so, solange Netanyahu in Israel regiert, äußere ich keine Meinung dazu, weil er eckt ja eh immer nur an, und im Grunde ist auch klar, was gesagt ist. Also ich beziehe mich auf mich und sage dann einfach, okay, hier nicht zum Thema. Er hat ja quasi genauso angefangen. Sie werden von mir dazu nichts hören, und da finde ich, gibt es 1000 gute Gründe, warum man das so sagen kann. Aber in dem Moment, wo er auf seinen Nachnamen abstellt, muss er dazu da was sagen. Weil dann ergibt das ja alles gar keinen Sinn, sich auf eine individuelle Haltung zurückzuziehen, weil er ist ja nicht sein Opa, Vater oder wie auch immer.
Genau.
Und deswegen macht das gar keinen Sinn, was er gerade gesagt hat.
Wir kommen zwar aus Familien, aber wir sind die ja nicht. Ich bin ja nicht mein Großvater.
Und wir haben auch schon gehört, wenn das Familienargument so gelte, dann gelte das auch für die Nation. Denn wir haben gerade einen politischen Diskurs in Amerika, wir haben den Hasumi dazu gehört, die sagen, Familie ist gleich Nation. Das sind nur verschiedene Abstraktionslevel, dasselben.
Aber so wird das ja gemacht. Ich meine, jetzt ist ja auch rausgekommen, Uschi Glas hatte ihren Ahnenforscher bestellt, um mal rauszufinden, was so mit ihrer Familie war, stellt sich dann heraus, dass der Vater da auch in der SS wohl war. Und er sei aber dann ein guter Vater gewesen und so weiter und hat nie darüber geredet. Und das führt sie dann alles nochmal aus und kritisiert aber dann vor allem den Antisemitismus von links. Also das ist so interessant, dass sie darüber spricht. Zumal man ja auch, das ist auch wieder so typisch, wir könnten auch über Uschi Glas jetzt reden, Uschi Glas war noch auf dem 100. Geburtstag von Leni Riefenstahl. Da gibt es noch Aufnahmen, der wurde organisiert von Siegfried und Roy. Und die stehen da und singen Happy Birthday für Leni Riefenstahl. Die nun wirklich an der Propaganda nicht nur irgendwie so latent teilgenommen hat, sie war die Propaganda und hat im Nachhinein Geschichtsklitterung ohne Ende betrieben und hat Dinge verheimlicht, verleugnet, obwohl es klar war, dass sie zum Beispiel auf Zwangsarbeiter zurückgegriffen hat als Statistin und all diese Dinge. Und dann kann man jetzt noch auf so einer filmästhetischen Sache sagen, ja, aber das sind beeindruckende Bilder und dem würde ich ja sogar zustimmen. Aber man kann nicht zum 100. Geburtstag von Leni Riefenstahl gehen und dann noch sagen, wir haben ein Problem mit Antisemitismus in Deutschland und der kommt vor allem von links. Das ist einfach nicht zusammenzukriegen.
Ich bin sehr gespannt. Ich sehe ja hier seitenlang Clips dazu.
Wir hören mal weiter.
Ich kann es Ihnen nur grundsätzlich sagen, dass natürlich wie in allem, was das Recht betrifft, immer ein Verhältnismäßigkeitsgrundsatz stehen muss. Daran gibt es auch nicht zu zweifeln. Aber wir dürfen nicht vergessen, dass es die Hamas war, die Israel angegriffen hat und die furchtbarsten Verbrechen dort verübt haben. Und dass Israel reagiert und sich verteidigen darf, darin besteht unter Völkerrechtlern auch überhaupt kein Zweifel.
Nein, das hat niemand in Abrede gestellt.
Ich bin nur nicht der Ansicht, dass wir als Deutsche Israel Ratschläge geben sollen oder unter Umständen auch noch kritisieren. Das verbitte ich mir einfach. Zumindest gilt das für mich selbst.
Was denn nun? Deutschland bitte als Ganzes nicht und für ihn selbst nicht. Und Deutschland liefert ja Waffen. Also wir sind ja beteiligt daran. Es ist ja nicht so, dass man aus einer reinen Zuschauerperspektive hier irgendetwas kommentiert, sondern man ist ja beteiligt an dem, was dort geschieht.
Also ich verstehe, in welche Richtung du das aufarbeiten möchtest. Und das finde ich als Interessent am Herrn Hegemon sehr wichtig. Ich bin allerdings immer abgelenkt von den Inhalten dieser Clips. Denn das Recht, die Verhältnismäßigkeit, die Hamas und so weiter. Also die Hamas hat Israel angegriffen. Damit hat die israelische Bevölkerung eine Gewalterfahrung gemacht, die vorher auch die palästinensische Bevölkerung gemacht hat. Denn die Erzählung kennen wir doch alle. Die Hamas schmeißt, um mal ein Zeichen zu setzen, Leute von den Dächern, die liegen dann den Gas auf der Straße, damit alle sehen, hier lieber mal machen, was die Hamas sagt, ansonsten tot. So, die Hamas nutzt Palästinenser als menschliche Schutzschilde. Die Hamas quält ihre Bevölkerung da, weil irgendwann vor zehn Jahren mal eine Wahl stattfand und dann haben sich aber Sachen verändert, wie auch immer. So. Dieser ganze Connex zu sagen, nein, da kämpft die Hamas gegen Israel, nein, da kämpft die Hamas gegen die israelische Regierung und wie immer in solchen Kriegen wird das natürlich auf dem Rücken der Zivilbevölkerung ausgespielt. So. Und wir haben überall Opfer. Die Palästinenser waren zuerst Opfer der Hamas, dann ist die israelische Armee da eingezogen oder es hat mal mit Flugzeugen drüber geflogen, da wurde sie Opfer der israelischen Regierung. Sie ist also immer Opfer. Das macht gar keinen Sinn, wie er das hier aufschlüsselt. So im Sinne von, ne, die müssen ja gegen die Hamas kämpfen, also gegen die Zivilbevölkerung. Weil Zivilbevölkerung ist Zivilbevölkerung, egal ob palästinensisch oder israelisch. Also klar, da liegen Grenzen dazwischen und so, aber Zivilbevölkerung ist Zivilbevölkerung und die Zivilbevölkerung ist keine Seite des Konflikts.
Die Hamas hat einen Pokrom gegen die israelische Zivilbevölkerung begangen und dann ist die Frage, wie ist darauf zu antworten? Und wir sehen ja dann, er springt ja selbst zu dem Punkt Verhältnismäßigkeit, wir sehen ja dann, dass die israelische Reaktion darauf ist, dass man jetzt, die Zeit hat es jetzt gerade nochmal veröffentlicht, man von 100.000 Toten in Gaza spricht und davon sind nun sehr viele Frauen, Kinder oder Männer, die nicht zur Hamas gehören. Und dann ist das ein Kampf auf dem Rücken der Zivilbevölkerung und dann kann man nicht sagen, naja, da stehen sich irgendwie zwei gegenüber. Und da greift einer an und der andere verteidigt. Das ist so nicht machbar. Es sei denn, man sagt, die einen haben keine Zivilbevölkerung und nur die anderen haben eine. Und das würde man ja nicht tun. Das ist ja nicht logisch.
Genau. Das ist ja der Beitrag auch von Ole mit seinem Buch, zu sagen, da kämpft nicht Deutschland gegen Frankreich, da kämpft eine Elite gegen eine Elite. Und die brauchen sowohl Soldaten als auch eine Zivilbevölkerung, an der sie Exempels statuieren können oder wie auch immer. Aber wir können nicht einfach von zwei Parteien ausgehen, im Sinne von, ah ja, hier Israel und da die Hamas. Also was ist denn das für ein unterkomplexes Bild?
Ja, ja. Und wir sehen das ja auch jetzt auf einem anderen Konflikt. Bei der Ukraine, jetzt wird ja wieder verhandelt oder möglicherweise verhandelt, wie es dann ausgehen könnte. Es ist ja interessant, wie viele Sanktionspakete, ich glaube 18, 19, man schnürt, weil man immer noch sagt, naja, aber die Tür lassen wir uns noch offen und das Geschäft wollen wir mal noch behalten. Denn es ist ja eigentlich noch aushaltbar, da stellvertretend, wenn wir das schon so nicht machen, Menschen sterben auf dem Felde. Dann müssen das mal die jungen Russen und die jungen Ukrainer, die müssen sich halt da gegenseitig töten. Aber bevor jetzt Microsoft auf die Idee kommen würde, zu sagen, wir sperren unsere Dienste, Google sperrt die Dienste in Russland oder so, ist ja nicht passiert. Also hätte man ja auch zum Beispiel durchsetzen können, das hätte ja Russland doch einigermaßen in Unruhe gebracht.
Also Google und Microsoft zu sperren wäre das absolute Todesurteil für alle Länder.
So, und dann sagt man aber, das wäre wirklich schlecht für so ein Megakonzern, denn wie gucken dann die anderen Länder darauf, die ja auch Microsoft haben, aber vielleicht dann in Zukunft, also machen die sich davon los. Und das ist ja nur ein Beispiel. Genauso haben wir das ja hier, dass man sich fragte, wie das würde immer noch dann doch noch Öl nach Europa geliefert, einfach so in so ein kleiner Umweg. Und die einen wollen noch gerne die Luxushandtaschen weiterhin in Moskau verkaufen, die anderen wollen dies und das. Und da zeigt man ja ganz eindeutig, da ist man sich irgendwie so in der Elite nicht so eins, wie in die Hand hat man es. Aber gut, wir lassen das mal die Männer da austragen und bedeutet einfach, ja, wir gehen über die Leichen, Lehrer.
Also bei 19 Sanktionspaketen hat man ganz schön oft darüber entschieden, was man nicht sanktioniert.
Ja.
Das muss man einfach sagen. Und das ist einfach bescheuert.
Also ein zweites hätte man noch irgendwie verstanden, dass man beim Ersten was vergessen hat.
Weißt du noch, von Arken im Sommerinterview, als er... Ja. Ja, aber jetzt im 18. Sanktionspaket ist ja das und das drin. Und er fragt einfach nur mal die Journalistin zurück, warum erst im 18. und dann sagt sie, ja, das muss ich Ihnen jetzt nicht erklären.
Ja, genau. Also daran kann man es sehr deutlich sehen.
Alles schräg.
Die Staatsräson.
Es ist, das war tatsächlich auch immer Staatsräson Deutschlands.
Die Unverbrüchlichkeit der Beziehung.
Die Unverbrüchlichkeit dieser Beziehung. Wir können auch im nächsten Schritt, wissen Sie, wir machen dann damit weiter. Dann ist die Frage, war es richtig, war es falsch, was Israel mit Teheran gemacht hat? Ich weigere mich, diese Diskussion zu führen. Israel ist ein von Feinden umgebender Staat. Es ist der einzige demokratische Rechtsstaat nach westlichem Vorbild, den es dort unten gibt. Und wir müssen alles tun, dass es nicht schlimmer wird.
Ich weigere mich, die Diskussion zu führen, setze sie aber hiermit fort. Also das ist ja lustig.
Das ist wirklich kaum zu ertragen. Vor allem bei diesen Fragen, war es falsch, was Israel in Teheran gemacht hat? Also zumindest bei der Sache mit Katar haben wir danach Fotos bekommen, wie das Telefon auf Trumps Shows stand und Netanyahu wie ein kleiner Junge da anrufen musste, um sich zu entschuldigen. Wir können schon uns zutrauen, bei solchen Sachen jetzt nicht nur rhetorisch zu fragen, ja war das jetzt falsch oder nicht? Denn da muss man jetzt nicht auf die Geschichtsbücher warten, ob es alle tot sind und so und die Zeitzeugen es nicht mehr scham erfüllt miterleben müssen, wie wir sagen, das war echt falsch.
Die ganze muslimische Welt oder große Teile, ich habe in Deutschland keinen Vertreter, also kein führenden Vertreter der Muslime gehört, der die Taten der Hamas verurteilt hat. Also ich möchte wirklich noch mal klar dafür plädieren, auch wenn...
Aber auch da, von Schirach, das ist da nicht so...
Das gab es nicht.
Ich weiß, aber ist da auch nicht da so wahnsinnig viel Politik im Spiel? Wir hatten sehr wohl Muslime hier sitzen, die das absolut verurteilen.
Ja, aber keine Huen vertreten, keine Organisationen.
Ich will nur sagen, für mein Rechtsempfinden, eine Sache da reinzugehen und zu sagen, wir ziehen die, die das gemacht haben, zur Rechenschaft. Aber es ist eine ganz andere Sache, kollektiv eine Bevölkerung zu bestrafen, die zu einem überwiegenden Teil aus kleinen Kindern und Frauen besteht.
Die hohen Vertreter des Islam oder die wichtigsten Vertreter der Muslime, wer soll das sein? Also weiß er, wie das funktioniert mit diesen Muslimen und dem Islam? Da gibt es jetzt nicht den Vatikanen, dass man das nicht bei Papst anrufen kann und so?
Vor allem, die sitzen dann in Deutschland und gehen hier in eine Talkshow und sagen jetzt nein. Also wir haben ja arabische Staaten beispielsweise, die diese Resolution gemacht haben. Also das ist ja auch alles. Also ich will nicht leugnen, dass es in der muslimischen Welt international ein Antisemitismus gibt, der auch sich verstärkt hat. Nur was hier so getan wird, ist so als seien irgendwie die Muslime jetzt generell antisemitisch oder so. Und das kann ja nicht sein, dass man das jetzt einfach so da mal stehen lässt und immer noch sagt, aber ich mische mich in diese Debatte nicht ein.
Ich will noch mal darauf hinweisen, wenn ein Herr Hegemon in Bilanz sitzt, also der Herr Hegemon ist im Grunde eingeladen bei Gott himself, was Hegemon-Dimensionen angeht. Und dort kommen Vorwürfe, jemand hätte etwas nicht getan, eine kommunikative Handlung nicht gemacht. Ich verstehe, dass Leute, die irgendwie sagen, das ist mir alles zu kompliziert und so, ich bleibe bei einem nüchternen, banalen, handlungstheoretischen Modell. Ich sehe Menschen und sie handeln. Und danach stricke ich meine politische Berichterstattung, meine Medien erleben, was auch immer, ja, so. Der Protagonist und seine Helden auf der Handlung. Nicht handeln ist kein Handeln. Wir können nicht einfach immer bei einer Duldung unterstellen, dass jemand aktiv gehandelt hat. Das ist ein bisschen wie beim Fußball, dass man Situationen, die sich innerhalb von 0,3 Sekunden ergeben, dass man sie durch Zeitlupe auf drei Sekunden streckt und dadurch allen mega Intention zurechnet. Warum hat er seine Ferse da gerade so gedreht, genau auf das Schienbein? So, ja. Nein, das ist eine optische Täuschung. Diese Intention hat es nie gegeben. Wir versuchen sie nur im Nachhinein, weil sich, als sagen wir mal, die Situation ergibt sich in 0,3 Sekunden. Zehn Sekunden später, also die ist schon dreißigmal vergangen, wird nachträglich retrospektiv festgestellt, das war eine ganz wichtige Situation, wir brauchen jetzt einen Fernsehbeweis. Das ändert an der Geschichtsschreibung der Situation gar nichts, nur an unserer Beobachtung. Wir können nicht immer das so dominieren lassen.
Naja, zumal.
Also wenn irgendwer irgendwas nicht gesagt hat, dann ist der Vorwurf entweder ganz konkret zu machen, Herr Lanz, warum haben Sie den nicht eingeladen und konkret gefragt, ja, aber nicht einfach in den Raum hineinrufen, da hat jemand nicht gehandelt.
Ja, also was man ja als Vorwurf bringen kann, und das bringt er dann auch in einer anderen Passage, da sagt er dann, dass es nach dem 7. Oktober direkt Solidaritätsbekundungen mit der Hamas gegeben hat, eben diese Szenen, die sich in einigen Straßen, in Großstädten vor allem haben, da sind aber nicht hohe Vertreter von der Öffentlichkeit. da sind aber nicht hohe Vertreter von der Öffentlichkeit. da sind aber nicht hohe Vertreter von der Öffentlichkeit. da sind aber nicht hohe Vertreter von der Öffentlichkeit. da sind aber nicht hohe Vertreter von der Öffentlichkeit. da sind aber nicht hohe Vertreter von der Öffentlichkeit. da sind aber nicht hohe Vertreter von der Öffentlichkeit. Wenn man aber zugleich sagt, diese ganzen Demonstrationen, die stattgefunden haben, pro palästinensischer Art, die können ja nicht verstehen, warum hat es nicht genau so Demonstrationen oder warum hat es nicht stattdessen Demonstrationen gegen die Hamas gegeben. Dann muss man hier ja zwei Dinge auseinanderhalten. Also wenn man sinnvoll demonstriert, dann demonstriert man ja dort, wo man etwas bewegen kann. Also wenn ich jetzt für Venezuela hier auf die Straße gehe, dann ist das relativ sinnlos. Es sei denn, Deutschland würde gerade mit Venezuela irgendwas verhandeln. Oder wäre da an irgendetwas beteiligt. Hier geht es ja darum zu sagen, Deutschland soll bitte aufhören mit diesen Waffenlieferungen beispielsweise. Oder soll palästinensische Menschen aufnehmen, nämlich Zivilbevölkerung aufnehmen. All das sind ja Anliegen, die artikuliert man an eine Deutsch-Regierung. Während man ja nicht sinnvollerweise irgendetwas bewirken kann. Also das hat auch nicht viel gebracht. Aber man kann möglicherweise hoffen, Deliberative, Demokratie und so weiter, dass man da Menschen erreicht, Entscheidungsträger, die dann sagen, ist vielleicht ein Punkt. Während jetzt eine Demonstration, die sagt, liebe Hamas, gib doch mal die Geiseln frei, ja von Deutschland oder so. Das ist ja ein reiner Symbolakt, der ja überhaupt nichts bewirkt in der Welt der Hamas. Das kann man machen, aber das ist ja einfach nicht das, warum man eigentlich eine politische Demonstration macht. Eine politische Demonstration macht man nicht einfach nur der Symbolik halber, sondern man versucht damit, die Einflusssphäre, die man hat, gelten zu machen. Und die kann man eben gelten machen, zum Beispiel, indem man sagen will, ich möchte da keine Waffen haben. Oder man kann auch eine Demo machen und sagen, Deutschland soll mehr Waffen liefern. Auch das wäre sinnvoll. Aber einfach nur so, um das mal gemacht zu haben, ist es absolut sinnlos. Wir hören weiter.
Und es entsteht der Eindruck, da dürfen die einen etwas, was wir bei den anderen verurteilen. Es entsteht ja der katastrophale Eindruck von doppelten Standards. Wenn Putin das in der Ukraine macht, dann gibt es keine Begriffe, die groß genug sind in der deutschen Politik, um das zu verurteilen.
Ich verstehe schon auch den Unterschied.
Aber in der völkerrechtlichen Bewertung ist die Zerstörung von Wasserleitungen die Zerstörung von Wasserleitungen. Und in der völkerrechtlichen Bewertung ist die Bestrafung von Zivilbevölkerung die Bestrafung von Zivilbevölkerung.
Ich glaube nur nicht, dass es Bestrafung ist. Und das ist auch nicht die Idee von Bestrafung. Aber wissen Sie, weder Sie, Herr Lanz, noch ich haben einen genauen Einblick, was da ganz konkret passiert.
Ja, wir wissen ja eigentlich gar nichts. Wir wollen aber auch nichts wissen. Kommen wir zu einer weiteren Sendung, jetzt aus dem November.
Warum war er überall?
Hat er ein neues Buch?
Ein Buch und eine Tournee? Alles mögliche, ja, ja, ja. Es ist einfach unser Orakel jetzt.
Ich freue mich auch für ihn.
Ja, und es kann er nicht alles hier in Gauk alleine machen. Er war bei Karin Mioska auch zu Gast hier, die Anmoderation.
Über Tatorte hat er geschrieben wie niemand sonst. Doch mit dem Schriftsteller und Juristen Ferdinand von Schirach werden wir heute nicht über Verbrechen sprechen, sondern über Vertrauen.
Darauf kommen wir heute noch mehrmals, auf das Vertrauen. Das Thema lautet also...
Vertrauenskrise und Empörungskultur haben wir den Kompromiss verlernt.
Ich wäre gern wieder Student, weil dann könnte man das mit seinen Kommilitonen einfach public viewing-mäßig johlenend sich anschauen. Genial, schon die Einführung.
Es waren noch andere Gäste dabei, aber die ignorieren wir jetzt mal weitgehend.
Das fragen wir heute und ich freue mich auf unsere weiteren Gäste. Die ehemalige Vorsitzende von Bündnis 90 Die Grünen, Ricarda Lang und den stellvertretenden Chefredakteur der Zeit, Martin Machowit.
Ah ja, okay. Gut. Da ist es aber jetzt auch nicht so, dass das unglaublich relevant ist, was dort gesagt wird. Ricarda Lang bemüht sich in und wieder noch inhaltlich was anderes zu bringen. Aber ja, es ist eigentlich ja so, dass Ferdinand von Schirach ganz langsam spricht, ganz lange Pausen macht. Aber da er nun mal Ferdinand von Schirach ist, aus dieser Aristokratenfamilie stammt, wo es natürlich auch unschöne Sachen in der Vergangenheit gegeben hat, aber da er aus dieser Familie stammt, unterbricht man ihn natürlich nicht. Denn üblicherweise, du kennst es aus Talkshows, ist es so, dass man entweder versucht schnell zu reden oder den Ton immer nach hinten anzuheben, damit man ja nicht unterbrochen wird, weil sofort schon Doro Berda oder Kubicki reinbrüllen. Aber bei Ferdinand von Schirach, das ist reine Autorität, der kann ganz langsam etwas formulieren. Alle hören zu.
Herr von Schirach, sie haben vor vier Jahren eine Initiative gestartet, mit der sie die Grundrechte Europas erweitern wollten und die Verfassungen zeitgemäßer gestalten wollten. Und gemäß Ihres Artikels 4, Ihrer Grundrechtekarte, soll es ein Recht auf Wahrheit geben. Ich zitiere das Recht, dass Äußerungen von Amtsträgern der Wahrheit entsprechen.
Das ist ein Vorschlag. Schirach führt aus.
Also das geht dort bei diesen Grundrechten im Wesentlichen darum, ganz extreme Fälle zu erfassen. Also natürlich lügen Politiker dauernd. Das müssen sie auch tun. Das geht gar nicht anders. Und das ist auch nichts Neues. Also ich erinnere mich an einen Satz, Konrad Adenauer, was geht nicht mein dummes Geschwätz von gestern an? Also es wird dauernd alles Mögliche wieder geändert. Und das kann eigentlich auch nicht anders sein.
Er erinnert sich an den Satz von Adenauer. Man weiß gar nicht, ist das jetzt metaphorisch gemeint oder er erinnert sich wirklich?
Möglicherweise. Wir wissen es nicht. Aber es geht also darum, dass Politiker ja schon lügen dürfen und auch müssen. Das gehört zum Geschäft. Aber es gibt dann ganz schlimme Lügen. Da muss dann ein Gesetz für Wahrheit her. Ich frage mich dann, wer misst das? Gibt es da eine Waage, mit der man sagen kann, oh, das ist aber jetzt eine schwere Höhe, die wiegt drei Kilo mehr? Da müssen wir jetzt mal einschreiten. Komisch.
Unser Problem dabei ist, dass das Vertrauen extrem gefährdet ist im Moment. Die Menschen sind misstrauisch. Wir haben ja jetzt gerade eine Studie, die Mittelstudie der Friedrich-Ebert-Stiftung. Und da glauben nur noch 49 Prozent der Menschen, dass die Demokratie gut funktioniert. 80 Prozent stehen hinter der Demokratie. Was schön ist und ein tolles Ergebnis und 6 Prozent mehr als beim letzten Mal. Ja.
So, Vertrauensverlust, aber zugleich nicht Demokratieverlust. Es gibt da so einen Wunsch nach Partizipation offenbar. Das haben wir ja schon häufiger jetzt gesehen. Das hat ja auch Philipp Manow aufgezeigt. Ja, vielleicht ein Vertrauensverlust bei den liberalen Demokratien, aber das demokratische, also dass man ein System haben will, in dem man wählen kann, das ist nicht irgendwo im Schwinden begriffen. Im Gegenteil, es wird eigentlich mehr gewählt denn je. Aber warum ist denn das jetzt mit dem Vertrauen so?
Wir müssen überlegen, wann, und das wäre die eigentliche Frage, wann wird das Vertrauen in die Politik erschüttert? Und ich glaube, das ist bei drei Dingen der Fall. Einmal, wenn etwas versprochen wird und nicht gehalten. Das ist eines der schlimmsten Sachen.
Was also permanent ja vorkommt.
Dann, wenn Handeln der Politiker als ungerecht empfunden wird.
Von wem wird es ungerecht empfunden? Also das sind einfach so Aussagen, mit denen ich sage, also ich kenne Leute, die halten das für unglaublich ungerecht, dass sie mit ihrem hohen Einkommen noch Solidaritätszuschlag zahlen müssen. Ich wiederum finde, das ist ganz gut, das hat wenigstens ein bisschen Progression. Die sollen ruhig mal diesen Beitrag noch leisten. Was ist da jetzt gerecht?
Ich werde auch gleich was dazu sagen. Machen wir noch Punkt 3.
Punkt 3, auch noch wichtig.
Und das Dritte ist, wenn Probleme nicht wirklich benannt werden, also wenn die Dinge nicht beim Namen genannt werden.
Ah, okay. Also wir haben Vertrauen erschüttert, Gerechtigkeit und so eine Art von, sagen wir mal, Wahrhaftigkeit, Ernsthaftigkeit. So, Probleme werden ignoriert, und wir müssen uns irgendwas vermieden. Wir haben nachher auch Clips von El-Mafaalanis, der ein Buch über Vertrauen gerade geschrieben hat. Ich hab's noch nicht gelesen, ein bisschen kleiner. Wir werden es auf jeden Fall im Salon besprechen. Denn ich glaube, und das ist schon, ich glaube, die sind hier alle auf dem falschen Weg, wir haben keine Vertrauenskrise, weil die Kategorie Vertrauen hier völlig falsch ist. Man sollte auch nicht zu profan an die Sache rangehen, sondern es ist, wie wir schon im Dezember 2019 besprachen, als Ankündigung für dieses Jahrzehnt eine Glaubenskrise. Die Leute glauben nicht mehr, dass die Demokratie funktioniert. Und Gerechtigkeit und Obskurität sind Kategorien, die da auch passen. Beim Vertrauen passen die nicht. Und vielleicht sind hier gerade die publizistisch am wirkmächtigsten Denker, also Schirach für die Alten, El-Mafaalanis für die Jungen, gerade auf einem ganz falschen Weg. Das werden wir mal nachher schon und dann auch im Salon mal ermitteln.
Es gibt ja das Buch über Vertrauen von Niklas Luhmann. Und da ist ja Luhmann der Auffassung, dass wir in einer komplexen, ausdifferenzierten Gesellschaft ja nicht über alles uns selbst eine Meinung bilden können. Wir können nicht alles verifizieren, sondern wir steigen ins Auto ein, drehen den Schlüssel rum und fahren los. Aber wir haben jetzt nicht in allen Einzelheiten uns klargemacht. Wie ist denn das jetzt mit den Zündkerzen? Und wir wissen noch nicht, man hat unser Auto überhaupt noch Zündkerzen, all diese Dinge. Und das gilt natürlich auch für Institutionen. Das heißt, wir kommen eigentlich, na doch, in Institutionen ist es schon so, dass ich, ich könnte jetzt sagen, vertrauen muss oder daran glauben muss.
Was ist der Unterschied? Es gibt einen ganz großen Unterschied zu spalten.
Also, Luhmann würde ja schon betonen, dass wir darüber nicht alles wissen können. Also nur noch die Experten der Experten können es wissen. Bedeutet also, wir müssen in die Dimension des Glaubens kommen, um zu sagen, scheint zu klappen, wird schon klar, wird schon gut gehen.
Ja, also wir werden das auch natürlich mit Luhmannshilfe und meiner eigenen. Ich habe in Redaktionsschluss auch über Medienvertrauen vor zehn Jahren geschrieben. Ich finde immer noch, das ist im Grunde, da steht alles drin, was man wissen muss. Das mit dem Vertrauen ist so ein bisschen problematisch, weil wir es immer labeln unter dieser Maßgabe, wir können es ja nicht wissen, wir müssen vertrauen, wir deschauen es ja nicht, also dein Auto beispiele und so. Vielleicht gibt es ja gar nichts zu validieren. Also vielleicht kann man durch mehr Fleiß gar nicht zu mehr Erkenntnis und Wissen kommen, sondern es gibt einfach hinter dem Vertrauen gar nichts zu validieren. Das ist ja vielleicht auch ein Ding. Dieses Vertrauen, und das ist super interessant bei Niklas Luhmer, der nun die große Gesellschaftstheorie geschrieben hat, die wichtigsten Sachen werden an, ich sage jetzt mal grob, das Individuum zurückgebunden. Also Geld, die großen Kommunikationsmedien, Wahrheit und so weiter, die haben alle über symbiotische Mechanismen direkt mit dem Körper zu tun, mit uns. Also wirklich Menschen aus Fleisch und Blut. Die Theorie ist ja eine Abtraktion darüber, die eben sobald Kommunikation beginnt, dann einfach greift und sehr wirkmächtig ist. Aber wir haben dieses Phänomen beim Vertrauen, dass Niklas Luhmann nicht einfach sagt, wir können Institutionen, müssen wir vertrauen, weil wir sie nicht durchschauen können. Das wäre zu kurz gesprungen, das so zu sagen. Sondern Vertrauen ist ein Mechanismus, der vor allem in dieser individuellen Auseinandersetzung, in einer Interaktion, also zwischen Personen, Komplexität reduziert. Und zwar nicht im Sinne von, naja, ich kann jetzt nicht meiner Tochter überall nachspüren, ich muss ihr vertrauen. Nee, selbst wenn du ihr überall nachspürst, du wirst zum Wesen deiner Tochter nicht vordringen. So, da gibt es einfach, das ist Kommunikation, ihre Kognition und so, alles ist verborgen. So, also müssen wir sowieso vertrauen. Egal, was wir für tolle Apparate haben, egal, wie viel Wissen wir haben.
Aber er sagt dann, dass bei den Institutionen, die es natürlich mit Experten zu tun haben, deren Wissen beschränkt sich aber wiederum auch nur auf ihr Feld, bedeutet also selbst die größten Experten.
Na, komm mal nachher zu.
Bedeutet ja, die größten Experten müssen ja auch wiederum den anderen Experten vertrauen, weil sie das wiederum nicht bewerten können.
Das hast du jetzt aufgemacht als Thema. Das werden wir noch groß behandeln. Ich will nur jetzt das alles wieder zusammenbinden. Diese Idee, dass wir Vertrauen als Kategorie der persönlichen Koordinierung von Verhalten einfach so auf Systeme und Institutionen übertragen können, ist völlig falsch. Also wirklich radikal falsch. Das darf man so denken. Anders kriegt man den Alltag nicht bewältigt. Aber wenn man versucht, das aufzulösen, wird das nicht gelingen. Und auch wenn Lignas Luhmann schrieb, es gibt Personenvertrauen und Systemvertrauen, ja, es gibt Systemvertrauen, aber jetzt nicht einfach Vertrauen in Institutionen. So im Sinne von, die Lufthansa wird schon wissen, wie sie das Flugzeug so operieren, dass wir da alle in Basel ohne gut ankommen und ohne sakraler Familie gucken können, weil da geht es, glaube ich, ja. Nein, nein, nein, das sind alles Kurzschlüsse, die darf man nicht machen und die machen aber alle.
Das heißt, wir brauchen bei dem Einstieg ins Flugzeug auch die interpersonelle Vertrauensbasis, dass du siehst, okay, die Flugbegleiterin sieht so aus, sagen wir vertrauenswürdig.
Ich will es mal ganz salopp sagen, Leute wie Schirach, Leute wie Mafaalanis würden nicht ins Fernsehen gehen und auch nicht eingeladen werden, wenn sie dort nicht über Institution und Vertrauen, sondern über Glauben und so tun, als ob besprechen würden. Und ich sage aber als Soziologe und ich mische mich jetzt in Mafaalanis Feld ein, wo er nämlich sagt, da darf es uns niemand. Ich bin ein Diplom-Soziologe in Bielefeld ausgebildet. Ich darf mich also durchaus bei dem Professor in Dortmund, der Soziologie lehrt, einmischen und sagen, und ich habe dazu auch bei den Sozialtheoristen einen kurzen Text geschrieben, wir dürfen durchaus mal von den massenmedialen Hauptbegriffen der Superstars, unseren Grundbegriffen, abweichen und sagen, ja, ja, das Problem, Frau Mioska, was Sie da beschreiben und sehen, das ist schon da. Nur mit Vertrauen, Institutionen und Systemen kommen wir hier nicht weiter. Wir haben eine Glaubenskrise. Und nur weil Ihnen das unattraktiv ist, jetzt in so einer Abendnachrichtensendung, die unter Politik läuft, über Glauben zu reden, ja, es gibt einen sakralen, religiösen Glauben, aber es gibt halt auch einen Alltagsglauben. Und der wird gerade verletzt.
Gerade das als ob angesprochen, das ist ja dann auch wichtig, um das zu verstehen, was wir jetzt eben bei Luhmann ausgeführt haben. Das heißt, man schaut nicht dahinter und dann hat man hier noch mal die Wahrheit zum greifen, sondern wir tun auch in der Kommunikation so als ob und wenn dieses als ob aber nicht mehr funktioniert, dann haben wir eigentlich die Glaubenskrise.
Genau. Und jetzt ist die Frage, dann kann man dann groß aufschlüsseln. Und das wäre dann auch Thema für so ein Buch. Wenn das als ob nicht mehr funktioniert, wer muss ich dafür rechtfertigen? Der Ehemann, der fremdgegangen ist und die Frau sagt einfach jeden Morgen, ich tue jetzt mal so als ob hier nichts wäre und dann, es ist ja auch nichts, also ist das Konkurrent, dann plötzlich stellt sie fest, ach nee, es ist ja doch was. Jetzt kann ich nicht weiter so tun als ob. Und wenn ich so weiter tue als ob, um mich und ihn zu schützen, dann laufe ich in so eine Lüge rein und dann und so weiter und dann wird alles kompliziert. Wer muss sich jetzt für was rechtfertigen, dass die Frau eine als ob Vermutung hatte? Ist es der wirklich der Mann? So, ja, also das sind solche Fragen. So und das wird hier einfach alles gar nicht gemacht. Also die Leute, die hier kommen mit, ja wir müssen vertrauen, weil die Realität ist so kompliziert, die sagen einfach, wir nutzen jetzt mal das Wort vertrauen, weil ansonsten wäre es zu kompliziert. Und ich sage, ja, das wird dann nicht einfach nur kompliziert, sondern das ist einfach alles gar nicht.
Das schwingt eigentlich so was mit, bist du eh zu blöd für, beschäftige ich damit nicht, vertraue einfach.
Also wir haben ja auch ein Re-Entry des Problems selbst in der Behandlung dieses Problems.
Und sie, ich glaube, sehr häufig, das sage ich auch schon die ganze Zeit, ich glaube, ich denke.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, bleibt mal bei, ich glaube, wir glauben, wenn wir glauben, glauben wir. Wir müssen da nicht ausweichen in so eine coolere Sympathie.
Warum eigentlich das Wort vertrauen? Es ist ja überall dieses Wort vertrauen da. Und ich habe überlegt, welches Wort meinen die denn sehr häufig, wenn sie von Vertrauen reden? Glauben. Ja, das wäre auf der analytischen Ebene das. Nein, was fordern sie eigentlich ein von, was fordert einen von Schirach ein von der Normalbevölkerung? Dann ist das eigentlich gehorsam. Die wollen eigentlich gehorsam und sagen, die sind so ungezogen geworden, die Bürger. Zum Beispiel, hier haben wir es dann.
Und alle drei Dinge sind passiert. Wir haben also jetzt im Moment dauernd einen Kanzler, der etwas verspricht, was er überhaupt nicht halten kann. Wir können inzwischen mehr Dinge aufzählen, die nicht gehalten worden sind, als die gehalten worden sind. Das Zweite ist, bei den Dingen, die nicht adressiert werden, ist es so, wir haben in unserem Land im Moment ein riesiges strukturelles Problem. Unsere Infrastruktur funktioniert in vielen Bereichen nicht mehr. Wir haben, ich möchte nur, Entschuldigen Sie, wenn ich das so sage, ich möchte nur das Asylrecht nehmen. Wir haben mittlerweile 50 Prozent der Verwaltungsrichter, die ausschließlich mit Asylverfahren beschäftigt sind. Das kann nicht gut gehen auf Dauer. Und das dritte bei der Gerechtigkeit haben wir...
Ja, was haben wir bei der Gerechtigkeit?
Noch mal, entschuldigen Sie, dass ich das so sage.
Keine Angst, ich sitze nicht auf Zensur.
Der dritte Fall ist das Bürgergeld, das vollkommen falsch angepackt worden ist, wo man gesagt hat, man spart Geld. Es geht beim Bürgergeld nicht um Geld, sondern es geht um Gerechtigkeit.
Also Gerechtigkeit, wir sind ja, wir lassen uns jetzt von einem Multimillionär nochmal sagen, wir müssen doch wohl ans Bürgergeld nochmal härter ran, denn es geht ja um Gerechtigkeit.
Ich will einen Podcast empfehlen, natürlich nur über Bande, meine Webseite, weil ich darüber geschrieben habe bei stefanschulz.com, die sogenannte Gegenwart, Ischoma-Mangold und Lars Weißbrot. Die fragen sich, was ist Wahrheit? Dieser Podcast geht anderthalb Stunden. Nach 55 Minuten wird das erste Mal ein inhaltliches Thema genannt. Ich gehe auf meiner Seite das ganze Name-Dropping einmal durch. Drei Absätze lang von Pontius Pilatius über den Papst, über was auch immer, wer schon mal und so weiter. So, und original eine Sekunde nachdem Ischoma Mangold das Thema benennt, ruft Lars Weißbrot, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, schon hast du einen Fehler gemacht. So, also vermeiden sie dann für die nächste halbe Stunde wieder irgendwelche Themen, reden über das Abstrakte, kommen am Ende noch mal auf Thomas de Maizière, der irgendwas zur Asyl und so gesagt, zack, schon wieder, ja. Nach 30 Sekunden Ischoma Mangold so, ah, jetzt verbrennen wir uns wieder das Thema an so einer politischen Diskussion, wir wollten ja eigentlich gar nicht so, weißt du? So, also, Themen, das ist wirklich, die Leute schweben immer über so Sachen, ja, wenn nicht über Vertrauen geredet wird. Das V stimmt, aber die Frage ist, was wird hier gerade vermieden? Ja, ja, und wenn dann jemand wie Schirach einfach da sitzt und sagt, ich lasse mich gerne einladen, ich rede zum Thema Vertrauen, und dann kommt aber nach drei Sekunden schon absolute tagespolitische Einlassung.
Bürgergeld.
Das Bürgergeld. Die Asylprozesse. Absurd einfach. Das ist wirklich bescheuert.
Wie retten wir die Demokratie?
Das Kompromisse-Machen verlernt.
Nein, überhaupt nicht. Das Problem liegt, glaube ich, an einer völlig anderen Stelle. Also, wir gehen mal einen Schritt zurück. Die Pharaonen regierten 3.000 Jahre. Das Imperium Romanum gab es 1.000 Jahre. Die Harpsburger waren 650 Jahre. Unsere Demokratie ist gerade mal 80 Jahre alt. Und es ist gar nicht überraschend, dass man diese Demokratie reformieren muss. In vielfältiger Weise. Und zwar nicht nur ein kleines Stückchen irgendwo hinten dran kleben oder so etwas, sondern ganz grundlegend. Und eine der grundlegenden Dinge, die man reformieren muss.
Ja, was sind die grundlegenden Dinge?
Das ist ganz schlimm. Die Pharaonen und Rom lebten ja, also das gab es ja 1.000 und 3.000 Jahre.
Ja, da hat die Bevölkerung aber gehorcht. Die wusste nämlich.
Es ist wie politische Entscheidungen umgesetzt werden können. Wir leben in einer anderen Welt als 1950. Es ist viel schneller geworden. Und die Herausforderungen sind viel größer geworden. Und wir haben aber dieselben alten...
Die Herausforderungen sind größer geworden. Ich denke mal, wir hatten den Kalten Krieg. Deutschland wurde durch eine Mauer geteilt. Das ist ja jetzt nicht eine kleine Herausforderung in meinen Augen.
1950, ne?
Armut. Ohne Ende. Aufbau.
1950 sind die Leute vor den Reichstag gegangen, um da ihre Kartoffeln zu ernten. In der Hoffnung, dass sie nicht schon jemand grün aus dem Boden zieht, bevor sie fertig sind. So, das war die Herausforderung. Heute ist die Herausforderung, nämlich jetzt Gemini oder Claude, um irgendwie mein Leben zu vereinfachen und so. Also das kann man auch alles mal ein bisschen...
Das ist ein Mechanismus, mit dem wir arbeiten müssen. Ich würde, wenn ich darf, etwas völlig anderes vorschlagen. Ich würde sagen, machen Sie eine große Grundgesetzreform. Sagen Sie, der Kanzler muss sieben Jahre gewählt werden, danach nicht mehr. Machen Sie alle Landtagswahlen am selben Tag, nach dreieinhalb Jahren. Und machen Sie dann, das würde noch so ein bisschen, was nützt aber noch nicht ganz viel.
Darüber kann man ja reden, ob man die Landtagswahlen mehr zusammenbündelt, dass man aus einem Wahlkampfvodos rauskommt. Diesen Vorschlag gibt es ja von vielen. Ich glaube, den hat auch Omit Nouri pur mal gemacht. Von Precht gab es sowas in der Art auch schon mal. Was er aber jetzt hier schon mal sagt ist, sieben Jahre kann es das Schaffen danach nicht mehr gewählt werden. Damit wird ja so getan, als sei das nur der Grund des Machterhalts, warum jetzt gerade so oder so taktiert wird. Wir haben jetzt zum Beispiel in der letzten Merkel-Ära gesehen, wo sie frühzeitig angekündigt hatte, ich bin nicht mehr dabei, dass sie trotzdem nichts mehr gemacht hat. Also im Gegenteil, sie hat dann noch weniger gemacht als davor.
Ich habe eh einen anderen Vorschlag.
Das ist ja völliger Unsinn, das zu glauben.
Also Herr Schirach kommt mit der großen, wie eben schon gesagt, ich komme zum Thema Vertrauen und so in die größte Sendung. Ich komme nur in die größten Sendungen Deutschlands, unter jeden Fall zum Thema Vertrauen. Und über die anderen Themen sage ich nichts. Und dann ja, unendliche Einlassungen zum Thema Gaza, Palästina und so weiter. Und hier zum Thema jetzt plötzlich Bürgergeld und wie wir das mit dem Kanzler machen. Also diese Idee mal ernst genommen. Sieben Jahre Kanzlerschaft und Midterm Election. Weil mal sieben Jahre Kanzlerschaft. Wieso machen wir nicht einfach acht Jahre draus und fragen in der Mitte nochmal die Bevölkerung, ob sie das nochmal bestätigen möchte? Ziehen eine Notbremse ein. Das ist das amerikanische Modell. Sehen wir gerade in Amerika, das ist wahnsinnig gut funktioniert und wird das auf jeden Fall auch machen müssen. Nein, sehen wir nicht. Sondern das, was wir gerade sehen, ist auch, und ich empfehle sehr, Karl-Rudolf Korte, der bringt es ja nicht einfach nur immer auf den Punkt, sondern er hat ja auch immer recht damit. Das sind ja nicht nur schöne Worte, sondern ist ja auch immer der, der immer recht hat.
Muss sagen, wer das ist, nicht jeder Kind hin.
Karl-Rudolf Korte ist ein Professor für Politik, der vor allem dadurch auffällt, dass er viel im Fernsehen auftaucht. Beim CDF lässt sich jemand mal zuschalten oder ist im Studio und erklärt dann kurz. Und er war jetzt beim Deutschlandfunk dieser Corbinian Frenzel Sendung, die da mit Tachsimer kommt und so. Und er beschreibt Folgendes. Das Problem, was wir gerade beobachten, ist ein Bruch mit unserer Sehgewohnheit. Wir haben keinen Kanzler mehr, der einfach eine Entscheidung trifft und danach wird nur noch ausgeführt. Sondern das Parlament selbst trifft mittlerweile Entscheidungen. Und das Parlament besteht nun mal aus mehreren Gruppen. Und es sind nicht einfach nur Fraktionen, sondern gibt es auch mal eine junge Union, die einfach sagt, wir sind ja auch 18 Leute. Und wir sind kriegsentscheidend, weil ohne uns keine Mehrheit. Das bedeutet, Deutschland hat gerade auch die Chance zu sagen, wir entledigen uns mal von diesem, wir haben den Kanzler eh nur so halb eingeführt, außer Angst davor, dass wieder ein Hitler kommt. Wir machen auf gar keinen Fall ein präsidiales System. Und erst recht nicht, er mächtigen wir jemanden auf sieben Jahre. Sondern wir sagen einfach, okay, wir wählen dich heute, kannst einen Tag Party machen und danach schießen wir dich kotz und klein. Weil hier bestimmt das Parlament. So, ja, und diesen Weg kann man auch mal weitergehen. Ganz richtig. Dass man nicht die ganze Zeit leidet darunter, dass März zu schwach ist und es nicht hinkriegt. Wir sehen offensichtlich, dass März der totale Loser ist, der wirklich nichts gebacken kriegt. Jeder wäre ein besserer Kanzler als, und ich meine nicht jeder Politiker, sondern jeder Mensch von der Straße nach Los verfahren, würde das besser machen. So, was wir jetzt gerade sehen, ist eine Ermächtigung des Parlaments. Und damit eine Ermächtigung von jedem Einzelnen, der es schafft, 18 Leute hinter sich zu versammeln.
Und das ist nicht eine Krise der Demokratie.
Genau, das ist gut.
Das ist keine Krise der Demokratie. Ich meine, ich vertrete nicht die Position der Jungen Union da in der Sache der Rente.
Ich auch nicht, aber das Prinzip finde ich toll.
Aber das Prinzip ist gut. Aber Schirach hat dann andere Ideen, denn es bleibt ja nicht bei diesen sieben Jahren. Pass auf, du kennst es aus dem Märchen. Man hat in der Regel drei Wünsche frei.
Das, was fast nutzen würde, wäre etwas, was ich jetzt mal Kanzlergesetze nennen würde. Der Kanzler hat die Möglichkeit, drei Gesetze in diesen sieben Jahren ohne das Parlament zu verabschieden. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht prüft diese Gesetze, bevor sie in Kraft treten in einem Normenkontrollverfahren. Und das Parlament hat nach drei Jahren die Möglichkeit, diese Gesetze wieder abzuschaffen.
Und was ist, wenn dieser Supreme Court einfach sagt, wir winken dir alles durch, wir geben dir gottgleiche Rechte, dann haben vier Leute in Deutschland einfach entschieden, was jetzt Sache ist für die nächsten sieben Jahre und man hat drei Freischüsse, um Gesetze Scheiß zu machen.
Und so hat man die Demokratie gerettet, indem man sie ein bisschen abschafft.
Was sind denn das für Verbesserungsvorschläge?
Ist der Wahnsinn, oder?
Das diskutieren die gerade im Fernsehen abends.
Also man kann ja mal nicht zu den Pfarrerohren gehen, sondern mal eine historische Perspektive einnehmen, wenn man das dann mal möchte. Vielleicht können wir mal ganz kurz zu meinem allerletzten Clip zu diesem Thema springen, denn es passt jetzt gerade so gut, wir sind so wunderbar in Rage. Und zwar ist das der Clip 2, 9, noch ein bisschen runter, schau doch mal, 2, 9, 4. Ich freu mich dir hier auch.
Ich will noch mal anmerken, wenn man jetzt Comedyprogramm schreibt, könnte man das so gestalten, der Moderator fragt Herr Schirach, können Sie sich zu dem Thema äußern? Er sagt nein, und ich möchte noch anfügen, also bei meinem Namen, und als Proante kommt dann nichts zu Gaza, sondern wir sollten einen Kanzler auf sieben Jahre ermächtigen und ihn drei Freischüsse geben. Das ist die Lehre von Herrn Schirach. Sorry, aber das ist doch Comedy.
Ja, und höchst geschichtsvergessen, so scheint mir doch, weil Tilo war ein Historiker zu Gast, der Adelsexperte ist, Leonhard Horovsky, und der führt unglaublich viel aus, was man so alles über die Adligen sagen kann und bislang noch nicht wusste. Sehr interessant. Jedenfalls gibt es da so eine Passage, da geht es dann, nachdem man sagte, ja, es gibt ja auch in England zum Beispiel anti-monarchistische Bestrebungen, sagt er, ja, er sei kein Monarchist. Aber folgendes.
Wahrscheinlich das beste Argument, also ich bin kein Monarchist, um Gottes Willen, aber, aber wenn man drüber nachdenkt, gibt es ein Argument, zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt Brite wäre und also in einer Monarchie lebte und sich fragen müsste, was machen wir jetzt damit? Und dann kann ich jeden verstehen, der sagt, wir wollen das lieber abschaffen. Aber das eine denkbare Argument zugunsten der Monarchie ist, sie füllt einen Platz aus, der sonst von jemand anderem gefüllt werden wird. Und sie füllt ihn aus mit Leuten, die durch Erbschaft rekrutiert sind und die also definitionsgemäß, ich will nicht sagen unfähig sind, aber die sind nicht dahin gekommen, weil sie so einen Machttrieb haben, weil sie gierig sind nach Macht.
Also wir sind hier nicht im Modus Rutger Brichmann, die Mächtigen, die schamlos sind und all das.
Natürlich kann theoretisch da auch immer mal einer sein, der auf die Idee kommen könnte, ich könnte ja alle Institutionen umstürzen, um wirklich wieder die Herrschaft zu haben, statt nur die Dekorfigur an der Spitze zu sein. Das ist aber statistisch unwahrscheinlich. Nicht zuletzt, weil er ja so auch schon oder gelegentlich dann sie auch schon eine ganz angenehme Position hat. Wenn man diesen Platz freiräumt, indem man die Monarchie abschafft, dann kann man sagen, wir schaffen uns so eine Art Staatsnotar an, wie die Bundesrepublik ihn hat, dann ist es halt der Steinmeier. Ja, kann man machen. Aber natürlich steht eben dann auch die Möglichkeit oder das Risiko im Raum, dass dieser Platz dann immer noch mal eines Tages in die Hand kommt von jemandem, der dann diese Ich-verkörper-den-Staat-ich-bin-die-Nation-Rolle, die eben ein amerikanischer Präsident hat, ungünstigerweise, missbraucht. Und der dann, weil, wenn dann eine solche Rolle länger schon existiert wie in den USA, wo ja diese Präsidentschaft eben von Anfang an so eine große Rolle hat, der dann auch behandelt wird, als sei er ein König, den man zum Beispiel nicht mal dann auf die Schnelle anklagen kann, wenn er gerade versucht hat, durch einen offensichtlichen Putschversuch die Demokratie mehr oder weniger abzuschaffen am 6. Januar.
Ja, und deshalb ist genau das, was du jetzt eben sagtest, eigentlich den Parlamentarismus zu stärken, das entscheidende Konzept. Ja, einen König können wir jetzt nicht wieder herholen, aber man muss eigentlich sagen, das sind Demokratisierungsbewegungen. Aber Schirach begibt sich jetzt wieder nach diesem wunderbaren Reformvorschlag hinein in die Realpolitik.
Ja.
Man muss einfach sagen und das wissen inzwischen ja alle, die Asylpolitik, so wie sie gedacht ist und wie sie in dem Land durchgeführt ist, funktioniert schlicht nicht. Und zwar das Land hat es großartig gemacht, das muss man auch erst mal sagen. Wir haben mehr Flüchtlinge aufgenommen als jedes andere westliche Land und das war eine wirkliche Großtat und dafür muss man sich nicht schämen, sondern das Gegenteil, darauf kann man stolz sein. Aber wir müssen sehen, dass die Infrastruktur inzwischen vollkommen überfordert ist. Wir können nicht sagen, wir nehmen noch mehr auf. Wir können nicht sagen...
Das ist ein eiserndes Gesetz, das geht einfach nicht mehr.
Ralf Bollmann, ich glaube, der schreibt für die FAZ, kann sein. hat diese großen Merkel Biografie geschrieben. Und er war jetzt in meinem SWR Kultur Forum, meiner Lieblingssendung, zu Gast und sagte dort, ich habe den Clip auch, aber ich suche ihn jetzt nicht raus, können wir später mal spielen. Dass wir 2020, 2021, 2022 durch die große Lücke in der Versorgung kamen, also durch die Pandemie, dass plötzlich doch noch Brötchen geschmiert wurden, Pakete ausgetragen wurden und so weiter. Dass Deutschland noch funktioniert hat in dieser Krisenzeit, ist nur durch einen Umstand zu erklären. Flüchtlinge 2015, hätte es diese Leute nicht gegeben in Deutschland, wäre hier ausgewesen. So und nein, wir haben nicht eine kaputte Infrastruktur, die die Flüchtlinge nur dank dieses Zuzugs, haben wir überhaupt noch ein Restinfrastruktur. Ja, so rum muss man das sehen. Und von daher, lieber Herr Schirach, dieses ganze Argument mit, wir sind alle überfordert, weil die Richter so viel damit zu tun haben. Warum haben die Richter so viel damit zu tun? Weil die ganzen Bescheidescheiße sind. Die kommen einfach scheiße aus dieser Verwaltung und die Verwaltung denkt sich, kann auch das Justizwesen klären. Das hat mit den Flüchtlingen gar nichts zu tun.
Es geht nur in diese Richtung und natürlich wird auch noch folgender Herr zitiert.
Ja, sehr gut.
Tatsächlich ist es so, wie Gauk das mal gesagt hat, unser frühere Bundespräsident. Unser Herz ist weit, aber unsere Möglichkeiten sind beschränkt. Und das muss man sagen und dann kriegt man die AfD auch, weil das wollen die Leute und man muss es dann eben auch tun.
Genau, das Gegenteil ist wahr.
Wir sollen jetzt die AfD abschieben, also was ja schon die ganze Zeit geschieht. Denn dann bekommt man die Leute wieder zurück. Also dieser Kurs, der jetzt die ganze Zeit fehlt, schlägt, weil die AfD wunderbare Erfolge hat. Und trotzdem, man die ganze Zeit ihre Politik macht, tragen sie immer noch die Erfolge davon. Hier ja auch nochmal diese Idee davon, dass es da keine, dass es eine Knappheit gibt. Die Knappheit ist ja produziert, wie wir wissen. Also er könnte ja sagen, ja wir hätten 100 Milliarden mehr mobilisieren müssen, Zwecksintegration und all das. Das wäre ja noch eine Antwort gewesen auf irgendwas. Aber nein.
Ich möchte eine Pointe machen. Schaltet jetzt bitte die Videokameras ein. Also lieber nur der Koch, bitte mach einen Clip hier von. Deutschland kann alles schaffen. Wir könnten alles schaffen. Leider sind unsere Herzen beschränkt. Ja. Gauck hat genau falsch rum den Spruch gemacht.
Ja, ganz richtig. Joska versucht es mit einem Themenwechsel Social Media.
Um die Gefahr, dass Algorithmen Dinge immer wieder hervorspulen, die nicht der Wahrheit entsprechen. Und Sie erinnern daran im Zusammenhang in Ihrem neuen Buch, der Stille Freund, da erinnern Sie an George Orwells Vision von 1984. Das Wahrheitsministerium bei Orwell, das sagte, dass man, dass die Wahrheit nur das Gegenteil der Wahrheit geglaubt werden kann, dass Vergangenheiten verändert werden, dass Tatsachen nicht mehr gelten. Perfektionieren die sozialen Medien aus ihrer Sicht das, was Orwells damals schon beschrieb?
So, Gauck, Orwell, Rohm, die Pharaone.
Er sagte übrigens Ja.
Ja. JK. Rowling.
Und er sagte ja noch, wir brauchen unbedingt ein Gesetz, dass die Politiker zur Wahrheit verpflichtet sind.
Unbedingt. Unbedingt. Hier Widersprüche werden nicht aufgedröselt, weil wir müssen einfach vertrauen, weißt du?
Ja.
JK. Rowling hat sehr viel Erfolg damit gehabt, indem sie einfach sagte, ich schreibe Belletristik. Was brauche ich? Ein Märchenschloss, ein verwunschenen Wald, ein Zauberstab, eine Winkelgasse. So schreibt Schirach auch seine Bücher. Was brauche ich? Faraon, Rom, Gauck, Orwell. Wir sollten das Buch lesen und dann einfach einen Katalog zusammenstellen. Sachregister, Ideenregister. Was kommt da drin vor?
Absolut.
Tun Sie, klar.
Na, wie groß ist die Gefahr?
Also ich halte die Gefahr für riesig, für viel größer, als wir das uns im Moment vorstellen können. Diese Tech-Konzerne haben die besten Psychologen der Welt dort sitzen. Sie überlegen von morgens bis abends, wie kann ich die Leute auf der Plattform halten. Wir wissen inzwischen ganz gruselige Dinge. Also zum Beispiel weiß Facebook vor ihnen, ob sie schwanger sind oder nicht, weil sie bestimmte Sachen anschauen und eben Millionen anderer Schwangere das anschauen, können die dann ungefähr sagen, sehr wahrscheinlich...
Ja, den Artikel hatte ich 2011 auch gelesen.
Ja. Sie wissen vor ihnen, bevor sie sich outen, über ihre sexuelle Orientierung. Ja, lauter solche Dinge.
Ja, Moment mal. Also das ist ja nun wirklich Unsinn. Also man weiß ja von seiner sexuellen Orientierung in der Regel vor seinem Outing, sonst würde man ja nicht zu einem Outing übergehen. Und das ist ja so logisch, dass ein Konzern, der mit Bildmaterial zum Beispiel arbeitet, sehen kann, ob da jemand lieber Jungs oder Mädchen mag. Ja, da wüsste ich jetzt nicht, wo das Novum liegt oder ich weiß noch nicht, was daran jetzt so besonders sein soll, dass man sagt, oh Gott, das will diese Unendliche macht.
Ja, also dieser Diskurs ist, wie du eben schon sagtest, seit 2011 anders eigentlich. Denn wir wissen mittlerweile, wann Technik richtig gut funktioniert. Google Maps schickt uns keine Umwege, um uns länger in der App zu halten. Google Mail sortiert für uns den ganzen Scheiß, den wir nicht sehen wollen, aus. Das ist der große Vorteil dieser Technologie. Ja, es gibt diese Newsfeeds und die muss man halt ganz gezielt kritisieren. Und irgendwann werden wir das auch machen. Ich empfehle wirklich sehr den Podcast Haken dran, weil da wird mehrfach die Woche einfach und zwar wirklich im Detail. Ich habe eine riesige Pointensammlung, die gehen wir irgendwann einfach mal durch von A bis Z, wo wie mit Kindern, Jugendlichen und so weiter im Internet umgegangen wird. Das hat alles, also diese Idee von das Internet, Quelle Internet, Social Media ist ein riesiges Problem und so. Nein, also das muss man sich wirklich im Detail anschauen. Und auch unter pragmatischen Gesichtspunkten, wir kriegen es ja nicht wieder weg.
Ja.
Also so omni wie diese Kritik ist, kann ja die Lösung nicht sein.
Also so könnte ja dann nur sein, man muss einfach diesen einen Schalter umlegen und dann haben wir kein Internet mehr.
Genau, wir machen einfach Strom aus.
Ja.
Züge fahren wieder zehn Gramm Haar, damit die Seele nicht den Körper verlässt.
Und alles, ja, am Ende sieht man auch fremde Menschen, wenn man in Intercity unterwegs ist. Das geht ja gar nicht. So diskutieren die.
Aber die Wahlen.
Ach, die Wahlen.
Wir müssen nur eine Situation finden, wo wir auf der einen Seite zwischen Zensur entscheiden und auf der anderen Seite zwischen möglichst großer Meinungsfreiheit. Ich möchte ja, dass die Leute alles sagen, was sie sagen wollen. Das ist ja besser, sie tun das. Aber wir müssen es trotzdem sehen, dass es enorm gefährlich ist, weil sie einfach Wahlen beeinflussen können. Und zwar so, dass der Nutze der sozialen Medien das überhaupt nicht merkt.
Der Nutzer auch des Fernsehens merkt nicht, wie er die ganze Zeit beeinflusst wird. Und damit hören wir auf mit Mioska. Sie leitet über.
Gutes Schlusswort. Ich muss den Weg zu Ingo Zamparoni zu den Tagesthemen finden. Ingo, was macht ihr?
Wir schauen noch mal auf den Streit in der Union um das Rentenpaket. Da gab es ja bei seinem Auftritt bei der Jungen Union gestern, da hat der Bundeskanzler Friedrich Merz die Pläne der Bundesregierung zur Rente ja noch mal verteidigt. Aber wie er die Kluft zum Parteinachwuchs ist auch wichtig für die Abstimmung im Bundestag, bei dem Thema noch überbrücken will, das und mehr gleich bei uns in den Tagesthemen.
Bei diesem Thema findet die ganze Zeit eine Beeinflussung statt. Und die Leute merken das gar nicht. Sie denken die ganze Zeit, ach ja, genau, die Jungen, endlich kämpfen sie mal für die Jungen. Es ist ein Generationenkonflikt und wir sehen natürlich dann deutlich, es ist ein Umverteilungskonflikt. Wir kommen gleich auf die Rente noch mal zu sprechen, dann bei Schirach. Aber zu sagen, das ist über die sozialen Medien. Ja, ja, der hat dann natürlich auch eine ganz großartige Idee.
Ja, also Maurice Höfgen hat, ich glaube, heute Nacht oder so kam ein Newsletter von ihm. Es geht nicht um zu wenig Kinder, zu viele Alte, sondern es geht um Arm und Reich.
Genau.
Und wir kommen ja immer wieder darauf heute zurück, also sowieso in diesem Podcast. Ja. Das ist hier natürlich auch...
Da ist ja permanente Manipulation, die stattfindet ganz ohne sozialen Medien. Das macht das Öffentlich-Rechtliche ganz allein.
Ja, das Ding ist so ein bisschen, in der Demokratie selbst ist der Erfolgsmechanismus einprogrammiert, nämlich solange Wahlterminen stattfinden, ist alles in Ordnung. Das ist ein bisschen wie, wir reden immer von Wirtschaftskrise und tun so, als würde Geld nicht mehr funktionieren. Aber Geld funktioniert immer. Wirtschaftskrise ist nur, irgendwer hat irgendwelche Ansprüche, die gerade nicht befriedigt werden und so. Dann reden alle von Wirtschaftskrise ist schrumpft. So, die Demokratie funktioniert immer, außer Wahlen werden abgeschafft. Zwischen den Wahlen finden dann halt Wahlkämpfe statt. Und da kann man jetzt ein bisschen Social Media reintun in sein Leben oder rausnehmen oder Fernsehen rein, Fernsehen raus. Oder je nachdem, ob man Tockel, der hat Tockel rein, Tockel raus. Diese Diskussion kann man alle führen. Aber die Demokratie ist nicht in Gefahr, solange Wahlen stattfinden. So, und das ist der Erfolgsmechanismus. Und wenn alles, und das ist eben dieser tolle Mechanismus, wenn alles rundherum nach Krise aussieht, da kannst du das nicht mehr so mächtig wie vorher. Im Parlament streiten sie nur noch. Jetzt gibt es 18 Leute, die haben gar keine Fraktionsstärke, tun aber trotzdem so, als wären sie wichtig, wie auch immer. Das ist ja alles scheißegal. Es gibt Wahltermine, es gibt Abstimmung, da wird durchgezählt, das Ergebnis wird aufgeschrieben, fertig ist. Und dann geht's weiter.
Moment, das ist ja eine Definition, wie man sie in etwa so auch bei Schummpeter vorfindet. Jetzt sagen aber Leute wie von Schirach und einige andere, ich denke auch Schiritz ginge in diese Richtung. Nein, wir müssen ja die liberale Demokratie schützen. Und die bedeutet ja Vertrauen in die Institutionen, damit alles den Gang weitergehen kann, wie es immer war. Und da sagst du zu Recht, na ja, das ist eine Definition von Demokratie. Aber Demokratie eigentlich meint, dass es regelmäßige Wahlen gibt. Und entsprechend gibt es die Kämpfe davor, wer wird gewählt. Und dabei werden alle möglichen Wege gesucht, Wähler zu erreichen. Und ja, da gibt es aber überall Manipulation, beziehungsweise wird die Unwahrheit gesagt, werden Dinge vertuscht, was auch immer. Aber das ist jetzt nicht grundsätzlich eine Krise der Demokratie.
Genau. Und ich will auch ausdrücklich darauf hinweisen, dass die AfD so viele Nichtwähler reinholt, ist sehr gut, denn ohne, dass die AfD so riesig im Parlament säße, würden die anderen Fraktionen die ja einfach wegnahe ignorieren. Und jetzt plötzlich machen die sich Gedanken, wie können wir die denn noch erreichen? Müssen wir jetzt auch beim Wahlkampf irgendwas machen und so? Und das ist alles gut. Das sieht nur aus nach Krise, aber das unterstreicht die Funktionstüchtigkeit dieses Systems.
Ja, man hat ja die ganze Zeit die Nichtwähler ignoriert, hat sich noch ein bisschen über die lustig gemacht und das war's.
Und da Nichtwähler überkommuniert haben mit ihrer politischen Handlungsfähigkeit, mit ihrer ökonomischen, haben halt solche Leute wie Schirach und so das einfach sehr genossen, ihr Partikulares, also Hauptsache mir geht es gut, durchzupauken, Hauptsache meine Bücher werden verkauft. Ich möchte nicht, dass davon was geändert wird. Am Ende sind auch meine Buchverkäufe in Gefahr und ich werde nicht mehr eingeladen oder was auch immer. Ja, das ist natürlich jetzt bedroht, aber das ist keine Krise der Demokratie. Das ist eine Krise von Ferdinand von Schirach.
Wo könnte man noch hingehen, wenn man schon bei Lanz und Myoska war? Natürlich zu Paul Ronsheimer.
Es gibt einen Gast, den ich mir schon ganz lange gewünscht habe, weil ich das verfolge, was er schreibt, wie er im Fernsehen debattiert und ich hänge dann an den Lippen dieses Gastes und ich freue mich, dass er heute bei mir zu Gast ist, Ferdinand von Schirach.
Sie reden also auch über Vertrauen und warum klappt denn so vieles nicht mehr hin und her. Wann war der Punkt da, an dem Schirach sagte, ne, der hier ist in dem Land, da stimmt da was nicht mehr.
Und was diese Krisen, in denen wir jetzt sind, glaube ich recht deutlich zeigen, ist, dass man etwas verändern muss und zwar etwas Grundlegendes und nicht so ein Flickwerk hinten und vorne ein bisschen was dran kleben und oben ein bisschen etwas wegschneiden. Das funktioniert nicht mehr, sondern wir müssen angesichts dieser enormen Zeitenwende, die ja in allen möglichen Bereichen stattfindet und die den Leuten auch mir Sorgen macht, weil unser bisheriges Leben so wahrscheinlich nicht weiterzuführen ist, dem muss sich eine Demokratie anpassen und unsere Demokratie ist anpassungsfähig und wir können das machen. Wir müssen es nur wollen und irgendwann auch anfangen.
Sie haben gerade die Finanzkrise genannt, wo sie das erstmals Gefühl hatten, da verändert sich was. Es gab weitere Ereignisse und die nahe nach vollen, die sie genannt haben, die Migrationskrise, sicherlich Corona, der Ukraine-Krieg. Aber gab es so einen Moment für sie, wo sie gedacht haben, das geht gerade nicht mehr in die richtige Richtung in Deutschland?
Ja, also da sitzt ein Typ, ich sage jetzt mal im Fernsehen, bei Bild und sagt im Rücken noch sein Name und so, Schirach. Man kann die Pointe immer nur wiederholen, ja, aber jetzt hat er Flickwerk gesagt. So, da sitzen Leute im Parlament, die machen ihre Arbeit. Die schreiben Gesetze, die gehen das durch, die beschaffen Mehrheiten. Ja, dann kommt es zu Turbulenzen, weil junge Leute sagen, sorry, aber euer Rentending und so, das funktioniert so nicht. Und dann kommen viele und sagen, ja, die haben irgendwie so recht. Und tausend partikulare Interessen, ja, kommen jetzt zu diesem Bild zusammen. Und ich würde ja sagen, beraumt die Abstimmung an, macht die Abstimmung. Wenn ihr es im Parlament nicht hinkriegt, müssen wir Wähler halt neu wählen oder was auch immer, wenn da keine Mehrheitsbildung möglich ist. So, und dann kommt er und sagt immer noch im Rückblick mit dem, also mein Familienname ist Schirach, ich will diesen politischen Fleckenteppich nicht mehr haben. Ich will die große Lösung. Während überall, wo er zu Gast ist, ansonsten der Tenor ist, also wenn immer die Leute mit ihren einfachen Antworten kommen und nur einen starken Mann suchen und so, das ist immer blöd. Aber Schirach, ich hänge an seinem Lippen, der soll in meinem Podcast bitte sagen, weg mit dem Flickenteppich. Ich brauch den großen, starken Mann, sieben Jahre, drei Freischüsse.
Er führt das dann da auch noch mal aus, das spielen wir jetzt nicht ab. Absurd. Aber wir kommen zu dem Punkt, an dem Schirach sagte, hier geht es nicht mehr weiter.
Ich habe das gedacht, also das ist so eine Winzigkeit im Grunde genommen, aber ich habe das gedacht bei der Verteilung der Impfstoffe. Ich habe gedacht, das kann doch nicht wahr sein, dass wir es in diesem Land nicht fertigbringen, die Impfstoffe in jedes Geschäft zu bringen und zu jedem Arzt zu bringen. Und damals habe ich mir auch gedacht, wenn ich Angela Merkel in dem Moment gewesen wäre, dann hätte ich die Leute angerufen, die das jeden Tag machen. Also keine Ahnung, Edeka und Lidl und alle möglichen anderen, die Drogeriemärkte, die das können und hätte gefragt, dann hätte ich gesagt, pass mal auf, unsere Beamten sind dafür da, dass sie sehr gut sind in der Verwaltung, aber das können sie nicht.
Hat er nicht eben noch gesagt, bitte kein Flickenteppich? Und bei Corona, das hat man ja viel zu zentral gelöst, das hätte man im Flickenteppich machen müssen. Also bei Edeka schult man jetzt den Filialeiter, wir eine Ecke einrichten, damit dann ein Arzt da hängt oder soll der selber die Spritze geben oder was auch immer. Die Idee, das zentral über in der Messe Frankfurt Halle 1 ist das Impfzentrum und da fahren wir alle hin, wir wissen genau, wo das ist und dann ist da eine Schlange und da steht man an, das war doch die genialste Idee ever in so einer Situation.
Ich verstehe auch gar nicht, was er meint. Also das Problem war ja die Knappheit der Impfstoffe.
Das ist was ganz anderes als das, was er eben gesagt hat.
Also es war ja nicht so, dass die Impfstoffe in Berlin lagerten und man sagte, puh, wir wissen gar nicht, wer die ausliefert, sondern die Impfstoffe waren ja nicht in ausreichender Zahl da, deshalb hat man angefangen, erst mal mit den ganz Alten und hat dort erstmal den Zentren und irgendwann hatten dann auch die Hausarzt die Impfstoffe bekommen, zumal ja die nicht bei EDEKA hätten verkauft werden können. Man konnte sie sich ja nicht selbst spritzen, sondern sie mussten gekühlt und entsprechend gespritzt werden. Da haben wir damals auch diskutiert, muss das unbedingt ein Arzt sein, könnte das nicht auch anderes Personal tun. Da haben manche gesagt, nein, auf keinen Fall, ich bin der Ansicht und andere waren es ja dann auch. Nein, das hätte durchaus auch Sprechstunden helfen und sonst, wir hätten das machen können. Das sind alles Dinge, über die man da diskutieren kann. Aber hier zu sagen, das hätte man über den Edeka-Chef oder so regeln können. Nein, man hätte es ja nicht ins Regal stellen können. Zumal Edeka und sonst was, die haben nicht mit Knappheiten zu tun. Die haben einen großen Markt, dann können die überlegen, gut, wie viel von dem Käse brauchen wir und wie viel brauchen wir da. Und dann stellen die das ins Geschäft und dann wird es gekauft. Und es gab auch, vor allem musste man ja die Nachfrage organisieren so, dass die Menschen, die besonders vulnerabel waren, zuerst daran kamen. Ein Edeka ist anders aufgebaut oder ein Lidl. Dort geht man einfach hin und wer zahlungsfähig ist, bekommt das Zeugs. Da geht es nicht so, dass man sagt, Herr Schmitt, Sie sehen eh so gesund aus, für Sie gibt es heute kein Obst. Das kriegt jetzt erstmal die Oma. Das gibt es ja da nicht. Von daher ist also dieser Vergleich hirnrissig.
Ja, es ist absolut absurd. Corona, und das ist jetzt mal ein echtes Vertrauensthema, im wirklich tiefgehend soziologischen Sinne. Corona bedeutete nicht einfach nur, dass die Leute einen materiellen Virus in sich hatten, sondern die hatten auch einen kognitiven. Die Leute hatten Angst, es gab so eine Unbestimmtheit. Alle haben Drossen gehört. Und bei Drossen, es war nicht die inhaltliche Aufklärung, sondern es war einfach, da spricht die Koryphäe. Du verstehst zwar nicht, was ich sage, aber so.
Wir sind in der Sphäre des Glaubens.
Genau. So, zu Corona-Pandemie wollten die Menschen den Staat sehen. Sie wollten das Impfzentrum sehen. Und sie haben es wirklich nur akzeptiert als größte Einrichtung der Stadt. Temporär, aber es musste die größte Einrichtung der Stadt sein. Da musste völlig klar sein, wenn ich da hinfahre, da steht schon mal eine Polizei, da wird auch nicht organisiert, da leuchten Lampen, da ist was, da ist was gebaut einfach. Diese Idee zu sagen, wir wissen, du bist so unsicher, es gibt so einen Impfstoff, wir hoffen, dein Edeka kriegt das irgendwie hin. Und dann kommst du da so hin und musst dich so durchfragen und keine Ahnung, bin ich schon dran? Und dann sagen die so, sagt irgend so ein Typ so, nee, sie sind noch nicht dran, sie müssen jetzt wieder nach Hause. Und ja, also diese ganze Idee, wie er spricht komplett seiner Denke mit Vertrauen, Staat, Flickenteppich.
Ich verstehe auch nicht, also ich mein, wir können jetzt alle mal einen Beamtenwitz machen, aber es ist doch gar nicht so, dass Beamte so etwas nicht können, sondern genau das ist eigentlich deren Aufgabe, solche Dinge auch mit zu organisieren. Sie organisieren ja auch Stadtfeste mit oder sonst was, wo ganz viel bedacht werden kann. Ja, dann kann mal irgendetwas schiefgehen und das ist dann noch der große Skandal, wer ist für was verantwortlich. Aber das ist doch so, dass das eigentlich eine große Aufgabe ist, von Beamten so etwas zu organisieren. Also was soll denn sonst die Aufgabe von Beamten sein?
Und man sieht ja auch, wenn andere Regelungen neu gemacht werden müssen, weil es keinen Präzedenzfall dafür gibt, ist so ein Impfzentrum gar kein Problem für den Staat. Baue da einfach auf. Nur wenn man die ganze Zeit und dann klagt da nochmal einer und hier und da und so, dann wird es halt kompliziert. Was jetzt auch nicht bedeutet, dass man da mit einem großen Herrscher der sieben Jahre drei Freischüsse da drüber bügeln kann. Aber ja, wir könnten es eigentlich aufarbeiten und die Sachen verstehen.
Das Einzige, was man hätte machen können, wäre eigentlich noch mehr Staaten, noch mehr bei der Impfstoffproduktion auf staatliche Bänder setzen. Das hätte man noch viel mehr ausbauen können, hätte man das schneller impfen können. Und unser Anliegen war ja immer, der Welt diese Impfstoffe zu verschenken. Überall werden sie gebraucht und jetzt nicht da, sich klein zu rechnen. Aber auch hier toller Vorschlag, Impfstoffe.
Und dass wir da nicht in der Lage waren, über unseren eigenen Schatten zu springen und einfach sagen, wir rufen jetzt die Leute an, die das machen können. Wir haben es übermorgen verteilt. Das hat mich schon wahnsinnig geärgert.
Die waren nicht da. Sie konnten nicht in zwei Tagen verteilt werden. Sie waren nicht da.
Absurd, das ist wirklich absurd.
Genauso bei dem Einkauf der Impfstoffe. Das fand ich eine ähnliche Situation. Es gibt ja auf der Welt in der Wirtschaft Leute, die nichts anderes machen als einzukaufen. Also der Chefeinkäufer von VW oder von einem anderen Unternehmen. Das sind Leute, die wissen, wie die Isancen, alle Isancen beim Einkaufen sind und warum wir das Beamte haben machen lassen und nicht solche Einkäufer, die das hätten. Das können sie über die Masken sagen oder sonst etwas. Wenn Politiker das machen oder Beamte das machen, ist es halt nicht so professionell, wie wenn das jemand macht, der das jeden Tag macht und der das gut kann.
Also Beamte kaufen doch laufend was ein. Also Staatsaufträge werden vergeben. Es ist doch nicht so, als würde man jetzt zum ersten Mal hätte man das. Und jetzt sollen wir jetzt in die Debatte gehen, ob man drei Euro zu viel für den Impfstoff gezahlt hat, der sich tausendmal ausgezahlt hat. Und dass Jens Spahn irgendeinen komischen Alleingang mit seinen Masken da nochmal gemacht hat. Das ist ja wie ein ganz anderes Problem. Da könnte man ja eigentlich sagen, das war doch nach der Schirach-Logik toll, dass da endlich mal einer alleine vorgeht und man nicht diese ganzen Beamten hat, sondern ich mach das mal mit einem Telefonanruf. Da sehen wir ja schon, wo das Problem dann ist. Und das war ja auch damals unsere Kritik an Esra Klein, der dann so sehr glorifizierte diese Bürgermeister, die jetzt mal sagen, ich machs mal ganz alleine und hör mal auf niemanden, ich brauch nicht noch einen Gutachten, die Brücke wird jetzt so gebaut. Ja, genau das öffnet ja Tür und Tor für so etwas, was wir dann bei Jens Spahn erlebt haben.
Also wir haben eine Staatsquote von 50 Prozent. Das bedeutet, bei der Hälfte von dem, was in Deutschland passiert, hat der Staat. Und das Kräfteverhältnis ist aber ungefähr, auf einen Beamten kommen 35.000 Leute in der Wirtschaft, die die ganze Zeit Bullshit-Shop mäßig da rein funken und auch noch mal hier ein bisschen Budget haben wollen. Würde man den Staat einfach mal machen lassen, ohne diese ganzen...
Ja, da hätte man mehr Leute. Ich hab das jetzt gehört von einem Architekten, der sagte da bei den Baugenehmigungen, es ist einfach ein Personalmangel da. Es sind entsprechende Genehmigungen, die müssen eigentlich längst durchgewunken werden. Es fehlen dann Leute. Also müsste man mehr Leute ausbilden, die das machen. Unzugleich natürlich gewisse Verschlankungen vornehmen. Sicherlich hat man das aufgebläht und da ist ja auch niemand dagegen, das abzuhalten. Aber das Problem sind nicht die Beamten. Und hätte man jetzt die Einkäufer, auch da frage ich mich, wie machen die das dann? Also die Seel-Cross-Metro und so weiter, die tun sich dann zusammen und reden dann mit Biontech und falschen dann oder was?
Völlig absurd. Das lohnt sich gar nicht inhaltlich. Also sobald er diese, also egal auf welcher Ebene, das große abstrakte Vertrauen, irgendwas mit Staat, irgendwas mit Demokratie oder halt die Mühen der Ebene, die er selber als Flickenteppich abqualifiziert. Es macht gar keinen Sinn, irgendwo ein ernsthaftes Gespräch mit Verdinlern von Schirach zu führen.
Wir sind sehr, sehr, sehr langsam mit diesen Dingen. Wir sind sehr genau, aber auch sehr langsam.
Woran liegt das?
Naja, das liegt einfach daran, wie Verwaltung überhaupt funktioniert. Ich kann Ihnen ein Beispiel schildern. Ich war lange Zeit Strafverteidiger und wir hatten im Gericht einen besonderen Wachtmeister und der besondere Wachtmeister war dafür zuständig bei heiklen Verfahren oder bei Sachen, die ganz schnell gehen mussten. Die Akten von einem Zimmer zum anderen zu bringen, das ging trotzdem zwei Tage. Kam dann an und es war alles in Ordnung, es gab Vermerke darüber. Die Langsamkeit in einer Demokratie führt immer auch zur Gerechtigkeit, weil sie sozusagen nicht mit der heißen Nadel nähen, sondern sie überlegen, sie gehen einen Schritt zurück, sie denken darüber nach.
Wir halten fest, wir sind zu langsam und die Langsamkeit ist aber wichtig für die Demokratie. Ja, was denn nun?
Ich würde sagen, alle seine Begriffe müssen auf den Prüfstand, ein Wort, das man auch nicht sagen darf, aber wenn man über Sorgfalt reden müsste, wollte, müsste man halt über Sorgfalt reden. Das kann man nicht verstecken hinter Geschwindigkeit. So, genauso wie man Vertrauen nicht sagen sollte, weil man Glaube meint und so weiter und so fort. Also es muss alles hier mal abgeklopft werden, bei den von Schirach, denn bisher ist es nicht bestsellertauglich. Das sind Kalenderaufbrüche. Das kann man sich als Geschenk Weihnachten geben lassen und dann hängt man sich das hin und dann jeden Tag eine Sekunde lang reißt man Blatt ab. Aber mehr ist nicht gerade. Guck mal, was besser wird.
Erledigen können und sie holen sich Hilfe dazu. Was ist dagegen zu sagen? Wir holen für...
Man soll sich Hilfe dazuholen. Jetzt kommt er aber zugleich.
Jedes idiotische Problem, irgendwelche Unternehmensberater in Ministerien, die dort irgendwas lösen sollen. Das halte ich für uns.
Er hat sich gerade komplett selbst widersprochen und es war noch nicht mal ein zweiter Halbsatz.
Denn das wäre ja wie Unternehmensberatung, wenn ich sage, liebe Chef-Einkäufer, liebe Edeka-Leute, könnt ihr mir mal sagen, wie wir einkaufen, dann ist das Beratung. Dann holt man Beratung, was die Ministerien ja wirklich in einem exorbitanten Ausmaß tun. Aber Berater sind auch falsch.
Das macht alles gar keinen Sinn.
Und deswegen meine ich Deutschdiskurse. Wie kann es sein, dass das jetzt hier als Sternstunde der Philosophie durchgeht? Wie ist das möglich? Also wir sind ja jetzt hier schon auf dem Gipfel der Debattenintelligenz angekommen. Ich halte es nicht mehr aus, in welches Land muss man ziehen, wo es anders ist. Ich weiß es nicht.
Crazy.
Rondsheimer spricht über eine gewisse Trägheit.
Wie viel von dieser Trägheit des Systems, das Sie spüren, dass ich spüre, dass andere mitbekommen, jeder in seinem Alltag, in seinem Beruf, in seinem Umfeld auf unterschiedlichem Weg. Aber wir alle spüren ja, dass da Dinge nicht funktionieren, nicht mehr funktionieren, zu langsam sind, im Vergleich auch zu anderen Ländern.
Wie lange will er das noch ausbauen, diese Floskel?
Ist das nicht schön, wenn jemand über Tragheit so träge spricht?
Es geht jetzt schon 20 Sekunden, ja wirklich. Das ist ja, also dieser Re-Entry, ja, des Problems selbst in seine Behandlung ist ja wirklich bei diesem Schiradding, es infiziert auch alle anderen.
Wie viel von dem hat dazu beigetragen, dass so viele Menschen kein Vertrauen mehr haben in die Parteien, die lange da waren und stattdessen sagen, so, also ich weiß, lass uns den Ball zurückspielen und sagen, die Treckheit, das seid ihr.
Ihr seid die Treckheit, genau. Also wir regen uns ja in diesem Podcast auch immer über Sachen auf, die nicht funktionieren. Das sind die Deutsche Bahn, Honorarabrechnung beim öffentlich-rechtlichen Lohnfunk und so weiter und so fort, ja. Aber in so ein allgemeines Bild auszuufern, wohin soll es denn führen? Also was ist denn die Zielsetzung von dem, was hier so insgesamt gerade stattfindet, das ist doch völlig absurd. Also dieses mehr anderen ist nicht auf dem Punkt, ich sag, also ich will es nochmal wie vorher sagen, bei der Demokratie und auch bei der Wirtschaft. Wirtschaftskrise und Krise der Demokratie sehen wir nicht. Geld funktioniert einfach, dass es falsch verteilt ist. Ja, das ist aber keine Wirtschaftskrise. Das ist eine Verteilungskrise. Das ist Armutskrise. Das ist ein soziales Problem. Aber Geld funktioniert. So, die Demokratie funktioniert auch. Wir haben Wahltermine. Wir können es also einfach drauf ankommen lassen. Wenn ein Kanzler irgendetwas sagt und ich sage, sorry, alter Mann, ich verstehe dich einfach nicht, und dann kommt jemand und sagt, aber wenn sie jetzt wirklich ehrlich sind, sie wissen doch, was er meinte. Genau das hat Ronzheimer gerade auch gemacht. Diese Trägheit. Und dann fühlt er das so ewig lange aus und möchte uns dann suggerieren, dass wir ja wissen, was er meint. Und ich sage, nein, Paul, ich weiß nicht, was du meinst. Du machst einfach nur so einen Wortsalat, weil du in der Interaktion deinem Gesprächspartner gefallen möchtest. Wäre ja auch blöd, Schirach da zu haben, wo man doch an seinen Lippen hängt und sich sehentlich gefreut hat, dass er endlich da ist. Und dann hat man plötzlich Widerspruch.
Die meisten Menschen gehen einfach ihre Arbeit nach und die sind da jetzt auch nicht bei langsamer geworden. Aber das ist immer diese Verengung der Perspektive, die man einfach hat, indem man auch vor allem viel in den Medien unterwegs ist. Und dann überträgt man das, macht man so merkwürdige Assoziationen. Ich hatte kürzlich einen Podcast gehört, da sagte dann so ein Business-Typ, ja und wenn ich das sehe, wenn ich das sehe in den Städten um 14 Uhr, sitzen die dann schon beim Edel Italiener und trinken freitags ein Glas Wein. Da weiß ich schon, hier wird nichts mehr gearbeitet. Und dann weiß ich genau, dann weiß ich genau, wen der meint. Und ich könnte auch in Köln genau diese Restaurants benennen, in denen das freitags so zu beobachten ist. Nur gehen die dann dahin und sagen, warum bewegt sich in Deutschland nichts mehr? Und dann würde ich sagen, guckt aus dem Fenster in dem Restaurant raus und seht dort, wie die Menschen alle noch normal arbeiten und gerade nicht beim Edel Italiener sitzen und Weißwein trinken. Das ist der Punkt. Das machen die aber alle nicht. Und wir kritisieren die Bahn, weil wir sehr genau sagen können, wie viel Milliarden fehlen und wie viel Personal eigentlich dringend herbestellt werden müsste, um das umzusetzen, um die Bahn wieder pünktlich zu machen. Und die Warnhöfe wieder entsprechend auf Vordarm anzubringen. Und da geht es aber nicht darum, dass allgemein sind wir träge geworden, sondern das ist ein sehr konkretes Problem, dass eine Merkel-Regierung vernachlässigt hat und die Ampel hat es auch nicht angepackt. Und diese Regierung wird es auch nicht tun.
Das Tolle ist, nichts verstehen wir so präzise wie die Unzuverlässigkeit der Bahn. Wir messen jeden einzelnen Zug und wir wissen auch genau, woran es liegt. Einer der Volker Dingstabums, hier FDP und so, die Bahn muss bitte ansagen, warum sie zu spät kommt. Und seitdem heißt es immer, man im Gleis irgendwas hier, Personenschaden, Schalte und so. Dieses allgemeine Gelaber, Trägheit und so, ich will es euch reinhemmern. Das sind Glaubenskrisen. Das ist dieses unkonkrete, wir gehen mal in die Kirche, wir beten, wir hoffen, dass es hilft. Wir haben noch nie was von Gott gehört, keine Ahnung. Gaudi hat das Licht so geil gemalt, ich habe eine Erleuchtung gehabt. So, Punkt. Das sind Glaubenskrisen, die wir hier erleben. Wirtschaft, Geld funktioniert makellos. Also wirklich genial, wie gut Geld funktioniert. Demokratie, also der Aufwand, den wir betreiben, um zu sagen, wie viel Sitze hat das Parlament und wie werden diese Sitze gefüllt, ist sagenumwoben. Das sind quasi alle vier Jahre, wenn ihr Impfzentren aufgebaut, um das zu organisieren, funktioniert tadellos. Gibt da keine Kritik. Also jetzt, BSW, Bundestag hat jetzt gesagt, befassen wir uns doch mal nicht damit. Und wir wissen genau, wo es endet, Bundesverfassungsgericht, Neuauszählung. Weil das ist ja eklatant, was da passiert. Also würde mich sozusagen, wäre eine Glaubenskrise, wenn es nicht so käme.
Wenn das nicht so käme, wäre es schon verwunderlich.
Alles funktioniert. Nur, diese Leute haben mit ihren ganz konkreten, partikularistischen Interessen mittlerweile Probleme. Sie sind nicht mehr allein. Und anstatt das einfach mal wahrzunehmen, so wie ein Therapeut, der erstmal so, ja, vielleicht sollten wir das jetzt nicht länger vermeiden und dann mal genau hingucken. Vermeiden Sie es einfach immer weiter und kommen dann mit so Er spricht nicht über Finanzierungsprobleme. Und hier und da und so. Das Vertrauen, die Krise, die Demokratie, auch viele Krisen, die Zukunft, die Träger halt. Alte Männer, einfach mal ein echtes Gespräch führen. Ohne Podcast-Mikrofon, mit echten Freunden und wenn es nicht weiterhilft, ein Therapeuten. Aber nicht sowas.
Wir müssen aber Probleme lösen.
Um diese Leute zurückzuholen und dass sie wieder Vertrauen haben. Das sind nicht Strategien, Überlegungen, wie treten wir auf, irgendetwas andere. Sondern das einzige, was funktioniert, ist, dass die Dinge wieder in Ordnung kommen. Also, dass die Bahn wieder pünktlich fährt, dass wir das Rentenproblem lösen, dass wir das Migrationsproblem lösen, dass wir das Sozialstaatsproblem lösen, dass wir das Steuerproblem lösen, dass wir die Probleme tatsächlich lösen. Darüber zu reden, dass wir das wollen, wird nicht funktionieren.
Das ist ja eine ganz interessante Reihung. Denn einmal ist ja konkret, die Bahn soll pünktlich kommen, einen Ansatz, den wir auch teilen. Aber dann redet er nur noch von das Rentenproblem, das Migrationsproblem, das Steuerproblem lösen. Ja, was meinte er jetzt? Sind die Renten zu hoch, zu niedrig? Zahlen wir zu viel aus? Also zu viel, zu wenig Migranten? Steuererhöhung? Will er für seine Klasse der Reichen die Steuer erhöhen? Ich glaube nein. Das heißt, hier geht er so ins ganz Allgemeine und sagt, da müssen einfach Probleme gelöst werden und kommt dann auf Abschiebungen und so was zu sprechen.
Ich gebe Ihnen ein Beispiel. Wir haben jetzt von dem Kanzler gehört, dass Syrer im großen Stil zurückgeführt werden sollen. Das ist etwas, was nicht funktionieren wird. Was wir heute wissen, dass es nicht funktionieren kann. Wir haben beim Bundesamt für Migration und Flüchtlinge Einzelfallprüfung. Einzelfallprüfung. Das heißt, jeder einzelne Fall wird geprüft. Nachdem jeder einzelne Fall, der dort rückgeführt werden soll, geprüft worden ist, hat jeder von diesen Leuten die Klagemöglichkeit. Wir haben jetzt schon 160.000 Klagen, Asylklagen, Anhängig, die nicht bearbeitet worden sind.
Die Option wäre ja jetzt, dass man das lässt mit diesen Rückführungen. Oh nein?
Wir brauchen anderthalb Jahre, um sozusagen mit den jetzt anhängigen Asylklagen überhaupt fertig zu werden. Jetzt können Sie sich vorstellen, wenn jetzt nochmal 30.000 neue Asylklagen, dann wird es ja nicht schneller, sondern eher langsamer. Das heißt also, wenn alles ganz toll läuft und nicht irgendetwas in Syrien noch passiert, braucht es mindestens zwei Jahre und das ist sehr optimistisch gerechnet.
Es läuft demnach toll, wenn wir die Menschen, die wir dringend brauchen könnten, wieder nach Syrien abschieben, wo es ja katastrophal aussieht, wie der Außenminister ja mehrfach betont hat.
Alles genial. Ich meine, ich weiß so ein bisschen, wo das herkommt. Wahrscheinlich stelle ich eine Vermutung an, aber wahrscheinlich hat er sehr viele Richter in seinem Freundeskreis.
Vermutlich.
Wir sind dann beim Deutschen Richtertag.
Ja.
Hören dort, wie alles blockiert ist.
Kommt ja gar nicht mehr zu irgendwas. Akten stapeln sich, diese ganzen Einzelfälle, das ist absurd.
Ja.
Aussen, da kann man eh nicht leiden. Und eins plus eins ist zwei. Ich will darauf hinweisen, Arne Semsrott, wir schätzen ihn ja wirklich sehr, war für Frag den Staat in Morgenmagazin. Ich habe die Clips von Nur der Koch gesehen. Und er redet dort mit einem Vertreter des öffentlichen Nahverkehrs. Und es geht um die Frage, warum blockieren die eigentlich, verstopfen die eigentlich das Rechtssystem? In Berlin, wo irgendwie so und so viele, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, jeder Fünfte, jeder Vierte, keine Ahnung, er sitzt im Gefängnis, weil er keinen Fahrschein gekauft hat für 2,70 Euro. Das kostet uns pro Tag 190 Euro oder so. Und dieser Vertreter vom öffentlichen Nahverkehr sagt dann, ja, da geht uns ja voll viel Geld verloren, wenn die keinen Fahrschein kaufen. Und das ist ja auch voll problematisch. Und Arne Semsrott dann, ja, aber wir kriegen immer die Meldung, dass sich da Leute umbringen, weil sie halt in Lebenskrisen stecken. Und dann gucken wir so nach, ob wir die hätten freikaufen können, weil die halt so ein Programm haben, die Leute einfach aus dem Gefängnis freizukaufen, wenn die wegen Schwarzfahren drin sitzen. Das sind doch mal nicht Flickenteppich des Kurses, sondern darum geht es doch. Und das ist bei diesem Asylzeug genau dasselbe.
Dieser Herr kann ja offenbar auch nicht in Bilanzen denken. Also man hat dann, man will die 2,70 Euro haben und zahlt aber 190 Euro pro Tag, die in dem Gefängnis sitzen.
Das ist ja eine andere Kasse und dadurch ist das alles.
Ach ja.
Dein großes Thema Rente.
Okay, ich bin gespannt.
Rente.
Jetzt, was gerade ganz aktuell ist, die Rentendebatte, es wird jetzt, wenn es alles gut geht und die Koalition nicht auseinanderbricht, auf 2031 verschoben, aber ist es nicht gelöst dadurch?
Ha, wenn alles gut geht, und bislang geht es ja alles gut, ich habe heute Morgen gelesen, Koalition bleibt erstmal bei ihrem Vorschlag. Man schreibt so ein paar Sachen rein, die man mal prüft und die Rentenkommission macht und so. Das kann die Jungen Union dann und so. Soll sie mal damit leben. Wenn alles gut läuft, wird es einfach verschoben. Was für ihn bedeutet, wenn alles gut läuft, bleibt es, wie es ist. Dann wird für die Rente die einzige Finanzierungsquelle, die überhaupt Sinn macht, nämlich das Gesamtdeutsche Vermögen, auch wenn es privat enttitelt ist, unangetastet. Sehr gut, Herr Schirach. So kommt man gut bis zu seinem eigenen Lebensende. Man soll noch die anderen Brot essen.
Ja, das ist, glaube ich, hier nochmal ganz wichtig zu sagen, worum es überhaupt bei dieser Rente geht. Es ist eine Umverteilungsdebatte, die wir dort erleben, zwischen denen, die eingezahlt haben in die Rente. Es ist nicht eine Umverteilungsdebatte, dass hier das Kapital in irgendeiner Weise zur Raison gebeten wird. Es sind nicht die Vermieter, die das zahlen. Es ist nicht der Großaktionär oder sonst irgendwer, sondern es sind die Leute, die in die Rente einzahlen. Die können jetzt schauen, zahlen sie etwas weniger in die Rente ein, um dann später weniger Rente zu bekommen. Oder zahlen sie jetzt etwas mehr für die Rente ein und bekommen dann ein bisschen mehr. Das sind die Debatten. Es wird dabei so einen Generationenkampf daraus gemacht. Und wenn man sich, was meine ich, das sind alles kein Geheimbissen. Also jetzt mal, Bundeszentrale für politische Bildung. In Verbindung mit der Entwicklung der Verbraucherpreise ist die reale Standardrente im Zeitraum 2003 bis 2014 sogar gesunken. Das heißt, dass sich die Kaufkraft in diesen Jahren insgesamt verringerte. In den Folgejahren stieg die reale Standardrente wieder an und erreichte 2020 das Niveau von 2003. Also nach 17 Jahren ist man wieder auf diesem Niveau. Das heißt, es gab also zwischen 2003 und 2020 keine Kaufkraftgewinne. Also in Renten dann ging es jetzt nicht immer besser.
Es geht ja grundsätzlich erstmal für alle so.
Kein Schlaraffenland. Genau und man könnte ja darüber reden, wie die Renten steigen. Zum Beispiel, indem die Löhne steigen. Dann können ja nämlich mehr eingezahlt werden. Und das immer so getan wird, als sei das so eine Solidargemeinschaft im Sinne von die Arbeitgeber geben ja was rein. Das stimmt ja nicht. Es ist so, dass der Preis für Arbeit wird ja berechnet. Nichts anderes. Also ich will es mal ganz konkret machen. Nehmen wir mal an, ich hätte jetzt Geld und würde sagen, das Tollste in meinem Leben wäre ein Chauffeur. Dann würde ich ja mich fragen, was kostet mich ein Chauffeur? Und dann sage ich ja nicht, ah der kostet mich so und so viel netto, sondern ich muss ja den gesamten Lohn berechnen. Also das, was ich an die Rentenkasse gebe, was ich an Sozialbeiträgen leiste und was dann demjenigen aufs Konto überwiesen wird. Und das ist ja einfach die Summe, mit der ich rechnen muss. Und dann ist die Fahrerkoste das 4000, 5000, 6000 Euro. Und genauso ist das bei allen Arbeitgebern. Es ist der Gesamtpreis. Das heißt, wenn gesagt wird, der Arbeitgeberanteil müsste gesenkt werden oder so. Auch das ist ja bei der Jungen Union. Dann meint das einfach, die wollen weniger Lohn zahlen. Das ist das. Das ist nicht irgendwie ein solidarischer Akt, sondern die rechnen einfach mit dem Gesamtpreis, was kostet eine Arbeitskraft. Und da sind alle Eventualitäten mit drin und das ist der Protolohn. Mit dem wird gerechnet und nicht mit dem Netto-Lohn. Und deswegen ist es eine Umverteilung, die stattfindet. Und dass er jetzt immer nur vom Rentenproblem, das gelöst werden muss, redet, dann frage ich mich, wie sieht die Lösung aus?
Ja, also jetzt aktuell gilt, du hast es ja genau richtig gesagt, ich hatte mal mit Hans, wahrscheinlich eines der größten Streitereien überhaupt im Aufwahr-Podcast, weil ich sagte, Hans ist alles scheißegal, es ist der Protopreis der Arbeit.
Richtig.
Egal, wie da irgendwelche Verteilungen laufen und so. Und Hans so, nein, nein, das muss man da ganz detailliert sehen. Mittlerweile hat es sich zugespitzt, denn das, was du jetzt gesagt hast, stimmt absolut. Plus, wenn wir jetzt einfach sagen, die Jungen bezahlen halt ein bisschen mehr ein, müssen wir ihnen auch mehr Ansprüche geben. Das entlastet ja die Rentenkasse nicht, es bleibt ein Binnenverhältnis so. Es gibt nur eine Lösung, von außen muss weiter Geld reinfließen, aber nicht einfach nur wie bislang so, spezifisch durch den Bundeshaushalt, sondern es muss halt eine richtige Abgabe geben. Eine Vermögensabgabe, die direkt in die Rente umgelagert wird. So ungefähr, ganz zweckdienlich. Was jetzt bedeutet, ich sage ja immer ganz negativ, wenn ich über die Alten Republik, so in Abendveranstaltungen rede, erstmal, wir reden über Probleme, die wir gar nicht lösen. Also wir sprechen einfach nur so Probleme, es reicht ja schon mal was Bescheid zu wissen. Was jetzt dazu führt, in der aktuellen Diskussion zwischen CDU, SPD, hier ein paar Berater und dann kommt die junge Union und so, alle haben Recht, alle haben Recht mit dem, was sie sagen. Keiner hat Unrecht. Die junge Union hat nicht Unrecht. Die SPD hat auch nicht Unrecht. Merkel oder so dazwischen hat auch nicht Unrecht. Alle haben Recht. Sie trauen sich nicht zuzugestehen, dass es halt nicht aufgeht.
Genau.
So, das Binnenverhältnis hin und her zu verschieben.
Deswegen ist der Streit ja auch, das muss man ja auch fragen.
Nur nimmkostendings hier bla bla bla, Ansprüche hoch, Ansprüche runter. Solange das eingeschlossene System wie jetzt bleibt, haben alle Recht und es ist unauflösbar.
Ich kann dich ja nicht entlasten, indem ich sage, du darfst jetzt weniger eins sein, aber du bekommst hinterher auch weniger. Das ist ja keine Entlastung.
Genau. Man hat halt eine Seite verloren so.
Ja, und das ist die Seite, die er arbeiten muss, die verliert gerade bei dieser Debatte. Deswegen ist ja auch der eigentliche Konflikt jetzt gerade, wo man sagt, oder setzt sich aber die SPD so stark durch, das ist ja ein Scheinkonflikt. Also da wird ja nicht mehr darüber diskutiert, ob das Rentenniveau gesenkt wird, 2031, sondern wird das jetzt von den aufrechterhaltenen, aufgrund von ein paar Zusatzzahlungen, die da erfolgen aus der Staatskasse, wird das von 48 Prozent abgesenkt? Oder, wie die Junge Union das sagt, nein, nein, wir müssen dann, wenn, von 47 Prozent absenken. Das heißt, der Konflikt wäre eigentlich der mit Ferdinand von Schirach. Und um das deutlich zu machen, wie stark dieser Konflikt ist, hören wir natürlich jetzt uns an, wie er das Rentenproblem lösen will.
Du schreibst ja immer die Worte da rein, ne? Ich möchte, also, Farah ohne haben wir, Rom, Orwell, was war das Viertel? Gauck.
Gauck.
Gauck. So, jetzt kommt, ich würde es mal sagen, Rente. Norbert Blüm und natürlich der Staatswohnen von Norwegen, was sonst?
Richtig.
Norbert Blüm, die Rente ist sicher, ja. Man hat sich, man hat den netten Norbert Blüm mit seiner runden Brille gesehen und hat sich gedacht, naja, wenn der das sagt, dann wird die Rente sicher sein.
Warte, stopp, stopp, stopp. Macht er sich gerade über das Vertrauensthema lustig?
Ja.
Ja, macht er.
Genial, Herr Schirach, genial.
Und ich will auch nochmal sagen, wir sind jetzt im Jahr 2025. Das mit Blüm ist über 30 Jahre her. Offenbar hatte Blüm ja recht. Es ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass man gesagt hat, wir konnten leider in diesem Monat den Rentner nichts auszahlen.
Also, Deutschland ist so reich. Wir sind die drittgrößte Volkswirtschaft nach Umsatz, aber nicht die drittgrößte Bevölkerung. Rente zu bezahlen aus dem, was wir in Deutschland haben, wäre gar kein Problem. Die Frage ist nur, wenn Herr Schirach seinen nächsten Buchvertrag unterschreibt und da steht Vorschuss 750.000 Euro, ist er bereit, davon 24.000 abzugeben für diese neue Rentenabgabe oder nicht? Das ist das einzige, was noch offen ist.
Und das müssen wir ihn mal fragen.
Genau. Alles andere, Herr Blüm, der norwegische Staatsfonds. Ja, schön. Es gab mal eine Vergangenheit und die Norweger haben Öl im Boden. Das nützt uns gar nichts.
Wissen wir, dass die Rente überhaupt nicht sicher ist, sondern ein totales Chaos und das ist sozusagen der demografische Faktor, an dem sie ja nichts machen können.
Denn wir müssen ja die Syrer wieder abschieben. An dem demografischen Faktor geht es nicht.
Reine Mathematik, da gibt es nicht.
Und wir können auch gar nichts tun, damit die Frauen, die gerne Kinder haben, wollen sie auch bekommen. Wir können die nicht unterstützen.
Dieses eine Wunschkind, dass nicht geboren wird in Deutschland pro Frau, da kann man gar nichts machen.
Ja und dass eigentlich diese verpflichtende Einhaltung, dass jedem Kind einen Kita-Platz zusteht, was nicht realisiert wird, kann man halt nicht realisieren.
Zu viele Krisen dafür.
Nichts drum zu deuteln, dass es nicht mehr funktionieren wird. Und das ist jetzt klar.
Aber das wusste man doch auch schon vor 20 Jahren.
Bei Norbert Blüm hat man es geglaubt, dass es funktioniert.
Ich hab viele, also am Anfang vielleicht geglaubt, aber dann gab es ja ganz viele.
Übrigens war damals die Rente auch noch sicher. Das darf man auch nicht wirklich.
Ach so, ja. Warum war sie denn da sicher?
Finde ich witzig, wie jetzt bei ihm, dass der Glaube dann doch reinkommt. Doch bei Norbert Blüm hat man es damals geglaubt. Ja, das ist das, was du gerade als großes Thema uns allen vorstellst. Dass man einfach glaubt, wenn ein Politiker sagt, die Rente ist sicher, weil es auch mathematisch nachgerechnet keinen Sinn hat, daran zu zweifeln, dass die Rente sicher ist.
Ja, wesentlich sicherer. Das ist ja immer nur die Frage des Verhältnisses. Aber sie haben vollkommen recht. Norbert Blüm hätte damals einfach sagen können und müssen meines Erachtens, wir werden die Rente jetzt mal umstellen. Wir werden das in ein Kapitalverfahren, in eine Rentenkasse, die tatsächlich eine Kasse ist, wo Geld einbezahlt wird und drin bleibt und angelegt wird, umwandeln. Jetzt haben wir ja immer nur so einen Reihen raus. Also die jetzigen Arbeiter bezahlen den Rentner. Ja, einfach eine Transferleistung. Ja, in Norwegen ist es zum Beispiel vollkommen anders. Da wird das Geld, was erarbeitet wird, was sie sozusagen als Renten bezahlen müssen, in eine Form getan.
Nein, es stimmt einfach nicht.
Es kommt nicht aus der Arbeit.
Es gibt in Norwegen ein Umlageverfahren wie in Deutschland.
Genau.
In Norwegen sind die Rentenbeiträge aber niedriger. Generell die Sozialabgaben niedriger. Wir sprechen da in Norwegen davon, dass sie für den Arbeitnehmer bei hinten nur 7,8 Prozent liegen. Übrigens beim Arbeitgeber dann 14,1. Aber wir haben eben schon gesagt, es kommt auf den Protolohn an, es ist egal, wie das dann aufgeteilt wird. Und in Deutschland haben wir eben Arbeitgeber, Arbeitnehmeranteil von etwa 20 Prozent. Da steckt aber noch ein bisschen mehr drin als nur die Rente. Warum ist das so anders? Nun, erst einmal könnte man demografisch draufblicken, Norwegen ist jünger, ja. Medianalter 40 Jahre, Deutschland Medianalter 46 Jahre. Heißt, Anzahl der Menschen, die über 65 sind, da kommen eben sehr viel mehr Erwerbstätige auf diese Senioren. Und dann ist es ja nun so, dass Norwegen diesen Staatsfonds hat, aber der ist nicht einfach, dass man das Geld der Arbeiter nimmt und sagt, wir stopfen das hier in Aktien, sondern man hat Erdöl und Gas vorkommen und verkauft die an die ganze Welt, hat enorm viel Geld und macht das seit den 90er Jahren. Und das legt man dann an international. Und diese Möglichkeit hat Deutschland meines Wissens nicht, da wir nicht über diese Rohstoffe verfügen. Das Einzige, was man hätte machen können, wäre, man führt eine entsprechende Vermögenssteuer für die Schirachs und andere ein. Und dieses Geld, das könnte man überlegen, ob man das wo anlegt. Das wäre eine Möglichkeit gewesen. Die wird hier aber nicht angesprochen. Was er will, ist, dass jetzt quasi das, was ohnehin nur umverteilt werden darf, nämlich das, was die Arbeiter erwirtschaften, das soll jetzt bitte am Kapitalmarkt besser angelegt sein. Das ist den einzigen Vorschlag, den er dann macht. Der löst hier gar nichts.
Also er hätte die Niederlande nennen können. Die haben ja so einen privat und dann tatsächlich aus der Arbeit finanzierten Staatsfonds oder mehrere, aber man kann jetzt eine Summe mal nennen, eine Billion Euro. Und da sind die Unternehmen einfach verpflichtet, abseits aller konkreten Bruttolohnrechnungen und so weiter, grundsätzlich und dann anteilsmäßig in so einen Fonds einzuzahlen. Und dadurch ergibt sich da einfach eine Kasse, die man dann halt als Auszahlungsquelle nutzen kann. Nur das muss man halt einrichten. Was die jetzt alle versuchen, ist ja zu sagen, das Rentensystem funktioniert nicht. Also nehmen wir die Beitragszahlung, eine absolut innerhalb des Systems verrechnete Größe und führen die noch mal raus aus dem Rentensystem an die Börse. Also das geht ja gar nicht auf. Den Kuchen kleiner machen nützt jetzt gar nichts. Die Boomer kommen jetzt in Rente. Was man aber sagen könnte wäre, ja ja, also Geld kann man schon am Kapitalmarkt anlegen. Die Frage ist nur, welches. Und dann sind wir halt wieder bei der Frage.
Bei einer interessanten Umverteilungsfrage vielleicht.
Aber ich denke auch, Herr Schirach braucht, es ist ganz wichtig, wenn man dran hat, seit man ein Buch schreibt, braucht man dafür eine Million Euro. Sonst würde man es ja gar nicht machen. Einfach nur, weil die Idee gut ist, die man in das Buch schreiben will.
Politisches System noch mal. Ich habe auch hier nicht so richtig gewusst, was er meint.
Und da wir keine absoluten Mehrheiten mehr bekommen werden auf ganz lange Zeit.
Das ist seine Krise. Ja. Dass wir die CSU immer mit 60 Prozent im Parlament hatten.
Ja, aber wann auch? Also außer Bayern. Ausgenommen. Wann wurde denn Deutschland mit einer absoluten Mehrheit rediert?
Oder hat im Bundestag eine Mehrheit aus zwei Parteien oder sowas?
Nee, aber er redet ja hier wirklich von der absoluten Mehrheit. Also in welchen Bundesländern gibt es sonst ab? Gab es absolute Mehrheiten? Das ist doch Quatsch.
Das ist etwas, was er gerade beschreibt als Erwünschenswert. Das ist eine historische Mode, die mit dem System an sich nichts zu tun hat.
Wird es immer Koalitionsverträge geben? Das heißt, alles, was in den Wahlversprechen angekündigt wird, wird nie so umgesetzt, sondern wird immer weniger sein. Es sei denn, sie finden mal einen Koalitionspartner, der das genauso sieht und mitmacht. Aber das ist ziemlich unwahrscheinlich.
Sorry Herr Schirach, aber...
Hier hat kaum jemand einfach ein Problem mit Parlamentarismus.
Ich fühle mich gerade auch im Modus wie der Vater, der den ausgefallenen Politikunterricht ergänzt, indem er die Tagesschau kommentiert, wie die 15-Jährige uns jetzt noch mal ein bisschen gerade zu rücken. Also Herr Schirach ist ja wirklich komplett abgemeldet. Ja, wir haben keine Mehrheit. Mehrheiten müssen immer Koalition gemacht werden. Also, so wie ich das gesehen habe, war die große Ausstellung zur 75-Jahre-Grundgesetz der Kompromiss übertitelt. Und nicht die Mehrheit, das Durchregieren, die sieben Jahre, die drei Freischüsse. Wie schön es war als der Adenauer noch und so weiter. Einfach mit 51 Prozent oder was auch immer. Das ist doch absurd. Also wirklich, es ist doch totaler Kindergarten, was wir hier gucken. Also, wir gucken es natürlich aus Gründen, aber dass Deutschland damit beschaltet, ist wirklich skandalös.
Ich will das nochmal deutlich sagen. Wir sind hier ja auf dem Gipfel der deutschen Intelligenz angekommen. Das sind die großen Männer, die uns die Welt erklären. Die sitzen ja den ganzen Tag auf irgendwelchen Festivals und Podien. Und die Leute hängen an den Lippen, die nicht nur Ronzheimer und sagen, Mensch, wunderbar, so jemanden wie Schirach. Das wäre es doch eigentlich. Wie sieht denn Schirach jetzt den Kanzler?
Wenn Sie Friedrich Merz ansprechen, wie blicken Sie auf den Kanzler?
Also ich halte ihn für einen aus der Ferne. Muss ich sagen, ich kenne ihn nicht, aber aus der Ferne halte ich ihn für einen durch und durch anständigen Menschen. Und ich glaube, er hat das...
Waren machen Sie das fest?
Ja, lustigerweise an dem, was alle so schrecklich finden bei Ihnen. Ich mag diese Emotionalität.
Zum einen mal herzlich willkommen in der Realität. Wir kennen den Kanzler alle nur aus der Ferne. Wir müssen das nicht dazusagen.
Na, er muss das dazusagen, weil für ihn ist das natürlich in seinen Kreisen so, dass man immer wieder auf mächtige Politiker trifft und merkwürdigerweise den kennt er nicht.
Ich spiele noch mal die letzten fünf Sekunden.
Wollen wir noch mal aus dem Ende hören?
Warum machen Sie das fest?
Ja, lustigerweise an dem, was alle so schrecklich finden über ihn. Ich mag diese Emotionalität.
Willst du das noch ein bisschen im Köcher meinen, denn es kommt noch mehr dazu, die Emotionalität.
Wir können das ja im Wahlkampf sehen.
Wir können auch einfach die letzte Woche durchgehen. Nehmen wir die Aussagen zu Brasilien. Nehmen wir das, was er in der Rentendiskussion gemacht hat. Nehmen wir das.
Naja, das war nicht so schlau. Aber die Sachen sind ja dann alle nicht so wahnsinnig schlau.
Aber jetzt kommt's. Wir haben ja über das Buch von Robin Alexander ausführlich gesprochen. Ich glaube, ich hätte noch jemand das Buch gelesen.
Aber ich fand zum Beispiel, mich hat das sehr berührt, wie er von, ich damals war, lag die mal bei 36 Prozent im Wahlkampf.
Er suggeriert jetzt, dass die CDU Folgendes gemacht hat. Die CDU war super drauf, weil sie auf diese Wirtschaftsthemen gesetzt hat. Also das ist noch mal eine andere Erdrehung, als das jetzt Robin Alexander uns verkauft. Und dann aber ist Terror, Messerstöchereien. Und jetzt wird das so verkauft als Opferer, die CDU Prozente, weil man so emotional ist.
CDU, wo sie den, wir hören das noch mal von Anfang an. Aber ich fand zum Beispiel, mich hat das sehr berührt, wie er von, ich damals war, lag die mal bei 36 Prozent im Wahlkampf, die CDU, wo sie den, bis dahin hatten sie einen reinen Wirtschaftswahlkampf geführt. Dann passierten diese Anschläge und er führte einen Wahlkampf zur Anziehung, ja, zur Migration. Das kostete ihn fast zehn Prozentpunkte. Aber irgendwie fand ich diese Emotionalität, wie er da fast geheult hat bei dieser Geschichte mit dem Baby, das im Babywagen erstocken worden ist, das hat mich sehr berührt und ich fand das irgendwie schon ganz außergewöhnlich.
Man weiß gar nicht mehr, was man dazu sagen soll.
Sorry, dafür haben wir, also das haben wir, da haben wir alles eigentlich zugesagt.
Das lassen wir einfach mal so stehen im Salon, dann die ganze Besprechung zu Robin Alexander.
Aber erschütternd wirklich.
Fakten und Fake News natürlich noch, wichtiges Thema.
Und zwei Sachen sagen, schau dir mal, ich trage heute ein weißes Hemd. Wir können nicht darüber diskutieren, ob das Hemd weiß ist. Das ist eine Tatsache, die steht einfach fest. Wir können darüber reden, ob das ein schönes Hemd ist, ob er sich gut anfühlt, ob der Kragen hoch genug ist. Also Zeug. Aber das sind Meinungen, darüber können wir diskutieren. Was wir im Moment ständig machen, ist über Tatsachen zu diskutieren. Und das ist unfassbar gefährlich, weil wir dadurch keinen einzigen Schritt weiterkommen.
Wir müssen, wie meinen Sie das, Gennad?
Dann wollen wir mal bei den Tatsachen bleiben, über die wir jetzt nicht diskutieren sollten, weil die sind ja einfach so da, wie das Hemd von Schirach, das weiße. Ich habe ja auch ein weißes Hemd da.
Ja, bist du ja sicher? Also soweit ich weiß, diese Norweger, die ja alles besser machen, wo auch mehr Schnee fällt, die haben eine Verständigung darüber, was, also weiß, ja, das ist, was für ein weiß?
Welches weiß?
Naja, wir müssen uns klar sein darüber, dass die Probleme, wie bei der Rentenreform, also nehmen wir die Probleme auf, Migrationspolitik, Wirtschaftskrise, Energieknappheit, Autoindustrie, also die Stadt Deutschland, dass wir sie haben. Dass wir die Probleme haben.
Aber zweifelt die jemand an?
Ja, natürlich. Wenn Sie die Migrationsfrage nehmen, die ist zehn Jahre lang, fast von den Bürger, oder fast zehn Jahre lang, von den bürgerlichen Parteien nicht angesprochen worden.
Wir haben jetzt zehn Jahre über fast nichts anderes mehr gesprochen als darüber. Vor allem in den letzten fünf Jahren, in den letzten drei Jahren, nur noch Migration.
Ist ja ein Troll.
Also das gibt es doch gar nicht.
Macht er sich lustig mit seinen Kumpels, dass er, ich sitze morgen bei Myoska, guck mal, ich sage das, morgen bin ich bei Ronsheim, dort werde ich sagen, ich habe ja noch niemals über Migration geredet.
Das sind ja Leute, die warnen ja vor all diesen alternativen Medien. Dann würde ich sagen, diesen Satz, den kann man ja, also den sagen ja auch Hoss und Hopf. In Deutschland kann man ja, kann man ja nicht mal mehr über Migration reden, sagen die.
Ja, wir reden doch wirklich ausschließlich über Migration. Also ausschließlich. Ja. Wir reden jetzt mal seit drei Wochen über die Rente, weil die Junge Union mal so einen Aufstand macht und gerade der Deutschlandtag war.
Man ist ja ganz erleichtert, dass mal dann drei Wochen über die Rente geredet wird, wenn auch unsinnig, aber immerhin.
Ja, vor allem, wir reden ja auch nicht wirklich über die Rente. Wir reden ja über die Rente nur, weil sie eine Kontroverse zwischen Junge Union und die Union ist.
Wer wird sich vertragen?
Ja. Krass.
Kommt noch mal auf die Rente zu sprechen.
Die Frage der Rente, die wird in einer Form diskutiert, wo sie sagen können, sagen wir, seid ihr wahnsinnig? Es ist doch vollkommen klar, was passiert. Es ist greifbar. Sie müssen die Zahlen hinlegen. Wir können nicht über diese Zahlen diskutieren.
Aber wollten wir das alle ignorieren, weil das irgendwie unangenehm ist?
Nein, es liegt daran, dass die Parteien und die Politiker wieder gewählt werden. Sie schieben das raus bis 2031, hat Kohl schon immer gemacht. Schauen wir mal, dann ist es ein Stück weit weg und dann, bis dahin wird sich noch viel ändern. Das Wasser läuft in Bonn. Ich habe in Bonn studiert, dann läuft noch viel Wasser in den Rhein runter. Keine Ahnung.
Herr Helmut Kohl hatte das Rentenproblem nicht, deswegen hat er auch nichts verschoben. Und das Einzige, wovor er sich ja wegduckt, ist das, was du ja genau benannt hast. Man müsste darüber diskutieren, ob die Klasse der von Schirachs auch beteiligt werden an den Zahlungen, die nötig sind für die Rente. Aber was er ja eigentlich sagen will, die Politiker schweigen dazu, weil sie wiedergewählt werden wollen. Aber eigentlich finde ich und finden meine anderen reichen Freunde, dass die Rentner jetzt einfach mal noch 10 Null Runden bekommen sollten.
Es ist ja so, ich habe ja über die Altenrepublik ausführlich geschrieben, das Phänomen ist ja nicht, dass Politiker das verschweigen, sondern ich zitiere ja die Reden, ich zitiere das Statistische Bundesamt, die Beiräte, alle reden die ganze Zeit über die Rente. Nur im Journalismus kommt es nicht an. Warum nicht? Weil mal wieder irgendwas mit Migration ist, aber auch nicht wirklich mit Migration. Sondern nur mit so einem Devianten mit einer Waffe. So und das, was wir hier sehen, ist ja wieder so ein ganz typisches Phänomen. In Deutschland scheint ja nichts zu funktionieren, wird uns gesagt in den Medien. Und zwar im Format des aufklärerischen Diskurses. Gast Ferdinand von Schirach, Moderation austauschbar. Und der Duktus, in dem er auch die ganze Zeit redet, sieht ja so aus, als ob in Deutschland genau nichts funktioniert. Außer die Gespräche mit Ferdinand von Schirach.
Weil sie so schuldenruhig sind.
Das ist das einzige, was noch funktioniert in Deutschland.
Ganz geruhsam.
Aber das kann ja gar nicht stimmen, könnte man ja als denken. Es kann ja gar nicht stimmen, dass in Deutschland nichts funktioniert, außer die Gesprächsgestaltung mit Ferdinand von Schirach, der uns dann innerhalb von wow, in 45 Minuten alle Probleme einmal erklärt. Ja, der löst die Probleme. Zum Schluss noch ein Literatur-Tipp.
Tomasi di Lampedusa, der eines der schönsten Bücher überhaupt geschrieben hat. Il gastopardo, das ist in Deutsch, glaube ich, leopardo.
Dem stimme ich erst mal zu. Ja, das ist ein sehr schöner Roman. Den haben Ole und ich auch mal zusammen besprochen.
Das ist übersetzt aus dem Italienischen. Da gibt es einen tollen Satz drin. Und der heißt, damit es so bleibt wie bisher, muss sich alles ändern. Und das ist vielleicht das richtige Schlusswort für Ihren Podcast. Es muss sich wirklich vieles ändern, damit wir weiter so bequem leben können wie bisher.
So, wovon handelt der Roman? Der handelt von einem Aristokraten, der plötzlich merkt, da sind auch so demokratische Bestrebungen und so. Und dann ist die Frage, wie geht man darauf zu? Es geht aber darum, dass die aristokratische Klasse ihren Status halten kann. Und dass er jetzt das herbeizertiert und sagt, ja, es muss sich alles ändern. Meint natürlich nicht. Ich meine niemals für die Leute und das sollte man sich jetzt auch generell merken, es meint nie für die Leute, die in Talkshows sitzen, dass sich für die irgendetwas ändert, sondern die sagen, ihr braucht eine Nullrunde, die Bürgergeldempfänger sollen weniger Geld bekommen, die Syrer sollen zurück wo auch immer hin. Für alle, alle soll sich etwas ändern, außer für uns, damit wir weiter unseren Status Quo erhalten können. Das ist die Aussage hier.
Ich finde es auch gut, dass das Buch einfach so gut ist, weil der eine Satz so berührend ist.
Ja, das ist der eine Satz, den jeder zu zitieren weiß.
Ja, aber reicht doch auch. Das ist ein bisschen wie, du wirst Kanzler eines Landes, das unendliche Geschichte auch parallel und, glaube ich, wie das Schicksale in sich birgt. Und dann hängst du alles daran auf, dass es eine Gewalttat gab, also eine, gestern. Und die ist absolut dominierend. Egal, was für ein Terminkalender ist, wenn das Briefing mit der Bürgermeisterin ist, die es noch mal schildert, ist alles andere vergessen.
Also für die Normalbevölkerung, für die normalen Leute, muss sich natürlich alles ändern, damit sich für die anderen nichts ändert. Abmoderation göttlich.
Herr von Schirach, ganz tolle Schlusswort und hochspannend, ihn zuzuhören. Vielen Dank, dass Sie sich die Zeit genommen haben.
Danke, dass ich da sein durfte.
Und ich bin sicher, dass das einige hören.
Ja, wir.
Also an der Masse sowieso, aber auch von Leuten, die in dieser Politik sind. Und dass es ihnen Gedanken macht, ich glaube.
Ja, ein bisschen in Ronsheimer denke. Die Masse sowieso, aber auch so ein paar Auswählte, Handverlesene.
Und jetzt kommt es aber noch zu den Journalisten. Und beinahe käme man jetzt in ein interessantes Feld der Medienkritik.
Die größte Herausforderung, das vielleicht noch zum Schluss, ist tatsächlich auch für die Politik, denn sie können so viele Kommissionen einsetzen, wie sie wollen. Wenn sie sich nicht mal lösen oder überhaupt lösen können vom Tagesaktuellen. Und da auch vielleicht ein kritischer Blick auf das, was wir Journalisten tun. Nämlich tatsächlich sehr aktuell und jedes Mal der Aktualität nachrennen.
Und ihr hetzt die auch auf die ganze Zeit. Das ist für euch ja wild, dass ihr erlegen wollt.
Naja, das weiß ich nicht. Aber tatsächlich ist es so, dass es zumindest tagtäglich neue Themen gibt. Und da kann man schon kritisch drüber nachdenken. Und damit meine ich jetzt gar nicht unbedingt Zeitungen oder Online-Medien, aber die sozialen Medien, was das mit Debatten gemacht hat.
Also jetzt, wo es interessant wird, spielt er seine eigene Musik schon ein, um sich von der Bühne zu jagen, wie in so einer Ausgabeverleihung oder was?
Ja. Und dann zu sagen, damit meine ich jetzt gar nicht so Zeitungen an und Print- und Online-Medien. Die die ganze Zeit irgendwelche Themen setzen, bei denen man sagt, muss das jetzt wieder sein? Muss man jetzt wieder diesen Zorus da veranstalten? Und er sagt, nee, nee, also da die sozialen Medien, die machen alles so schnell.
Natürlich.
Also, dass die Bild-Zeitung einfach drei Jahre lang versuchte, jeden Tag eine Kampagne gegen Habeck zu starten und überall irgendetwas suchte. Also bei aller Kritik an Habeck, die auch gerechtfertigt ist, war das ja genau die Strategie der Treibjagd. Und dann zu sagen, ah nee, also ich meine jetzt gar nicht unser Haus oder die anderen Kollegen, die sozialen Medien, die machen alles sehr schnell.
Oh Gott.
Ich will aber auch noch einen Blick auf die jungen Leute werfen. Wir sprechen noch mit einem Clip über die Bambi-Verleihung. Du hast sie dir wahrscheinlich nicht angesehen.
Nein, und Leute glauben immer, dass ich hier irgendwie lüge oder so. Ich hätte dann die Haftbefehl-Doku doch gesehen oder was auch immer. Ich sage euch ganz ehrlich, was ich sehe. André Rieu, ich stehe doch zu den Sachen. Ich weiß bis heute nicht, wie Haftbefehl aussieht. Und ich gucke mir diese Doku auch nicht an. Und Bambi, nein, da steht jetzt Zartmann.mp4 in deinem Clip. Ich weiß, Herr Zartmann hat da irgendwas gemacht. Ich weiß von nichts.
Also du hast mitbekommen, Thomas Gottschalk hat einen etwas berühmten Auftritt in ihm gelegt.
Ich hab's aber nicht gesehen.
Aber über den wollen wir jetzt heute nicht reden. Sondern ich will einmal noch diesen hilflosen Antifaschismus der jungen Leute ansprechen, der jungen Leute, die so im Popmedien-Business unterwegs sind. Man kann sich und man sollte sich vielleicht sogar politisch positionieren. Aber man muss dann schon was Vernünftiges zu sagen haben. Und hier das ist einfach nur so, ich hole mir ein bisschen Social-Media-Applaus ab. Aber es ist nicht durchdacht. Auch wenn wir eben gesagt haben, ja Kompromisse ohne das kann natürlich ein Parlamentarismus nicht funktionieren. Aber das ist nicht so gemeint, wie das hier ausgedrückt wird von Zartmann, der also einen Preis entgegennahm, den Bambi entgegennahm und dann plötzlich bei seiner Dankesrede noch sagte.
Ich würde sagen, Fick die AfD, ist mir ganz wichtig zu sagen. Fick rechtspopulistische Scheiße. Ich kann verstehen, wenn Menschen gerade uns im Frieden sind. Ich kann es sehr gut verstehen. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass Rechtspopulismus der Weg daraus ist. Lass uns gemeinsam reden. Lass uns zu Lücken schließen. Irgendwie Kompromisse finden. Und keine Rechtspopulisten an die Macht kommen lassen. Das war's von mir.
Das ist einfach so ein Dahergerede von Lass uns Kompromisse schließen. Adressiert konkret, was los ist. Es gibt eine jetzige Bundesregierung, die die Abschiebungen vornimmt. Ist das der Kompromiss, der gemeint ist? Weil was ist einfach mit Kompromiss? Das ist auch so ein hohles Geschwätz. Also ist Kompromiss, wir schieben alle ab im Alphabet von A bis L und die anderen können bleiben. Was ist ein Kompromiss? Also ein Kompromiss hat erst einmal nichts Positives oder Negatives. Das ist ganz neutral. Und jetzt einfach nur zu sagen, ja schließt euch mal alle zusammen, ist genau falsch. Weil das suggeriert, dass es eh ein Einheitspreis ist. Und dann gibt es nur noch demgegenüberstehend die AfD. Man müsste hier, wenn man politisch sich äußern will, ganz klar sagen, was gerade schief läuft. Und dann müsste man eigentlich da stehen, sagt wegen mir Scheiß auf die AfD. Aber dann muss man sagen, wir brauchen jetzt 100 Milliarden Euro für Kindergärten und Schulen. Oder man muss sagen, wir brauchen jetzt das Erbe für alle ab 18 Jahre, 50.000 Euro. Man müsste sagen, jetzt brauchen wir Reallohnerhöhungen. Das sind politische Forderungen. Die werden dann nicht direkt umgesetzt, aber die sind in irgendeiner Weise sinnvoll. Hier, das ist einfach nur so ein diffuser Zusammenschluss. Macht mal alle irgendwie was, damit die AfD nicht. Und das ist genau das, was ja gerade stattfindet. Man macht die schlimmsten Kompromisse auf den Rücken von denen, die sich ohnehin nicht wehren können und verkauft das dann als einen tollen, demokratierettenden Kompromiss. Also solche hilflosen, antifaschistischen Auftritte will ich künftig nicht mehr hören.
Ja, vor allem hier gilt ja die Logik des ja, jetzt ist das Recht so von Leuten, die das hören. Wir haben ja, oder ich habe häufiger kritisiert, wenn der Bundespräsident als Vertreter des Staates und Leute wollen irgendwas gegen den Bundespräsident haben, was zum Thema Antisemitismus sagt, dann entscheiden sich die Leute in dem Moment dafür, Antisemiten zu sein, allein weil sie den Bundespräsidenten und damit dem Staat eins auswischen können. Und das, was wir gerade gehört haben, ist einfach nur das, was der Bundespräsident macht, nur im Modus so ein bisschen verändert.
Ja, so ein bisschen lauter, ein bisschen flippiger, ein bisschen jünger, peppiger.
Ja, ja, es funktioniert nicht, es führt zu Widerstand. Wir schließen das ganze Kapitel mit Schirach ab, in dem wir Markus Lanz hören in seinem eigenen Podcast. Er sagt, klug ist.
Ich möchte am Ende was Optimistisches sagen, damit man nicht sagt, dass wir mit unserem Podcast schlechte Laune machen. Und es ist übrigens auch ehrlich so, ja. Also auch in der Politik folgt auf Phasen des Chaoses wieder eine Zeit der Stabilität.
Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, wir müssen einfach dafür sorgen, dass diese sehr vielen schlecht gelaunten alten Männer endlich weniger zu sagen haben. Das ist mir... Ich habe das Gefühl, man so viele schlecht gelaunte Alte...
So wie wir, meinst du.
Nee, wir sind, ich meine, noch älter. Schau sie dir alle an.
Noch schlechter gelaunte.
Ja, genau. Die haben das Gefühl, es ist eh alles schon wurscht, weil sie ihr eigenes biologisches Ende ja mit dem Ende der Welt sozusagen gleichsetzen. Da haben wir neulich drüber gesprochen. Und dann, lass mal jucken, Kumpel.
Ja.
Interessant. Sehr interessant.
Er meint Herr Schirach.
Vielleicht.
Ich finde, er hat in dem Gespräch, wenn ich mich jetzt richtig erinnere, gut...
Ja, sehr gut gekonnt hat, ja. Wir wollen an dieser Stelle auf den Salon hinweisen. Das ist der Zusatzinhalt, den bekommt man, wenn man ein Abo abschließt. Das heißt, da gibt es immer noch einmal im Monat eine Folge mehr. Da sprechen wir immer ausführlich über ein Buch, das wir gemeinsam gelesen haben, diskutieren da so zwei Stunden drüber und anschließend gibt es dann noch Literatur-Tipps, Artikel-Tipps, alles, was man so gelesen haben könnte, wenn man denn möchte. Diesen Salon kann man ganz einfach buchen über Steady.
Man geht auf unsere Webseite, da ist ein goldener Button, klickt man drauf, meldet sich bei Steady an. Man kann bequemlichkeitshalber auch bei Apple und Patreon hören, falls man seine Podcasts eh mit Apple hört und der Ein-Click-Button-Lösung haben will. Bei Patreon, falls man eh schon da einen Account hat, wegen irgendwelchen amerikanischen Sachen oder so, kann man uns da auch finden, aber wir präferieren mal Steady.
Genau, das ist ganz einfach. Man kann dann auch ein Jahresabo abschließen, wenn man möchte, das ist ganz hilfreich. Es ist günstiger für die, die es abschließen, aber auch für uns, weil dann diese ganzen Zahlungsdienstleister nicht jeden Monat was abknapsen. Und man kann, darauf wollen wir auch hinweisen, denn bald ist ja Weihnachten. Man kann den Sanon auch für ein Jahr verschenken. Also nicht nur an Weihnachten generell, aber vielleicht zu Weihnachten besonders. Das ist über Steady möglich. Dann verschenkt man ein Jahrespaket und dieses Paket endet dann auch wieder. Also man hat dann nicht ein ewiges Abo dabei. Wir lesen gemeinsam das neue Buch des Ökonomen Branko Milanovic, The Great Global Transformation, National Market Liberalism in a Multi-Polar World. Und dieses Buch über diese multipolare Weltordnung ist, glaube ich, das Buch der Stunde. Also ich habe es noch nicht gelesen, aber ich bin so gespannt darauf, denn er, Branko Milanovic, ist der Experte für globale Ungleichheit, weiß also genau, wer wo was im Portemonnaie hat. Und jetzt schaut er sich natürlich auch mit dieser Brille, aber weiter über hinaus geht, an, wie verändert sich eigentlich die Welt. Und wenn wir sagen, die Welt wird gleicher, dann klingt das erst mal positiv. Aber er stellt zum Beispiel auch die Frage, werden wir er tragen können, wenn eine chinesische Mittelklasse mehr Geld im Portemonnaie hat, als wir in der Mittelklasse? Und was ist, wenn plötzlich die Kartenpreise für irgendwelche internationalen Sportevents dann teurer werden und wir sie uns vielleicht nicht mehr leisten können? Das ist nur eine Frage, die hier aufgerufen wird. Es geht viel um die Geoökonomie der Stunde. Darüber sprechen wir dann im Salon.
Sehr gut. Was wir dann noch lesen, sagen wir nochmal an vorher. Termine. Am 9. Januar bin ich in Erlangen. Abends. Gespräch mit dem Oberbürgermeister. Und ich werde mir wohl vorher in Nürnberg mal die Sachen anschauen, die es da so gibt. War noch nicht da. Also falls jemand sowieso da kommen will, sich da ein bisschen auskennt in Nürnberg.
Albrecht Dürerhaus.
Ja, das und auch Sepp Ruf, Architektur. Das ist ja nicht alles nur. Allerletzte Geschichte. Ich habe leider nur diesen einen Tag in Nürnberg, aber ich kann gleich morgens dahin und hätte dann so sechs Stunden, sollte ja irgendwie so ein bisschen reichen. Also Tipps gerne willkommen.
Und dann sage ich noch meine Termine. Ich bin am 4. Dezember in Frankfurt. Da geht es um Kulturpolitik in einem Vortrag. Am 5. ist die Studi-
Wann ist das?
Am 4.
Dezember?
Ja, 5. ist die Studio Rotgala. Da weiß ich aber nicht, ob es da noch Karten gibt. Und am 6.5. Studio Rotgala in Hamburg. Und am 6.5. bin ich 6.12. Entschuldigung, am 6.12. bin ich mit Ole Liebel in Dresden bei einem Podcastfestival. Da diskutieren wir über Meinungsfreiheit und wie man eigentlich aus einer linken Perspektive dazu stehen sollte.
Okay, sehr gut. Meinen Termin kriegt ihr auf meiner Webseite, allerdings nur auf der mobilen. Ich habe es auf der Desktop-Seite noch nicht eingebaut.
Bei mir ist alles auf der Homepage zu finden.
Gut. Außerdem sagen wir euch, Wolfgang und ich, wir haben eine Person eingestellt. Sie heißt Olivia und sie übernimmt redaktionale Tätigkeiten. Sie liest jede E-Mail, die ihr an mail.net Neue Zwanziger schickt, fasst sie uns zusammen. Falls in der E-Mail eine Frage auftaucht, wird sie uns richtig hervorgehoben, sodass wir sie dann auch mal beantworten können. Außerdem achtet ab sofort bitte auf euren Ton in den YouTube-Kommentaren, denn Olivia schreibt uns jeden Morgen eine Zusammenfassung aller YouTube-Kommentare aus den Videos, die wir in den letzten 28 Tagen veröffentlicht haben. Also immer das aktuelle.
Und auch die anderen Kommentare bei Steady und so etwas. Man kann vielleicht auch Olivia mal grüßen im Kommentar. Vielleicht möchtest du mal jemand Olivia hallo sagen. Also Olivia, die Menschen ahnen es, ist natürlich ein Produkt, das du erschaffen hast, ein Wesen, das du erschaffen hast, mittels diverser KI's. Du hast mir eben gezeigt, was du da alles miteinander verbunden hast. Das ist beeindruckend, ja.
Genau. Also es wird jeder Steady-Kommentar auf der Seite, jede Nachricht über Steady und jede E-Mail uns chronologisch aufgelistet. Längere Texte zusammengefasst, aber man kommt mit einem Klick, kann Wolfgang dann auch alles lesen. Aber typischerweise beginnen diese E-Mails immer mit Floskeln, wie toll sie den Podcast finden. Und liebe Hörer, ihr schreibt das dann in dem Moment zum ersten Mal, aber wir lesen es dann schon zum hundertsten Mal.
Nein, das ist doch gut gemeint.
Wir freuen uns sehr darüber.
Ich freue mich immer über ein liebes Wort.
Ja, das ist sehr, sehr, sehr gut.
Ich denke ja nicht nur über Effizienz in meinem Leben nach.
Genau. Ich wollte euch ja auch nur sagen, wenn ihr uns E-Mails schickt an mail.neuezwanziger.de, das wird auch im Impressum natürlich noch nachgetragen, werden die künftig von Olivia bearbeitet, sodass wir relativ zügigen Übersicht haben. Und vor allem wichtig, was wurde uns empfohlen, Texte, Bücher und so weiter. Und natürlich Fragen, die an uns gestellt werden, sodass wir dann da auch mal antworten können.
Was nicht bedeutet, dass wir auf alles antworten können, dass wir es manchmal ein bisschen aushufen. Aber wir kriegen jetzt zumindest alles sehr gut gebündelt.
Die Sichtbarkeit von Hörerrückmeldungen sind jetzt sehr viel.
Und die Fragen sind ja auch oftmals welche, die man mit in den Podcast hineinnimmt, ohne jetzt zu sagen, ich habe hier eine Frage und beantworte die. Sondern das sind natürlich alles Rückmeldungen, die wir auch so zu kennen sind, auch wenn wir dann nicht in einer E-Mail noch mal direkt noch auf Bezug nehmen.
Ich habe unterschiedliche Themen. Zum einen nur drei Clips. Ich will es aber mal abhandeln, weil jetzt so viel über Social Media und so weiter von Schirach und das ist ja alles ganz böse. Es ist tatsächlich ganz böse, aber statt Flickenteppich und so, nein, das kritisieren wir nicht. Wir gehen jetzt richtig kurz, punktuell rein. Deinen Lieblingspodcast, die Doppelgänger und Haken dran, haben das mal aufgearbeitet, so insgesamt, wie es eigentlich um Social Media steht. Zum einen zwei Clips vom Oktober aus dem Doppelgänger-Podcast.
Schätzt man den Schaden durch Online-Scams 2024 letztes Jahr?
Der Schaden durch Online, einfach nur, jemand weiß, er macht jetzt Betrüger rein und denkt sich, die Schwelle ist so niedrig, schickt man eine E-Mail raus, vielleicht fällt jemand auf den Link herein oder so. Wie groß ist der Schaden, wenn Online-Scams da stattfindet?
Milliarden, genau, rund 16,6 Milliarden US-Dollar. Das ist ohne Dunkelzimmer.
So, wir merken uns das mal. 16 Milliarden US-Dollar.
Nur, was beim FBI angezeigt wurde und nur USA. Das heißt, du kannst sofort Faktor 4 ranhängen, damit du auf den weltweiten Wert passt, damit hast du irgendwie 60 Milliarden. Das wäre interessanterweise genau der Profit von Meta, wenn ich mich nicht irre.
So, ja, das wäre genau der Profit von Meta.
Ich muss sagen, dass nicht jeder Online-Scam auf Social Media beginnt, aber da gibt es auch Studien zwischen jedem. Also es gibt widersprüchliche Studien, aber die meisten gehen davon, also die schlechtesten gehen, also nicht die schlechtesten, die mit den niedrigsten Quote gehen davon aus, dass mindestens ein Viertel auf Social Media starten inzwischen. Es gibt andere, die so eher Richtung 50 Prozent gehen. Und ich glaube, was man schon sieht, ist, dass Social Media wahrscheinlich, ich glaube, das erste Mal habe ich das so als Gedanken bei Scott Galloway tatsächlich gehört, ist wahrscheinlich wirklich, die eine der ersten so netto-negativen Technologien ist. Also bei...
Netto-negativen Technologien?...
so netto-negativen Technologien ist.
Ich habe das bei Scott Galloway nicht gehört, und ich höre eigentlich relativ viel von ihm. Also ich weiß nicht genau, aber die Idee an sich ist ja wirklich... ist ja crazy.
Also bei fossilen Energien und was weiß ich, kannste immer sagen, das hat auch so viel vorangebracht in der Menschheit, und blablabla, Pharmakologie und so weiter. Aber bei Social Media könnte man argumentieren, allein der wirtschaftliche Schaden, der durch Scams entsteht, weil Leute dadurch noch angreifbarer werden, weil du ihren Kontext kennst und so weiter. Das wird noch viel, viel schlimmer mit KI-Bots jetzt gerade werden, diese Scams. Sieht man ja auch schon. Also, allein der wirtschaftliche Schaden aus Scams übertrifft jetzt den finanziellen Gewinn von Facebook wahrscheinlich, würde ich vermuten, wenn man weltweit und dunkle Ziffer mit einbezieht.
Womit aber ja nicht jetzt der Gewinn, den jeder einzelne daraus ziehen kann, nochmal gesehen wird. Also das ist ja eine Rechnung, die jetzt Scott Galloway zwar gerne aufmacht, aber die stimmt ja nicht ganz. Also sicherlich, wenn ich jetzt nur auf diese Zahlen blicke, aber dass jeder selbst auch nochmal einen Gewinn für sich daraus hat. Es ging ja auch um netto negativ zu sein.
Netto negativ, dem steht natürlich ein Bruttogewinn gegenüber.
Aber den kannst du ja ganz schwer berechnen. Also ich habe ja jetzt keinen monetären Gewinn bei Instagram. Also ich bekomme ja von Instagram nichts ausgezahlt, trotz einer großen Follower-Scha. Aber trotzdem habe ich ja einen positiven Gewinn. Also ich sehe jetzt zum Beispiel, ja, weil ich will nur sagen, das kann man nicht beziffern. Ich kann nicht sagen, Instagram bringt mir 1.000 Euro, weil das eine andere Form von Gewinn ist, die ich daraus habe. Zum Beispiel soziale Interaktionen mit Menschen.
Ja, also die Olivia liest jetzt für uns pro Monat 100 Mails und 500 YouTube-Kommentare oder so. Das macht sie ganz automatisch. Und wir kriegen jeden Morgen einfach ein Update. Also da ist gar nichts mehr zu machen, ist alles automatisiert. So, und ich habe jetzt natürlich mit N8N und allen KI's, die es gibt und allen möglichen hier nochmal und da nochmal und so das zusammengebaut, ne. Und ehrlich gesagt, es ist ohne Grenze. Also ich kann das natürlich jetzt komplett konstruktiv für uns nutzen, dass wir einfach eine Übersicht haben für das Ding. Aber wenn ich es drauf anlegen würde und ich kann nicht programmieren, oder es ist jedenfalls nicht tiefschürfend, ich habe einfach diese KI's offen und gehe Schritt für Schritt durch. Die KI weiß auch nicht, was ich in dem Moment baue, sondern ich sage ihr nur Schritt für Schritt, was ich so will, ja. Ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen, wie das in drei Jahren abgeht auf dieser Welt.
Naja, das ist wahr.
Also diese Verknüpfung aus Social Media und du hast jetzt zu Recht diesen Vorteil. Ja, aber wir haben ja alle einen Vorteil davon, weil wir alle einzeln jetzt da teilnehmen können und so weiter. Das sind genau diese Notes, die jetzt ausgebeutet werden, dass da einfach jeder ist. So, ja, also das ist wirklich. Von daher ist diese Gedankenführung hier rein analytisch gedacht, ja. Also ich würde auch Olivia nicht verzichten, nur weil irgendwelche Omas ständig auf Scams reinfallen. Also das ist dann auch so ein bisschen das Problem der Omis. Von daher, ja, wir sind jetzt hier nicht im pragmatischen, praktischen Felde, sondern das ist einfach nur so eine Gedankenüberlegung.
Also wer Social Media so betreibt, wie es gerade betrieben wird, muss sich zumindest bewusst sein, dass er ein klar demiritorisches Business betreibt. Also was negative Gesamteffekte auf die Gesellschaft hat. Und selbst wenn du ein Ultrakapitalist bist, musst du immer noch sagen, dass höchstwahrscheinlich die negativen Effekte nicht deine persönliche Bereicherung übertreffen. Also es wäre anders formuliert, es wäre günstiger für den Staat, den Leuten ihre Profite so zu geben und sie dafür bitten, die Apps abzuschalten, weil es für die Gesamtgesellschaft von Vorteil wäre.
Das wäre eigentlich schon eine Idee.
Bisschen wie beim Kohleausstieg. Kommen die letzten 3.000 Arbeiter, wir zahlen euch nochmal eine Milliarde, zahlt ihr die aus und fertig ist. Man muss sie freikaufen aus diesem Business. Wie kommt man zu solchen Werten? Da muss ja einiges los sein auf Social Media. Hier Haken dran. Nee, vergangenen, also jetzt im November.
Und Meta schätzt intern, dass jeden Tag 15 Milliarden mal betrügerische Anzeigen ausgespielt werden. E-Commerce-Anzeigen von Betrügern, unseriöse Investmentangebote, Eleganz.
So, also, wie du sagtest, aber ich kann ja auch als Zugestellmieter teilnehmen und mir selber eine Marke aufbauen, meine Veranstaltungen bewerben, wie auch immer und so fort. Ja, alle sind jetzt da und man kann einfach eine Werbung buchen, Werbeplatz, also man wird dann überall angezeigt. Und 15 Milliarden mal am Tag wird einfach Werbung, die klar mit negativen Absichten aus, also wirklich betrügerischen Absichten ausgespielt wird. Wie kommt das?
Gale Online-Casinos, verbotene medizinische Produkte, das sind die Dinge, um die es hier geht. Und zehn Prozent der Einnahmen, also des gesamten Jahresumsatzes, das sind 16 Milliarden US-Dollar. Es geht aus diesen Dokumenten auch hervorschreibt Reuters, dass Meta mindestens drei Jahre lang versäumt hat, gegen diese Form von Anzeigen richtig vorzugehen. Ein Großteil der Betrugsfälle ging von Werbevermarktern aus, deren Verhalten so verdächtig war, dass die internen Warnsysteme auch angesprungen sind. Aber die Dokumente sagen, also es wird jetzt immer schlimmer, die Dokumente sagen, Meta sperrt diese Werbekunden nur dann, wenn die Warnsysteme mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit von mindestens 95 Prozent davon ausgehen, dass es auch wirklich Betrug ist. Was passiert, wenn die Wahrscheinlichkeit unter 95 Prozent verbleibt? Dann verlangt Meta höhere Werbepreise als Scharfe.
Das ist doch total logisch, oder? Was für Anreizsysteme.
In der Hoffnung, dass die Betrüger dann weniger Anzeigen schalten. Aber man kann es auch anders sehen. In diesem Fall verdient Meta dann einfach noch mehr Geld.
Und das heißt aber ja, dass Meta das offensichtlich erkennt.
Genau.
Also es gibt offensichtlich Methoden, um das zu erkennen.
Meta möchte das aber nicht.
Naja, nicht nur erkennen, sondern das ist ja ein Geschäftsproblem. Das ist wie, wenn man ein Spielcasino betreibt, dann weiß man um das Thema Spielsucht, aber das sind nun mal gute Kunden.
Ja, man macht den besonders bequem, den Sitz auf dem anderen Sitz. Ja, das ist wirklich brutal. Und wie gesagt, hier Haken dran. Wir haben noch ein großes Archiv. Irgendwann haben wir dafür mal Zeit. Noch ein kleines Thema, bevor ich auf ein größeres komme, das Gedenkstättenkonzept. Deutschland kümmert sich um seine Geschichte und der Kulturstaatsminister hat dazu ein Gedenkstättenkonzept. Das wurde jetzt nach fast 20 Jahren mal wieder aktualisiert. Der Deutschlandfunk hat eine kleine Nachricht dazu gemacht. Die hören wir fast vollständig, die geht ja auch nur kurz. Und wir versuchen mal diesen roten Faden, diesen Dreh da drin jetzt, der ist nicht so schwer zu finden.
Kulturstaatsminister Wolfram Weimer ist gelungen, was seiner Vorgänge...
So, das finde ich schon mal gut. Ihm ist gelungen, was Claudia Roth nicht gelang....
Claudia Roth verwehrt blieb. Die Verabschiedung eines neuen Gedenkstättenkonzepts. Die letzte Fassung stammt aus dem Jahr 2008. Wolfram Weimer stellt fest...
Seit 2008 hat sich die Welt verändert. Der zeitliche Abstand zu den Verbrechen wächst.
Die Zeitzeugen werden weniger.
Die Gesellschaft vielfältiger. Der digitale Raum prägt unser Denken.
So, die Zeitzeugen werden weniger. Wir wissen, was er im Hinterkopf hat.
Holocaust.
Nun hat Deutschland aber noch vielleicht andere Sachen, bei denen es schon lange keine Zeitzeugen mehr gibt. Was ist mit denen eigentlich? Also dieses Argument, die Zeitzeugen werden weniger. Deswegen müssen wir neu drüber nachdenken, wie wir uns um das Gedenken kümmern, greift irgendwie nur so partiell. Hier werden mal die drei Säulen genannt, um die es geht, bei was jetzt, also es geht ja vor allem um Budgetverteilung, was demnächst wie gefördert wird.
Was bleibt, ist der Fokus im Gedenkstättenkonzept auf die beiden Diktaturen auf deutschem Boden. Die Terrorherrschaft der Nationalsozialisten und die Unterdrückung in der DDR. Für die Projektförderung wurden drei neue Schwerpunkte definiert. Erstens der dringender gewordene bauliche Erhalt der historischen Gedenkstätten.
Guck ich dann in Nürnberg mal, wie es darum steht.
Zweitens will die Bundesregierung auch neue Formate der Vermittlung entwickeln. Denn die Gesellschaft ist durch Migration vielfältiger geworden und nur noch wenige Zeitzeugen sind am Leben. Gerade für junge Menschen müsse Geschichte dort zugänglich gemacht werden, wo sie sich aufhalten, im Netz. Weimer möchte den digitalen Raum zu einem Raum der Aufklärung machen. Und ein dritter Schwerpunkt, weiter wird in Vermittlung und Forschung investiert.
So, soweit so gut. Aber warum scheiterte Claudia Roth daran und was ist dem Weimer so leicht von der Hand gegangen?
Die Linke spricht von einem deutlichen Rückschritt im Verständnis deutscher Erinnerungskultur. Denn das Gedenkstättenkonzept klammert das Thema des deutschen Kolonialismus aus. Claudia Roth war damit gescheitert, die deutsche Kolonialgeschichte in die Konzeption mit einzubeziehen.
Wir wissen ja, weil wir das Manifest von Wolfram Weimer gelesen haben, dass er zum Kolonialismus, sagen wir, eine recht indifferente, wenn nicht sogar sympathisierende, naja, soweit wollen wir nicht gehen, aber er kann, ich glaube, solches und solches. Und deshalb will er natürlich nicht, dass jetzt die Kolonialgeschichte in dieser Weise präsent gemacht wird.
Aber er kennt ja seine Jobbeschreibung. Also kann man ja in vielen Dimensionen jetzt so fragen.
Naja, er ist der Beauftragte für Kultur, die irgendwie zusammenhängt mit Holocaust und DDR und Rechtsstaat. Das ist das Ding. Das wird jetzt gefördert und gemacht. Und überall, wo das nicht vorkommt, gibt es halt keine Förderung.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie...
Im Prinzip würde jetzt Schirach sagen, ja gut, dass wir das mal so machen.
Diese drei Kriterien, ganz schlimm, ganz lange her und niemand ist mehr da, gilt auch bald für den Holocaust. Also in 30 Jahren heißt es einfach, neues Gedenkstättenkonzept, war irgendwas.
Das ist ja ein Völliger.
Absolut, wir hören nochmal Wolfram Weimer.
Gedenkstätten, wo man sagt, wir beziehen uns nur auf das, es ist so was von Irrwache.
Das wird einfach ausgespart.
Wolfram Weimer fordert, die Verbrechen des Kolonialismus ernsthaft aufzuarbeiten, aber in eigenständiger Form.
Ja, nämlich ohne Budget. Das ist so eine verlogene Blödsinn. Vor allem, das fiel jetzt zeitlich fast auf den Tag mit, in Europa wird einfach mit rechtsradikaler Hilfe das Lieferkettengesetz gekillt. Ja. So, und das ist ja im Grunde Verantwortung übernahme durch koloniale Hinterlassenschaften.
Das ist Kolonialismus, ja.
Und das finde ich schon, also kein guter Weg, der hier eingeschlagen wird. Okay.
Ja, aber es ist ja ganz klar, weil die Kritik natürlich, wie jetzt von Wolfgang Weimer ist, dass alle, die sich mit Kolonialismus kritisch beschäftigen, eigentlich Netanyahu kritisieren und damit Israel hassen und damit eigentlich Antisemiten sind. Das sind ja einfach die Kaskaden, die dann da gemacht werden. Und damit ist das vom Tisch.
Ja. Also finde ich wirklich nicht gut, wollte ich hier mal vorteilen. Aladin El-Mafaalanis hat ein neues Buch geschrieben, mit dem tourt er Schirach gleich durch die Podcasts. Wir hören ihn bei Hotel Matze. Typischerweise finden wir ihn sehr gut und wir wissen, in unserer Hörerschaft gibt es viele, die das genauso sehen. Und jedem misslinkt aber mal was. Und ich denke, also ich bin sehr gespannt auf das Buch, aber schon die Vorfeldberichterstattung, die ich so sehe, oder was heißt Berichterstattung, die Vorfeld-Erarbeitung dieses Buchtextes-Themas gefällt mir nicht. Ich sehe hier Lücken im Diskurs. Ich habe es ja eben schon angemerkt. Vertrauen schön und gut, aber Glauben ist das Thema. Und wir hören mal ihn im Hotel Matze. Du hast mich gestern, nachdem du es irgendwie hörtest, auch gefragt, ja, kommt denn dieses und jenes Thema drin vor? Medienkritik, wer kritisiert wen? Wie können wir Vertrauen wieder aufbauen? Kann man Misstrauen konstruktiv nutzen, wie auch immer? Wir steigen also in einem sehr langen Gespräch mal punktuell ein, wo wir einfach wirklich nicht zustimmen können. Schon allein, weil man so schwer versteht, was er sagt.
Auch wenn die Leute ganz oft gar nicht Verschwörungstheoretiker oder Ideologen sein wollen, das geht ja nicht darum, was du intendierst, aber das führt oft dahin.
So, auch wenn die Leute gar keine Verschwörungserzählung verbreiten wollen, und er meint hier konkret Leute, die in ihrem Podcast sitzen und so tun, als wären sie Journalisten, weil sie über Themen reden, über die doch ansonsten nur Journalisten reden. Was heißt ich? Politische Berichterstattung, politische Podcasts, Gespräche so allgemein.
Wir zum Beispiel.
Er meint nicht konkret uns natürlich, aber wir wissen alle, wie die neue Medienlage funktioniert.
Ja, Matze fragt ja sogar an einer Stelle mal so nach, meinst du eigentlich mich? Genau, die Unklarheit betrifft ja alle. Aladdin El-Mafaalanis legt so Wert darauf, dass man da eine journalistische Ausbildung und alles durchlaufen haben muss, wie das ja auch in der Wissenschaft sei. Und in der Wissenschaft kritisieren sich die Wissenschaftler und hier die Journalisten. Und dann sagt Matze Hische, ja, aber ich habe ja keine journalistische Laufbahn, aber ich mache ja trotzdem jetzt diesen Podcast. Und da versucht er dann nochmal zu sagen, nein, nein, nein, du bist jetzt nicht Gemeinte, aber es bleibt alles ein bisschen ungewiss.
Genau. Das ist ein echtes Problem, denn wir können jetzt nicht jeden Diskurs über, ja, sie wissen schon, was er meint, laufen lassen.
Ja, und auch mit diesem Ruf zu Experten kommt man in ganz vielen Bereichen nicht weiter. Es gibt nicht, also es gibt viele Leute, die...
Wir hören uns ja gleich konkret, wie er es formuliert, und dann können wir es ja punktuell kritisieren. Also dieser erste Clip hier, den ich ausgesucht habe, er spricht über Medienarbeit.
Auch wenn die Leute ganz oft gar nicht Verschwörungstheoretiker oder Ideologen sein wollen, das geht ja nicht darum, was du intendierst, aber das führt oft dahin. Also es führt oft dahin, dass die halt ganz viele Sachen nicht gecheckt haben, dann eine für sich total plausible Erklärung haben und die so als Konkurrenz einbringen. Und dann ist es auch so ein Klassiker, dass man so Fragen stellt. Warum ist das eigentlich? Und findet ihr nicht auch das? Und ist ja nicht auch das? Das ist irgendwas zwischen, die Fragen kannst du stellen, aber die haben andere schon gestellt und beantwortet. Dir gefällt offenbar die Antwort nicht, aber die Fragen sind nicht neu. Also das könnte man so sehen und manchmal hat es auch, wirkt es wie Paranoia.
Erzähl, also du redest, also wenn ich das jetzt richtig, du redest etwas nebulös gerade. Dir geht es jetzt gerade um, also man könnte ja auch sagen, du redest über mich. Könnte man ja sagen. Also ich habe, also ich weiß, ich ahne, du redest nicht über mich, aber man könnte das jetzt auch so verstehen.
Ja, genau. Und das ist nämlich eines der großen Probleme. Wenn man so eine Kritik anführt, in der das Wortvorschwerungstheorie und so vorkommt, dann wäre es ganz gut zu wissen, über wen man redet.
Ja.
Und nicht so Leute, die so nachfragen und alles in Zweifel ziehen und nochmal so noch eine weitere Frage stellen, dann denke ich mir, ja, das ist eigentlich so eine Art, wie man auf Dinge zugeht.
Wenn Leute in ihren Podcasts ein Verhalten zeigen, was wir ihnen bei den Schülern antrainiert haben, weil wir es uns von ihnen wünschen, in der Frage, wenn ihr es nicht wisst, egal, ob schon jemand anders die Frage gestellt hat, fragt bitte selber, bis ihr es verstanden habt. Wenn es jemand anders verstanden hat, aber ihr noch nicht, reicht das noch nicht, du musst die Arbeit selber schreiben und so weiter. Das ist genau dieses Verhalten, das wir von Leuten wollen, das wünschen wir uns, das ist das Ergebnis erfolgreicher Sozialisation. So, dass das heute stattfindet, ist richtig so. Und sehr unterstützenswert.
Ein großes Problem ist, dass sehr oft die Fragen nicht gestellt werden. Wir haben jetzt gerade zwei Stunden Schirach hinter uns gebracht und fragen uns, wo sind die Fragen, die man eigentlich stellen müsste.
Und es ist auch ganz wichtig, nur weil heute viele am journalistischen, medialen, was weiß ich, wir reden über Sachen, Dinge teilnehmen. Heißt das noch lange nicht, dass irgendwer entschuldigt ist für irgendwelche Ansprüche, denen man nicht mehr genügt? Wenn die Tagesschau nicht funktioniert, wie die Tagesschau funktionieren sollte, und sie funktioniert ja derzeit, wie die Tagesschau funktionieren sollte, aber wir kennen ja andere Nachrichtensendungen, die versuchen auch so tagesschauartig zu sein und da gelingt es dann nicht. So, wenn die Tagesschau mal nicht mehr funktionieren sollte, wie schon die Tagesthemen nicht mehr funktionieren, dann hat das gar nichts damit zu tun, was sonst noch stattfindet. Ja. So, das ist dann völlig egal. Das blenden wir alles aus. Und Kritik an den Tagesthemen ist dann Kritik an den Tagesthemen. Die kann klug sein, die muss aber nicht klug sein. Die kann auch einfach so in den Raum gebrüllt werden. Leute sind unzufrieden. Unzufriedenheit kann man sich nicht wegwünschen durch eine appellative Ansage, indem man einfach sagt, ey, ist ja keine Ahnung, kennst dich da nicht aus, wie auch immer. Also hier schon mal völlig falsch abgebogen. Und ich finde in so einem Gespräch, alle Alarmglocken auf Rot und Laut, wenn der Podcaster selbst gerade anmerkt, sorry, das klang jetzt sehr kritisch, redest du eigentlich über mich. Also ich weiß, du redest nicht über mich, aber ich wollte es trotzdem mal, ich komme nicht umhin, das hier anzuwerken kurz. Dann ist schon irgendwie so, dann ist ein bisschen unklar, worum es geht. Und Mafalani stellt das jetzt mal klar.
Also erst mal, dass du glaubst, dass ich das meine, was du machst, das ist völlig daneben interpretiert. Also ich habe es tatsächlich ausgedrückt.
Das sagt jetzt Mafalani einfach, aber was waren noch mal die Kriterien, warum das jetzt für Matze nicht gilt, was gerade und so.
Ich habe es noch nicht so verstanden.
Wenn du jetzt einen Podcast hättest, wo du die Welt aus deiner Sicht deutes, und immer eine Gegendeutung zu dem, was öffentlich besprochen wird, dann wäre es das. Aber du stellst ja Fragen und oft sitzen ja hier Leute, die voll den Plan haben.
Das lässt sich überhaupt nicht operationalisieren, was Herr Kamm gesagt hat.
Also dann darf man auch nicht, weiß ich nicht, kann man nicht mit Heiner Flassbeck sprechen, der widerspricht den meisten Ökonomen in Deutschland.
Und zwar durchgehend. Da wird überhaupt gar kein grüner Grasheim grün gelassen. Ja, das alles Verrottung.
Dann muss man sagen, dann geht das nicht. Und dann ist das alles irgendwie Verschwörungstheorie oder schwierig.
Ja, und ich finde auch, wir sind hier gerade bei paradigmatischen Fragestellungen.
Ja.
Wenn das Vermögen von Herr Schirach für die Probleme, die er beschreibt, nicht herangezogen wird, bleiben diese Probleme, wie sie sind.
Alle Details darüber hinaus sind völlig egal. Es ist eine fundamentale Fragestellung. So, und wenn man diese fundamentale Fragestellung aufwirft, wird automatisch alles zur Kritik. Alles. Dann fängt man nicht an mit, ja, die AfD, um ein anderes Thema zu machen, die hat ja doch eine ganz gute Rentenpolitik. Weil nein, die will Leute im Mittelmeer absichtlich töten. So, da ist egal, was sie für eine Rentenpolitik macht. Also es ist einfach ein, das Fundament stimmt dann nicht. So ist das hier auch. Von daher ist dieses, also wenn die Kritik zu groß, zu weiträumig und zu irgendwas ist, dann ist man auf dem Felder. Und das ist auch die Frage, welchem? So, ja, also sehr schwierig alles. Jetzt kommt ein Punkt, du hast ihn eben schon angesprochen. Wir hören uns das mal an. Es ist wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr schwer, hier verständnisvoll mit diesem Podcast umzugehen.
Keiner kann mich kontrollieren in der Qualität meiner Arbeit, außer...
So, und damit meint er jetzt sich als Wissenschaftler. Keiner kann ihn und seine Arbeit, die wissenschaftliche Arbeit kritisiert.
Anderen, anderen Wissenschaftlern.
Außer anderen.
Keiner macht das.
Außer anderen Wissenschaftlern.
In der Qualität meiner Arbeit, außer anderen, anderen Wissenschaftlern. Keiner macht das. Kein Richter, kein Politiker, niemand kann, der nicht, jetzt bei uns, bei mir sogar, der nicht Soziologe oder Soziologin ist oder Migrationsforscher oder Bildungsforscher, wenn du das nicht irgendwie bist. Und vielleicht, ich gebe mich noch dazu, die eine oder andere Wissenschaftsjournalistin. Und dann, es hört auf. Dann kann keiner mehr dazu irgendwie. Einen Moment.
Alladin El-Mafaalanis schreibt Bücher in Publikumsverlagen. Die lesen mehr Leute als Soziologen und die eine Wissenschaftsjournalistin. Sondern das sind ja Bücher, die sich an ein breites Publikum richten. Sollen die jetzt einfach das Buch nehmen und armen nach der Lektüre sagen, so ist es, ich kann eh nicht widersprechen? Genau. Warum soll man das nicht können? Ja, man kann jetzt sagen, wo kann man in die Details einsteigen? Und wenn man jetzt nicht mal ein Semester Statistik gemacht hat, wird man vielleicht Schwierigkeiten haben, irgendeine Umfrage nochmal in allen methodischen Fragen kritisch zu beleuchten. Aber wenn doch jemand interveniert mit einem Sachbuch und sagt, wir brauchen mehr Vertrauen oder wir brauchen mehr dies und das, dann ist es doch eigentlich Kern der Demokratie, dass jeder einen Widerspruch formulieren kann. Und da kann man doch nicht sagen, das ist jetzt nur irgendwie in einem kleinen Kreis vorbei. Das wäre genauso, wenn ich sage, also bitte Filmanalysen kritisieren von mir, nur diejenigen, die Filmwissenschaftler sind. Und dabei bin ich aber selbst kein Filmwissenschaftler. Ah, das ist ja doof. Wer könnte mich ja noch kritisieren? Vielleicht nur Filmkritiker dürfen Filmkritiker kritisieren.
Also wir haben ja Laborwissenschaften. Und ich dachte hier so ein bisschen, als ich das hörte, weil er dann noch so diese, vielleicht die ein oder andere Journalistin so, dass er so dieses, der Drosten Podcast, und Christian Drosten bedankt sich da noch mal für die sehr guten Fragen aus der NDR Wissenschaftsredaktion.
Ja, so.
Nur, da hat man Fragen gestellt, die im Labor beantwortet werden können und nirgendwo sonst. Dazu braucht man einen Wissenschaftler, der mit dem Virus nicht diskutiert, sondern es einfach untersucht und uns dann die Beobachtungsergebnisse mitteilt. Hier läuft es also sehr über Experimente, Laborsituation, Falsifizierung. Ein Soziologe darf sowas niemals sagen. Ein Soziologe hat kein Labor. Ein Soziologe hat auch keine Falsifizierung. Ein Soziologe hat allein die Plausibilität. Und er muss für seine Argumentation werben wie ein Politiker um Zustimmung. Und das klingt vielleicht ein bisschen blöd und unattraktiv. Wir würden alle gerne ins Labor. Aber wer will kein Labor? Wir können allenfalls mal ein bisschen Operationalisierung und eine Frage stellen, ein bisschen Demoskopie, aber schon Teufelsküche. Und auch das Virus, wenn es das Labor verlässt, wird es heikel.
Ja, das hat sich ja dann gezeigt. Das war ja auch genau dann oft der Punkt, bei dem Drosten sagte, ja das ist eine Frage, die müssen sie an die Politik richten.
Genau, da sind jetzt politische Entscheidungen zu treffen. Da muss nämlich Interessensausgleich abge-... Also da kann man mit Leuten diskutieren. Mit dem Virus kann man nicht diskutieren, aber es ist wirklich nur in der Petrischale, nur in diesem Moment und nur, wenn man genau weiß, was man da gezüchtet hat, kann man Aussage treffen. So und jetzt kann man dann wissenschaftliche Journalistinnen erklären und dann freut man sich, dass sie eine gute Anschlussfrage gestellt haben. Damit hat dieser Medien-Teil gut funktioniert. Aber warum Mafaalanis das hier so für sich reklamieren, ist mir völlig unklar und wohin er jetzt abbiegt. Das ist für mich gerade noch als Gedankengebäude vielleicht okay, aber ich kann es mir nicht ganz erklären.
Ich hoffe aber, dass, wenn ich das gerade sagen darf, wir haben stark diese positivistische Haltung gehabt, hier MyLab und so, die alle sagen, Listen to the Science. Und als würde die Wissenschaft dann selbst schon die Antwort hervorbringen und dann ist das so. Also wir können noch hier sagen, es gibt vielleicht unhintergehbares, aber das ist gar nicht so viel, wenn wir bedenken, über was wir alle sonst noch reden können. Und wir haben ja jetzt so viele soziologische Ansätze in den vergangenen Monaten im Salon besprochen. Ja, unter anderem Kumka, Amlinger Nachtwei, wir hatten Reckwitz. Und dann können wir natürlich darüber reden, auch kritisieren, welche Schwerpunkte gesetzt werden. Zu fragen wäre, warum wird da nicht mehr oder weniger Empirie, welche Fragen werden eigentlich den Probanden gestellt. Das sind ja alles Bereiche, in die wir hineingehen, wo wir sagen können, als aufmerksame Leser können wir das tun.
Ansonsten, wenn wir uns hier in die völlig fehlgeleitete Operationalisierungs-Labor-Ecke verirren als Politikwissenschaftler, Soziologen, Kommunikationswissenschaftler, wie auch immer, dann könnte man wirklich einfach Argumentation machen, wie die reden in diesem Podcast immer so darüber, dass die Deutschen so arm sind. Also ich habe Beel in Brasilien gesehen, da wollte keiner bleiben. Die sind alle wieder hier zurück.
Punkt.
Damit ist das Argument gemacht. Nur, das ist ja nicht, wie wir politische Diskussionen führen. So, jetzt MF macht hier die Abbiegung, nachdem er uns sagte, er ist im Grunde unangreifbar, außer von Soziologen selbst.
Die eine oder andere Wissenschaftsjournalistin. Und dann es hört auf. Dann kann keiner mehr dazu irgendwie was beitragen. Das funktioniert nicht.
So, wenn man als Soziologe Bücher schreibt zum Thema Bildung, Sozialisation, Kinderarmut, was auch immer, dann will man, dass sich sehr viele Leute, die mit Soziologie gar nichts am Hut haben, dazu verhalten. Dass dann auch kritische Stimmen kommen, ja, so ist das halt. Aber hier als Soziologe zu sagen, da kann keiner was dazu sagen. Also wenn ich mein wissenschaftliches Werk zum Thema Kinderarmut vorlege, warum mache ich dann eigentlich die ganzen Abendveranstaltungen mit nichtsoziologischem Publikum, mit der Hoffnung, dass auch mal ein Politiker dabei ist?
Ja, ja, ja, dann muss man es machen, wie in naturwissenschaftlichen Bereichen ist das. Also da machen jetzt die sich mit höherer Mathematik oder was beschäftigen, die machen jetzt keine bunten Abende, an denen sie mit dem SPD Ortsverein diskutieren, weil die sagen, ja gut, das ist jetzt ein Bereich, in dem kann ich mich noch mit 20 anderen Experten drüber unterhalten und gucken, ob wir das mathematische Rätsel lösen oder nicht. Und das war's. Aber in dem Gefilde sind wir ja hier nicht. Und auch die Biologen können so vorgehen. Ich hatte mal so eine Diskussion verfolgt zwischen zwei Herzchirurgen. Das war sehr lustig, sich anzuheben, was die da sich an den Kopf werfen. Ich habe kein Wort verstanden. So, aber das sind dann deren Fachdiskurse.
Ja, also man kann klinische Soziologie machen. Ja, zum Beispiel im Beraterkontext. Der Chef beauftragt dich dann und sagt feuerfrei. Also sie sagen jetzt hier, wie wir uns strukturieren, oder machen wir das? Und nicht immer braucht man sozusagen so viel lebendiges Feedback. Manchmal liegt es auch einfach offensichtlich da. Und dann muss man einfach nur mal jetzt die Reform machen. Aber das ausgerechnet Mafaalanis, der nun genau nicht so eine Soziologie macht, sondern der immer die Anschlüsse sucht, jetzt so eine Abkanzlung hier stattfindet, das verstehe ich einfach nicht.
Wir müssen uns also selbst kontrollieren. Und wir müssen also selbst misstrauisch sein. Also und das bin ich wirklich. Ich bin, das ist dann auch immer ganz witzig, misstrauisch, so nett ich Kollegen finde auf so Kongressen, immer misstrauisch. Was haben die geschrieben? Wie haben die das analysiert? Und so weiter und so fort. Und das sind die selbst auch. Das ist die Stärke des Systems. So und jetzt kommen wir zu dem Punkt. Man kann dem System nur vertrauen, wenn man dem den misstrauischen Leuten im System vertraut.
So das macht keinen Sinn. Also ich vertraue einem System, dass ich nicht durchblicke. Und jetzt sind wir mal in diesem naiven, die Institution ist kompliziert. Ich kann die nicht verstehen, also muss ich ihr vertrauen. Das kann ich machen. Aber dieses Vertrauen baut sich nicht darüber auf, dass relativ viele sich auskennende Kritiker in diesem System Misstrauen formulieren, von dem ich denke, das ist aber plausibel. Sondern genau umgedreht. Ich gehe in den Supermarkt, in dem gerade niemand laut Kritik äußert, in dem sich die Mitarbeiter gut verstehen, in dem es gerade keinen Anlass gibt für Kritik. Und so ist das auch im Wissenschaftsbetrieb. Nur weil jemand kurz und klein geschossen wird, heißt das noch nicht, dass diejenigen, die jemanden kurz und klein schießen, dann plötzlich, ah ja, dann gilt denen jetzt mein Vertrauen, weil die haben den so schön kurz und klein geschossen, da blieb ja kein Satz stehen nach der Aussprache. So, das ist doch nicht der Modus, in dem es funktioniert. Also ich verstehe gar nicht, wie man auf so eine Idee kommt. So ein, okay, wir müssen einen Vertrauensdiskurs machen, aber wie Herr Schirach schon sagte, wir leiden ja an Misstrauen, also nutzen wir jetzt das Misstrauen, aber konstruktiv, wir vertrauen also Leuten, denen wir misstrauen, innerhalb Systeme, die wir nicht durchschauen.
Ja.
Das kann man zwar so sagen, aber das ergibt keinen Sinn.
Lass mich noch mal gerade was zum Vertrauen sagen mit Blick auf Politik, weil das wird hier alles so miteinander vermischt, was überhaupt nicht sein kann. Also die eine Sache ist ja zum Beispiel, bei einem systemischen Vertrauen gehe ich davon aus, dass fast alle Politiker in Deutschland korrupt sind. Das wäre ja jetzt so ein grundsätzliches Misstrauen gegenüber allen, die da herrschen in so einer konkreten Weise, dass ich sage, alles was die tun, tun sie eigentlich, um in die eigene Tasche zu wirtschaften. Der Auffassung bin ich nicht. So, wir haben in und wie der Fälle und wir nennen sie hier nicht, weil wir keine Anwaltspost haben wollen. Aber ja, alle Namen sind ja irgendwie so im Raume. Das passiert, aber wenn wir das international vergleichen und wenn wir auch sehen, gerade jetzt eine Merkel Kanzlerschaft oder so, die hat sich nicht dadurch ausgezeichnet, dass man da irgendwie sagen kann, da haben Leute in die eigene Tasche gewirtschaftet. So, da haben wir am Ende darüber diskutiert, ob irgendein Bundespräsident mal zwei Hotelzimmerrechnungen für jemand übernommen hat oder so. Also das ist alles nicht relevant in dem Sinne. Bei einer Trump-Regierung sieht das schon ein bisschen anders aus. Aber bleiben wir mal hier in Deutschland. Also dieses Misstrauen wäre eigentlich nicht angebracht. Wenn du mir jetzt die Frage stellst, vertraue ich darauf, dass die Politiker sich vor allem bemühen, das Leben der Arbeitnehmer und der Familien besser zu machen, dann würde ich sagen, nee, darauf vertraue ich auf keinen Fall. Ich bin ja nicht blöde oder naiv. Und das ist aber was anderes. Und hier kommt aber alles, wird so zusammengemischt, dass wir am Ende so sagen, ja, wir wollen vertrauen, also wir wollen so im Allgemeinen glauben, äh, der liebe Gott wird es schon richten oder ja. Also eigentlich will man so ein, deswegen habe ich eben gesagt, die Leute reden von Vertrauen, sie wollen aber eigentlich Gehorsam. Ja. Ja, das ist genau das, was man früher sagte. Der Fürst sagt, ich hab's hier schon häufiger zitiert, der Fürst sagt zum Pfarrer halt du sie dumm, ich halt sie arm.
Ja, genau.
So und das ist genau das, was wir nicht brauchen, diese Art von Gehorsam. Das will ich auch noch mal an einem Beispiel deutlich machen, das fiel mir jetzt ein. Du warst ja mal im Presseclub, da ging es auch um das Thema Rente. Und da können wir uns ja mal die Frage stellen, vertraue ich darauf, dass die Journalisten, die häufig im Fernsehen sind, die Interessen derer vertreten, die die unteren 90 Prozent sind. Machen wir mal eine ganz große Gruppe. Und dann würde ich sagen, ne, darauf vertraue ich auch nicht. Da wurde über die Mütterrente geredet von deinen Journalisten-Kollegen, als hätte die CSU in einem Anflug von Wahnsinn einfach unendlich viel Geld über die Mütter ausgeschüttet und man weiß gar nicht warum.
Neun Euro pro Frau.
Und dann denkt man, ne, die bekommen jetzt so ein bisschen mehr, wo sie eh schon nicht besonders gut dastehen. Und du hast dann auch gesagt, dass das wirklich verachtenswert ist, dass das so über Mütter und deren Rente gesprochen wird und so getan wird, als würde die CSU nur irgendwelche verrückten Wahlgeschenke machen. Und genau da ist auch wieder Misstrauen angesagt.
Ja.
Also es ist sowieso und das ist eine der großen soziologischen Fragestellungen, die man immer mitführen muss, finden wir ja gerade irgendwas gut. Vertrauen ist nicht einfach immer, wenn Vertrauen da ist, ist es gut. Bei Demokratie, okay, das verstehe ich mittlerweile so ein bisschen, dass man da so einen affirmativen Einschlag hat. Also deshalb auch auf Fragestellung geschuldet, ja. Aber Vertrauen. Wir alle haben Freunde und Menschen in unseren Kreisen, bei denen es völlig klar ist, das funktioniert ja nur, wenn man da so nicht ganz vertrauen einfach. Nein, die Tickets für heute Abend für alle zehn Leute bringt bitte nicht Dings mit. Sondern das macht mal jemand anders. So. Und das muss man dann regeln. Das heißt, noch lange nicht.
Mir vertraust du dann, dass ich dir mitdenke, sogar noch ausgetrocknet.
Genau. Und das heißt aber noch lange nicht, dass irgendetwas hier weniger wert ist, weil man das Vertrauen des einen nicht im selben Maße dem anderen gegenüber auch haben kann, sondern man findet dann einfach einen anderen Modus und gut. Wenn wir uns einfach alle nur vertrauen würden, bräuchten wir gar keine Demokratie.
Genau.
Wir haben die Demokratie, weil das Misstrauen nun mal das Ding ist.
Wir müssten keine Verkehrsregeln, nichts haben.
Genau. Und von daher sind diese ganzen Diskurse, die wir bis hierher von Schirach, jetzt von Mafaalanis so, das ist alles so ein bisschen schief und krumm. Das ist alles, ja, in den Medien muss man immer so abstrahier, dann findet man so Grundbegriffe, die bedeuten irgendwas. Aber wenn das Fundament da nicht stimmt, wenn das irgendwie schief ist, dann steht das einfach alles schief und dann kommt man da auch nicht weiter. Und Mafaalanis versucht jetzt noch mal seinen Punkt bis hierhin so ein bisschen zusammen zu fassen.
Also man muss den, also ich, also die Leute müssen mir als misstrauischen Berufsvertreter vertrauen, sonst funktioniert das System nicht. Das heißt, ich bin misstrauisch vom Berufswegen und nur ich und meine Kollegen können das System kontrollieren und das System funktioniert aber nur, kann nur stabil bleiben, wenn alle außerhalb des Systems den Misstrauischen im System vertrauen.
Ich versuche, dem mal entgegenzukommen. Wenn man so ganz eng abstecken würde, dann wäre das ja das Feld, man reicht einen Aufsatz ein, der in einer Zeitschrift, in einer Fachzeitschrift publiziert werden soll, dann hat man das Peer-Review-Verfahren und dort gehen alle in den Text hinein oder in das Paper hinein. Der Autorenname ist nicht sichtbar und jetzt versucht man zu verifizieren oder falsifizieren, je nachdem, welchen Ansatz man da pflegt. Und dann kann man sagen, aufgrund eines solchen Verfahrens, das durch mehrere Hände geht, es gewährleistet, dass eine entsprechende Qualität bei den Publikationen da ist. Aber sobald wir in das Feld gehen, man schreibt Bücher für Suhrkamp, DTV oder Rowold oder so, äußert sich in Vorlesungen, erhält irgendwelche Podiumsdiskussionen ab und so, ist das alles nicht so der Fall. Und selbst da in diesem Peer-Review-Verfahren gibt es sehr unglaublich viele Fallstrecke, die auch noch mal vorhanden sind.
Also das Peer-Review-Verfahren hat mit Vertrauen gar nichts zu tun.
Ne, das ist ein Misstrauensverfahren.
Renommee, Reputation, das ist Budget, alles Mögliche.
Ja, da geht es auch nicht nur um die Inhalte, da muss man ja auch noch mal die Abstufungen haben.
Genau, also das Vertrauensthema an sich ist schon mal ganz anders. Und dann muss man einfach ganz konkret sich den pragmatischen Fall mal anschauen. Es kommt ein Virus, Leute werden krank, Leute brauchen Hilfe, Leute hören drosten das Podcast. Dann kommt jemand und sagt, ich habe da Kritik von so einem anderen Typen gehört. Dann heißt es, aber der ist ja gar kein Arzt. Doch, doch, doch, doch, der ist auch Arzt. Ja, aber der ist ja kein Virologe. Doch, der ist auch Virologe. Ja, aber der ist ja kein Virologe für Corona-Viren. Ja, doch, damit hat er auch schon mal zu tun gehabt. Aber da arbeitet er ja nicht jetzt gerade im Labor, oder? Nee, der hat nur noch einen Lehrstuhl. So, ah ja, siehste, kein Insider. Teufels Küche.
Ja, das ist nämlich diese irre Debatte, dass man dann plötzlich eins drauf bekam, wenn man Kekole zitierte, als sei das jetzt völlig...
Streh, Kekole, menschenverachtend. Ja, Journalisten trauen sich das Urteil zu, diese Leute sind menschenverachtend.
Ja, weil sie dann plötzlich den Namen irgendwann... Gut, wir hatten natürlich auch Menschen mit einem Doktortitel, die irgendwas völlig an der Realität vorbei erzählt haben. Das kann passieren.
Ein Doktortitel erringst du, indem du dich drei Jahre von der Welt wegschließt, um in irgendeiner Bibliothek eine Monographie zu schreiben.
So, ja. Aber genau diese Beispiele zeigen dann, dass wir ja doch da differenzieren müssen. Wenn wir aber diese enge Definition verfolgen, dann können wir sagen, dann gibt es nur Drosten.
Genau. Und es gab ja dann auch wirklich nur Drosten.
Für viele, ja.
So.
Aber... Und irgendwann mussten wir ja dann Drosten gegen die Drosten-Anhänger verteidigen, weil die ja nicht mehr Drosten richtig zugehört haben.
Genau. Plötzlich gab es nur noch so einen idealisierten Drosten. Und der eigentliche Drosten, da verließt dann schon das Bild. Okay, jetzt wird es aber heikel, denn wir haben ja eben schon kritisiert, also die Medien, die laufen immer wunderbar. Alles geht schief, außer dass man sich in den Medien stattfindet. Das ist immer alles total Nachfrage von Matze.
Wenn du möchtest, würde ich es jetzt nämlich zurück zu den Medien nehmen wollen, genau an dieser Stelle, weil nach meinem Empfinden ist, die Medienkritik findet nur außerhalb der Medien statt und nicht innerhalb der Medien. Das heißt, und das ist natürlich für mich was persönliches.
Also, das ist aber nur keine Kritik. Medienkritik findet immer innerhalb der Medien statt. Das ist ja die Frage, was sind Medien?
Er meint jetzt, die Zeit kritisiert nicht die Zeit.
Er meint der innere Mainstream und so.
Diese Bücher dazu gibt es ja auch.
Das heißt, wenn 500 Medien über einen Fall wie Tilo Misch geschrieben, und der war letzte Woche hier, deswegen ist es so aktuell und er ist ein Freund von mir, und nur drei fragen ihn an, weil zweite Quelle, der ist ja journalistisch auf jeden Fall wichtig, dann zeigt das, da haben Medien wirklich Mist gebaut. Und ich habe noch nichts davon gelesen, irgendwo. Außer vielleicht, dass ich mal darüber rede oder ein anderer Podcaster.
So, ich will wieder anmerken, ein Nichthandeln, ein Dulden und so weiter, so hoch dramatisiert als, das ist eine aktive Handlung, sowieso schon schwierig. Niemand muss sich zu Tilo Misch geverhalten, nur weil er da über öffentlichen Druck bei seinen Chefs nicht durchkam oder was auch immer. Also eh schon mal ein komisches Thema. Aber ich finde, ein guter Einschlag, um Mafaalanis jetzt einfach zu reizen auch, sich dazu zu verhalten, weil das ist ja nun primäre Aufgabe der Soziologie. Sich eben nicht ins Labor davonzustehlen, sondern aussagefähig zu sein zum Thema. Ach so, du hast jetzt gerade was zum Thema Kritik, Medien und Systeme gesagt. Also ich habe immer so einen Fall. Kannst du mir den mal deuten. Wir haben natürlich jetzt schon wieder Tidumisch gehört, auch keinen Bock darüber zu reden, aber Matze hakt ein bisschen nach.
Was passiert, wenn jetzt jemand in der Talkshow geht oder hier sitzt oder wo auch immer und sagt, Zukunft?
Dieser Podcast ist noch langsamer als der, wenn Schirach da sitzt.
Also ich mache mir gerade Sorgen, aber ich bin mir sehr sicher, dass das alles gut wird.
Wird ausgelacht.
Wir glauben ja denjenigen, die skeptisch sind, die misstrauisch sind, den messen wir automatischen Hören-Intelligenzquotienten zu. Wir denken, der hat sich ja offensichtlich wirklich damit auseinandergesetzt und er weiß es besser.
So, das ist natürlich hochinteressant jetzt, denn jetzt wird so ein bisschen eingezahlt, was gute Soziologen dazu sagen, Kumpka zum Beispiel. Ja, die Medien haben eine eigene Logik. Die suchen die Kontroverse. Aber sie machen das paradox. Sie hoffen immer, dass es nur ein Schaufenster Kontroverse ist. Und dann sagen sie, guckt mal, wie frech der Seehofer war. Der hat die Merkel voll lange dastehen lassen. Megakonflikt in der Union. Wenn der Konflikt aber nicht Schaufenster ist, sondern echt, im Sinne von die junge Union, da ist eine Eigendynamik, wir kennen die auch gar nicht, könnte sein, dass die einfach nicht zustimmen im Bundestag. Dann ist der Konflikt echt. Und dann sind Journalisten nicht mehr in der Lage, uns zu erklären, was gerade passiert, nämlich Bundestag muss irgendwie neu gewählt werden oder was auch immer. Mehrheiten sind unklar, Minderheitsregierung. Was dazu führt, dass sie alle komplett durchdrehen und nicht mehr das Klein-Klein sehen, sondern nur noch die große Krise. Ja, also man zieht sich dann zurück wie Schirach so. Nee, Details sind gar nicht mehr wichtig. Das ist jetzt riesige Krise einfach, obwohl Medien jetzt gerade ins Detail gehen müssten, um ihre eigene, wir suchen immer die Kontroverse, aber sie darf nur eine Schaufenster-Kontroverse sein, zurückzubinden an das, was sie eigentlich berichterstatten. So und es findet aber nicht statt, weil das können ja die Medien nicht. Also findet keine Medienkritik statt innerhalb der Medien. Und dann sagt Matze, die kommt dann, wenn überhaupt von außen. Und das finde ich dann wieder witzig, weil Journalisten sitzen jetzt in der ARD-Aktuellredaktion, schreiben dort einen Text für tagesschau.de, der hat 15.000 Klicks und alle sagen, das ist der innere Mainstream, da kommt es drauf an. Wenn Precht aber ein neues Buch macht, möchte der das ordentlich promotet haben, fragt also nicht bei der Tagesschau-Redaktion nach, könnte mich mal irgendwie platzieren oder so. Sondern geht mal zu Hotel Matze, wo er hundertmal mehr Reichweite hat, als wenn jetzt irgendwas die ARD machen würde und so. Das gilt aber als Äußeres, also als Außen, nicht Medien, so. Und damit ist alles im Chaos. Also wenn wir überhaupt eine Megakrise haben, dann ist das die des Journalismus und des Medienbetriebs. Aber nicht der Wirtschaft, auch nicht der Rente. Das ist alles, das ist keine Krise. Das ist ein Konflikt zwischen Interessengruppen, der klar benannt werden kann. Innerhalb von fünf Minuten alles ist klar. Aber dieses Mediengefüge, das Matze hier gerade so aufgemacht hat, latent auch so ein bisschen, indirekt formuliert, das ist die eigentliche Krise. Weshalb sich auch alle so in Krise fühlen, weil was wir über die Welt wissen, wissen wir durch die Massenmedien. Und die Massenmedien sind halt in Krise gerade. Also ein operativer Krise. Mafaalanis versucht da jetzt so ein Buch zu platzieren mit so einem Gespräch.
Du erinnerst dich ja, es gab jetzt vor ein paar Tagen eine Äußerung von einer Beraterin von Obama, die ist vor einer Organisation aufgetreten, die, glaube ich, israelische Anliegen verfolgt in den USA. Und dann hat sie gesagt, ja, wir sind in einer großen Krise. Weiß nicht, ob du das mitbekommen hast. Und dann sagte sie, ja, früher, da war das ja so, da hat man amerikanische Medien gehabt. Und die waren nicht radikal. Und die waren alle so in der Mitte. Und man hatte auch das, was sonst in der Welt vorging, nicht so wahrgenommen. Und das sei jetzt dummerweise anders geworden. Also sie sagt, früher konnten wir das alles besser einhegen. Also da wurde einfach zu Krieg und Frieden und wie wir uns zu Nord-Ost und was gehalten wurden, einfach die eine Meinung gesendet in leichter Variation. Das ist aber echt blöd, dass das nicht mehr geht. Und natürlich schuld, soziale Medien und so etwas, kommt sie damit an. Aber das ist eigentlich so dieser Wunsch, der, glaube ich, auch bei ganz vielen Medienleuten da ist. Mensch, das war aber noch schön, als wir einfach da den einen Ton gesetzt hatten und dann haben wir uns nach dem ausgerichtet.
Genau. Und in deren Sicht, ja, Krise. Wir erleben sie, alle, wir fühlen sie, weil die Medien in einer Krise sind. Sie wissen nicht mehr genau, wie es funktioniert. Und da haben wir sowieso so ein, wir wollen relevant sein, wir wollen aber auch reichweitenstark sein, dann passt das wieder nicht und so. Ja, alles geht runter und drüber. Matze und Mafaalanis mehr anderen durch dieses Thema. Es ist wirklich schwierig, dem zu folgen. Und dann kommen sie einfach auf, Vertrauen in den Staat zu sprechen. Weil das ist ja sozusagen das, was man machen muss. Wenn man nicht weiter weiß, kritisiert man, was man als Staat vor sich sieht.
Also das System wird instabil. Das sehe ich. Also das ist es noch nicht. Also es ist noch nicht so instabil, dass es schon wirklich wackelt.
So, pass auf, wir hören das nochmal. Du interpretierst das jetzt.
Ich will nur gerade sagen, es war Sarah Hurwitz, die diese Äußerung mal hat. Man kann diesen Clip finden. Das ist schon sehr kurios, was ihr davon sich gebt.
Wir hören jetzt nochmal diese ersten Sekunden.
Es wackelt noch nicht.
Du sagst mir dann, was meint der mit System? Und was ist der Maßstab für ist es stabil oder nicht?
Also das System wird instabil. Das sehe ich. Also das ist es noch nicht. Also es ist noch nicht so instabil, dass es schon wirklich wackelt.
So, und jetzt denk dran, du kannst ja nur kritisieren, was der Soziologe sagt, wenn du selber, also du musst dir besonderes Mühe geben. Ja, also was mit dem System, was mit dem Wackeln und er sieht es, du auch?
Das System, meint er jetzt das Mediensystem oder denke ich viel zu klein? Und er sagt einfach das System der Demokratischen Bundesrepublik.
Ja, genau. Also klar, man könnte uns vorwerfen, wir haben den Knip zu knapp.
Das Land wackelt, aber nein, er meint so allgemein das System.
Ja, genau, also wir hören uns jetzt mal zwei Minuten lang. Das ist repräsentativ und dann können wir überprüfen, was er meint.
Aber ich sehe auch nicht, dass man diese weitere Destabilisierung jetzt in absehbarer Zeit aufhalten kann. Und das Aufhalten ist ein aus meiner Sicht ganz mühsamer Weg. Eben nicht kommunizieren, was schnell geht, eben nicht bekämpfen, was schnell geht, sondern diese harten Sachen, die du gerade gesagt hast. Also ich sehe nicht, dass es alles verloren ist, gar nicht. Aber die...
Haben wir schon Aufklärungen über welche Systeme, was verloren, was hatten wir mal?
Die eigentlichen Ursachen bekämpfen, bearbeiten, dass wenn wir jetzt...
Das ist wirklich kurz vor Banner, Jackie.
Anfang ist es so fünf, sechs, sieben Jahre, bis das, wie du gerade mit dem Wohnungsschlüssel gesagt hast, also fünf Jahre mindestens so, ne? Aber das ist auch, fünf Jahre wär super, weil wir ja 30 Jahre, es haben passieren lassen und so kommen lassen.
Das könnte jetzt so ein bisschen Infrastruktur und so sein.
Wahrscheinlich.
Und deswegen, ich würde eher sagen, den System vertraue ich, weil alle Alternativen sind schlechter.
Also dann scheint es das demokratische System.
Ja, aber das hat nichts mit seiner bisherigen Vertrauensdefinition zu tun.
Nee.
Weil die Alternativen schlechter sind.
Ja, dann brauche ich ja kein Vertrauen, sondern dann sage ich einfach, das andere ist noch schlechter.
Genau, das ist die Belem. Also ich bin noch Brasilien gefahren, sorry, aber ich finde Duisburg-Markt so plötzlich ganz toll. Ja.
Die Qualität, es gibt halt keine Alternative, die gleichwertig ist wie diese Systeme, wo es schwerer fällt, zu vertrauen.
Warum vertraut der Staat?
So, Matze versucht jetzt mal das Gespräch irgendwie zu retten und sagt einfach, komm, alter, lass uns über den Staat reden, weil da haben wir alle eine Meinung.
Der Staat, dem Bürger nicht.
Wir hören noch mal diese Fragestellung.
Die gleichwertig ist wie diese Systeme, wo es schwerer fällt, zu vertrauen.
Warum vertraut der Staat dem Bürger nicht?
Ein ganz großes Problem. Also ich plädiere total dafür, dass der Staat mehr dem Bürgern mehr vertraut. Also in Vorleistung geht. Wenn Vertrauen so wichtig ist, muss er auch mehr vertrauen.
Das macht der Staat nämlich nicht.
Das macht er nicht mehr oder immer weniger, weil es gibt folgenden Effekt, daran sieht man auch, weil wir haben jetzt gerade so viel über Medien und Wissenschaft und so gesprochen. Alle Systeme, alle, müssen Veränderung vornehmen. Alle. Weil wir in einer anderen Welt jetzt leben und die Bürger ein anderes Bedürfnis haben und nicht mehr eben blind oder nicht blind fest vertrauen und jetzt wollen die besser und so weiter.
Die Systeme müssen Veränderung vornehmen. Wie machen die das?
Alles muss jetzt verändert werden, damit es bleibt, wie es war.
Dann lesen wir wieder der Leopard.
So, jetzt hatten wir, also Mats hat ihm jetzt einen Verlegenheitsausweg geboten. Dann lassen wir uns doch über den Staat reden. Dann können gerade alle gut drüber jammern. Staat ist ja auch alles. Der kaputte Bordsteig, die nicht fahrende Bahn, die Schule, was auch immer. So, Mafalani, wir haben jetzt mal zwei Ausschnitte zum Thema Vertrauen und Staat. Ich würde ja sagen, man kann in dieses Thema richtig, also ich würde sagen, okay, das Vertrauensthema, der Vertrauensbegriff ist hier falsch, aber ich weiß ja nun wirklich, was ihr meint. Von daher, da bitte richtig einsteigen. Stattdessen versucht Mafalani jetzt so eine soziologische, sie da, da hast du noch nicht dran gedacht, hier noch mal ein Fun Fact. So eine Konzeption einfach ins Gespräch einzuweben.
Das ist jetzt wie Schirach schilderte, dass es da irgendeinen Gerichtsdiener gab, der nur Akten hin und her getragen hat.
Irgendwas Kleines, das Plausibilität unterfüttert und noch mal siehe hier meine Grundbegriffe aus meinem Fach. Ich bin unser OR, ich kenne mich aus.
Und wenn du jetzt über den Staat sprichst, kann man das, finde ich, ganz gut zeigen. Also, ich würde sagen, der Staat operiert überwiegend über Verwaltung und Recht. Verwaltung ist eher so die Prozess-Ebene und Recht ist eher das Geschriebene, was die Prozesse anleitet. Und wir haben eine ganz lange Weile, haben wir so einen Aufstieg gehabt, dass die Verrechtlichung das Vertrauen gestärkt hat.
So, erfüllt das aus?
Also, wir haben alles, es gibt nur noch Dokumentationspflichten, wie ein Nachbar sich verhalten soll, welcher Zentimeter wo sein muss und so weiter. Alles wurde so organisiert, dass die Menschen gar nicht mehr untereinander die Dinge regeln müssen und damit auch nicht mehr sozusagen Vertrauen, also Vertrauen wurde ersetzt durch Recht, ohne die Kraft des Vertrauens. Die verliert man. Ja. Und das heißt also, eine ganze Weile war es positiv und dann ist es jetzt gekippt.
Ja, also das stimmt so nicht. Ich weiß, was er meint. Wir kennen alle das Bürokratismus-Argument und jemand betritt den Raum und fragt, er kann nicht den als weißer Mann überhaupt noch was sagen oder was auch immer oder gelten hier schon wieder Regeln, die ich nicht kenne. Wann hat man wirklich mit einem verwaltenden Staat im Alltag zu tun, der in das zivile Leben eingreift? Meine These ist eigentlich nie.
Ganz, ganz selten.
Also das kommt eigentlich nicht vor.
Ja, es sei denn, man ist auf irgendwelche Transferleistungen angewiesen oder so.
Genau, aber die sind direkt mit dem Staat verhandelt und so weiter. Aber dass sich der Staat wirklich im eins zu eins von Menschen einmischt. Und ich meine jetzt nicht, klar, wir gehen an der Kasse und verhalten uns genau so, wie es die Rechtsordnung vorsieht. Wann ist der Vertrag beschlossen? Wann darf ich das als mein Besitz mit nach Hause nehmen? Und was holt man so? Sondern dieses neue Einmischen.
Wenn du jetzt ein Haus baust, dann hast du natürlich, brauchst du eine Baugenehmigung oder so. Oder du musst deinen Kfz anmelden. Aber das sind ja jetzt, der kommt ja nicht vorbei. Also wir, ja gut, dann Steuer. Vielleicht, wenn eine Steuerprüfung ist oder so, dann haben Leute Kontakte mit dem Staat. Aber es ist nicht so, dass der mir ständig begegnet.
Ja, und ich würde nämlich auch sagen, zum einen, leiden wir werden vom Staat nicht belästigt, sondern wir werden belästigt davon, dass Sachen nicht funktionieren, von denen wir erwartet haben, dass sie funktionieren, weil sie ja damals meistens dann angeblich auch funktioniert haben. Also ich weiß, wie meine Onkel in meinem Alter zugefahren sind und ich will nicht tauschen. Und vor allem nicht mit meiner Opa-Generation. Also da an der DDR so und dann kratzt er irgendwie die Scheibe frei und guckst, ist da schon Leipzig zu sehen? Und dann so, könnte noch so zehn Minuten sein, bis wir da sind. Sondern, ne, man sitzt ja entspannt da und dann kommt halt eine Anzeige, das Problem ist nur, Pünktlichkeit ist halt 60 Prozent. Aber das Pünktlichkeitsding, entweder Zug ist pünktlich oder nicht. Wenn er fährt, ist schon okay. Nur wenn er nicht fährt, ist halt das ganze System ausgefallen für dich in dem Moment. So, aber das ist jetzt wirklich der Start als der große Belästiger. Also für Unternehmer ja. Und Bürokratie, diese ganzen Sachen sind ja auch ein echtes Problem. Und ich bin sehr gespannt, wie da demnächst vielleicht mal mit einer Europa KI so ein bisschen gegengearbeitet wird. Im Sinne von Formulare ausfüllen und so. Aber dieses Verhältnis, was er jetzt aufmachte, Vertrauen und Recht. Und dass der Staat über immer mehr Recht Vertrauen abbaut, wo es eigentlich hingehört, wo wir es uns eigentlich wünschen. Genau das gilt, so wie er beschrieben hat, gerade nicht. Vor allem nicht jetzt. Denn bisher hat ja das Recht dazu geführt, dass es mehr Vertrauen gab und jetzt ist es plötzlich weniger. Das ist ganz schräg. Wir hören das mal bei Anne Brorhilke. Wir haben ein paar Mal von ihr gesprochen und Clips gehört. Sie ist diese Staatsanwältin, die damals, und wir haben ja die Serie auch kurz angesprochen, die ist ja sehr gut, Cum-Ex, die Affäre Cum-Ex und so. Sie hat also damals dieses Dings aufgearbeitet.
Sie hat es ins Rollen gebracht.
Und das war aber eine schwierige Geburt. Warum? Wegen Vertrauens und Misstrauens Konstellationen, die wir hinterfragen müssen im Lichte dessen, was wir gerade von Mafaalanis gehört haben. Es könnte nämlich genau das Gegenteil sein, dass der Staat den Leuten zu viel vertraut hat.
Es ist ja so, dass viel mehr Steuerprüfungen eigentlich sein müssten bei denen, die viel haben und dort geschreien sie ja nicht.
Christian Lindner hat die Steuerprüfung um 60 Prozent zurückgefahren in seinen drei Jahren.
Könnte man sagen, es hat ein wunderbarer Akt des Vertrauens.
Neuntausend weniger Einnahmen. So, das ist ein großer Akt des Vertrauens gewesen. Wir hören uns mal bei Brohelga. Das ist ein sehr langer Podcast, alles gesagt von der Zeit. Sie ist da, glaube ich, sechs Stunden zu Gast oder so. Sie schildert, wir springen mitten rein in die Schilderung, ihre erste Durchsuchung, die sie damals mitgemacht hat.
Man macht ja eine Durchsuchung nicht, weil man irgendwie das geträumt hat, sondern man hat ja eine Beweislage oder eine Verdachtslage und schreibt das alles auf.
So, man hört schon am Tonfall, sie ist so ein bisschen unzufrieden gewesen. Wir hatten doch eine Verdachtslage, wir haben das doch geklärt, wir waren doch bei einem Richter. Dann haben wir unsere Vorbereitung gemacht, haben das Haus verlassen, sind zur Bank gefahren und plötzlich war gar nichts mehr.
Und veranpracht das bei Gericht und dann kriegt man auch einen Gerichtsbeschluss. Und diesen Gerichtsbeschluss sollte man ja auch vollstrecken und nicht einfach wieder nach Hause fahren, wenn die sagen, wir wollen gerade nicht. Das würde man ja übrigens auch nicht beim Drogendieter machen. Na ja, jedenfalls hatte ich mich da schon gewundert, wie da so die Geflogenheiten sind und hatte das dann beobachtet bei dieser ersten Durchsuchung. Die haben uns schon reingelassen.
So, sie schildert jetzt, wie der Staat in einer Bank vorstellig wird und sagt, wir haben hier einen richterlichen Beschluss, eigentlich dürfen wir hier gerade mal alles. So, jetzt ist die Frage, stört hier vielleicht das ein oder andere Vertrauensverhältnis noch, die Arbeit, die zu erledigen ist?
Sind wir dadurch kniettief für Teppiche gewartet, an allen möglichen Kunstwerken vorbei und sind in einen Raum gebeten worden, wo wir dann netten Kaffee getrunken haben und irgendwie zwei Stunden unterhalten. Und dann kam eben raus, na ja, sie werden mal die Vorwürfe überdenken.
Also die Opfer der Razzia gerade, ne? Ja, wir denken mal drüber nach.
Und wenn sie was finden, sagen sie uns Bescheid. So, und dann sind wir wieder gegangen.
So, und dann sind wir wieder gegangen. Der Staat vertraut dir zu wenig, weißt du? Nee, der Staat vertraut dir zu wenig, wenn du kein Geld hast. Sobald du Geld hast, läuft es genau andersrum.
Irgendwie bemerkenswert fand.
Manchmal sind sie sehr diplomatisch, ne? Bemerkenswert, haben sie nicht gedacht, das Wort, oder?
Wahrscheinlich nicht. Ich hab jedenfalls gedacht, das entspricht ja nun nicht dem, wie es im Gesetz steht.
Was ist jetzt mit dem Recht?
Da hat man überhaupt einen Unterschied. Also warum durchsucht man bei Drogen, die lernen wie selbstverständlich, ne? Und macht hier die Schublade auf und hier, wenn die Bank sagt, ne, aber ihr könnt zwar hier einen Kaffee trinken am Küchentisch, aber ihr macht bitte keine Schublade auf und ihr fasst dir auch nix an, dann nimmt man das so hin. Also das fand ich komisch.
Ja, komisch. Passt so gar nicht zu dem, was wir eben als die große Krise, das Vertrauen der Staat, die Bürokratie und so, scheint wirklich am Geldbeutel zu hängen. Also das Fundament der ganzen Argumentation ist einfach arm und reich. Ja. So, und das Problem ist, wenn ich arm bin und das kritisiere, dann falle ich komplett bei Mafaalanis als ne, das geht nicht, das ist Verschwörungstheorie durch, weil ich habe an allem alles zu kritisieren.
Ja, zu Recht eigentlich.
Und zu Recht, genau. Ja, so der Soziologe hat also etwas übersehen, eine fundamentale Unterscheidung, hat einfach ein allgemeines Argument gemacht, das hier offenbar nicht passt. Weil wir Brohöcker gerne zuhören, lassen wir uns das noch ein bisschen erklären.
Zum einen müsste hier eigentlich eine Steuerverwaltung so aufgestellt sein, dass sie Interesse daran hat, die großen Fälle zu bearbeiten, wo uns wirklich viel Schaden entstanden ist. Und die kleinen Fälle, wenn sie zu wenig Ressourcen hat, dann eher die kleinen Fälle hinter den Ruhm fallen zu lassen. Das ist da auch da in der Praxis eher genau umgekehrt. Insgesamt gesehen ist es sowieso eine merkwürdige Entscheidung und hat überhaupt gar nichts mit Ökonomie zu tun, warum es so wenig Betriebsprüfer gibt. Betriebsprüfer kosten 60.000, 70.000 im Jahr und bringen im Schnitt eine Million zurück.
So, das ist eine Rendite von 14 Prozent oder sowas. Super. 140.400, also 14-fach.
Ja, dafür könnte man einige anstellen und richtig Geld machen.
Ich bin sehr dafür, dass mein Steuergeld dafür verwendet wird, das Steuergeld einzutreiben.
Ja, ja, ja. Das ist ja die Diskussion, die Leidige. Wenn es um Vermögensteuer geht, sagt man, das wird viel zu kompliziert, wenn wir da noch rausfinden müssen, wie viel Vermögen denn bei den Reichen ist. Aber man kann natürlich herausfinden, ob irgendein Bürgergeldempfänger unrechtmäßig 50 Euro zu viel bekommen hat. Da müssen wir mindestens drei Leute los schicken, um das zu ahnden.
Genau.
Obwohl sie noch nicht mal die großen Fälle bearbeiten. Also könnten wir wahrscheinlich noch viel mehr zurückholen. Also ist es doch eigentlich, wenn man jetzt mal nur ökonomisch denkt, eine rationale Entscheidung, mehr Betriebsfonds einzusetzen, passiert auch nicht.
Wenn wir die schon haben, soll ich dann Barbershops durchsuchen oder Banken?
Ja, wenn man sich die Schadenssummen anschaut, ganz klar Banken.
Aber was hat das mit meinem Gerechtigkeitsgefühl zu tun, wenn die Barbershops dann…
Das hast du jetzt auch mitbekommen. Schirach redet über Gerechtigkeit, kommt auf Ökonomie zu sprechen. Man denkt, was kommt jetzt? Ungleichheit? Nee, Gerechtigkeit bei den Bürgergeldempfängern, die bekommen zu viel. Da ist der Lohnabstand nicht mehr gewahrt.
Ich habe diesen einen Clip im Fernsehpodcast mit Mick gehört oder gespielt. Just in diesem Monat gibt es eine neue Gesetzeslage zum Thema Schwarzarbeit, die gezielt Nagelstudios und Friseure ins Visier nimmt.
Wirklich?
Weil da kann man nämlich noch mal eine Million rausholen oder so.
Mensch, toll.
Deutschlandweit. Es ist wirklich absurd. Cum ex und cum cum.
Jetzt sind die erst mal im Inland, die Aktien.
Sie beschreibt jetzt, wie das funktioniert. Diese Aktien machen hier ihren Holiday. Also bevor sie es erklärt, ich kann es ja auch noch mal kurz. Es geht um diese drei Sekunden. Also, zurückgebunden an unsere Vertrauensfrage. Diese Aktien sind für drei Sekunden in deinen Besitz. Und genau innerhalb dieser drei Sekunden sagst du beim Finanzamt, ich habe diese Aktien, ich bräuchte dafür immer die Erstattung meiner Kapitalerträge und so. Und dann hat die Bank natürlich diese Nachfrage. Ja, sind das wirklich ihre Aktien? Und du so, ja, ja. Und dann haben die noch mal Nachfragen. Und du sagst einfach immer, ja, ja, ja. Weil du genau weißt, die fragen nie danach, haben sie die Aktien vielleicht mal länger besessen als drei Sekunden? Der Staat vertraut dir da einfach. Sie beschreibt das hier mal, wie sehr der Staat einfach vertraut, wenn ihr mal sagt, das ist meine Aktie.
Ich habe sie zwar nur drei Sekunden besessen, ich will das hier gerade einwerfen, denn sowohl von Schirach als auch Aladin El-Mafaalanis gehen ja beide auf diese Kommission ein oder diesen Arbeitskreis, der sich da gebildet hatte, für einen handlungsfähigen Staat. Und da haben wir schon damals kritisiert bei all dem, wo wir auch sagen, das ist ein gutes Anliegen, das mal zu verfolgen, dass da doch sehr stark so eine Ausprägung war, die sagte, wir müssen jetzt mal Deutschland wie so ein Unternehmen führen. Das müsste doch möglich sein. Ja, da war die eine Dame, die sich da sehr für stark gemacht hat. Und ich glaube, dass das schon so ein Denken ist, dass sich jetzt immer mehr in der Fläche verbreitet, dass die Leute jetzt so, ich glaube, es war nicht die Mäcke, aber es hätte sie sein können, dass jetzt immer wieder so gesagt wird, ja, wir müssen das doch eigentlich über so Vertrauen, kurze Wege und all das machen. Und dann ist man aber sehr schnell dann dabei, dass man so ein Superministerium wollte, die eine doch haben, die nochmal so ein Effizienzministerium, mit dem man alles beschleunigen kann. Und das sorgt aber dann vor allem eigentlich dafür, dass man so eine Doge-Republik bekommt und eben nicht eine, ja, vertrauenserweckende Struktur.
Wie heißt sie?
Ja, das weiß ich nicht.
Also wir haben dazu im Mai, im März zielorientierte Bürokratie und der strafende Staat, ich hatte damals schon drüber gesprochen, mit Stefan Kühl und Judith Muster einen Podcast gemacht, wo nämlich auch diese Frage war, soll man jetzt weiter ins Bürokratische Klein-Klein gehen oder kann man nicht einfach, das war Kühls Idee jetzt sagen, der strafende Staat. Er macht einfach klare Verbote, also zielprogrammiert, wie man die dann einhält, ist sozusagen egal. Und dieses, ne, wir richten jetzt nochmal eine neue Barbershop und Fingernagelstudio. Das ist einfach völlig absurd, ne, wenn man hier, weil wenn er so, soll man lieber zum Barber gehen oder zur Bank? Also sie erklärt jetzt, wie dieses ex cum cum funktioniert mit diesem 3-Sekunden-Detail. Und eigentlich, das lernen wir ja in dieser Serie, wussten die Banken, wussten die, wusste der Staat, die Behörden. Ja, das ist das, also so funktioniert's. Aber sie konnten es nicht aufklären, weil sie plötzlich unglaublich viel Vertrauen haben mussten in das, was halt angeliefert wurde an Informationen von den Banken.
Jetzt sind die erstmal im Inland, die Aktien. Insider nennen das übrigens Dividend Holidays.
Dividend Holidays. Dividend Holidays, dass die Aktien mal für Stippvisiten in Deutschland sind und dann halt aber auch eben nur für Stippvisiten da wieder ins Ausland zurück wandern. Aber Kum-Kum ist auch schon böse, ist es nicht Spraftat?
Kommen wir gleich noch zu. Kann unter den gleichen Voraussetzungen strafbar sein wie Kum-Ex, weil das hat nichts mit der zugrundeliegenden Handelsstrategie zu tun, ob es strafbar ist oder nicht, sondern es hat was damit zu tun, ob ich...
Achtung, womit hat die Strafbarkeit zu tun?...
zu tun, ob es strafbar ist oder nicht, sondern es hat was damit zu tun, ob ich dem Finanzamt die wesentlichen Umstände offenlege oder nicht.
So, daran hängt die Strafbarkeit. Man muss also schon ziemlich darauf vertrauen, dass einem der Staat vertraut, wenn man sagt, eigentlich müsste ich ihnen diese Information geben, dass ich die Aktien nur drei Sekunden habe, aber wir vertrauen uns doch hier, oder? Also hier ist ziemlich viel nicht, wir vertrauen die Misstrauenden oder so, sondern hier ist ganz schön viel Vertrauen von allen Seiten.
Und wenn ich das, das kann ich sowohl unterlassen oder nicht machen. Was heißt denn das? Ich sage zum Beispiel dem Finanzamt dann nicht, ich habe die Aktien aber nur für drei Sekunden. Danach gehen die wieder zurück und ich darf auch gar nichts mit den Aktien machen, weil ich habe nämlich folgende Verträge abgeschlossen.
Das sage ich alles nicht.
Das sage ich vor allen Dingen alles nicht.
Ich bin ja diejenige, die mit dem Finanzamt kommuniziert.
Und das Finanzamt kennt einfach die Hintergründe nicht. Und da die aber zu rechtlichen Bewertungen erheblich sind, solche Abreden, wäre das problematisch, wenn man das dem Finanzamt nicht sagt. Dann ist man schon mit einem Bein quasi im Strafrecht drin.
So, die Banken fragen also nach. Sie nennen mir jetzt bitte alle relevanten Informationen, die erheblich dafür sind, wie wir ihre Steuerlast oder Erstattung berechnen. Und dann sagst du einfach, das ist halt meine Aktie. Ja. Und vertraust darauf, dass die das Recht nicht anwenden. Und damit haben die 50, 100 Milliarden verdient einfach.
Ja. Vertrauen.
So wenig vertraut das ist ein echtes Problem, dass der Staat dem Bürger nicht mehr vertraut. Nee, nur den armen Bürgern. Nur den armen Bürgern. Solange du dadurch hohe Teppiche wartest und einen Kaffee kriegst und auch mal im 30. Stock in Frankfurt in so einer Bank sitzen darfst. Vertrauen, gar kein Problem. Sie schildern das so ein bisschen. Jetzt könnte man natürlich sagen, ja gut, die haben danach gefragt im Gespräch, das ist meine Aktie, gut, aber nein, die Banken haben ja wirklich richtig aktiv gelogen. Da wurden ja richtig Daten geschönt.
Wir hatten, nicht nur wir, auch die anderen Staatsanwaltschaften hatten nicht mittels Durchsuchung, sondern sogenannter staatsanwaltschaftlicher Auskunftsersuchen, was so die unter, also die letzte Stufe vor der Durchsuchung ist sozusagen. Also es hat schon offizielle Schreiben und hat auch Konsequenzen, wenn man sich beantwortet. Aber damit hatten wir die Transaktionsdaten angefordert. Also die Prodaten im Grunde genommen, wo die Aktien ungebucht werden. Das braucht man eben zum Nachweis, wo die Aktie dann am welchen Tag war.
Und für diese Tage, von denen wir vorhin gesprochen haben.
Genau. Und die waren immer im bestimmten Format. Also das war eine Exotabelle, die hatte jetzt mal, ich weiß es nicht mal ganz genau, ungefähr 15 Spalten oder so. Und dann haben wir bei irgendeiner Durchsuchung, wo da wieder auch so rumgebockt wurde und wir da nicht weiter kamen, hatte ich gefragt, wer ist denn derjenige, der uns immer die Auskunftsersuchen beantwortet? Weil ich gedacht habe, derjenige muss ja hier was dazu wissen. Er hat uns ja schon seit drei Jahren irgendwelche Sachen beantwortet.
Seit drei Jahren.
Genau. Und deswegen sind wir dann zu dem hin. Und da habe ich mir angeschaut, was der dann so auf dem PC so, was man denn da so sieht. Und da sah man keine Exotabellen mit 15 Spalten, sondern mit 100. Und dann stellte sich später im E-Mail-Verkehr, als wir dann auch E-Mails gesichert haben, raus, dass die sich tatsächlich verständigt hatten, auch mit anderen, dass sie den Staatsanwaltschaften nur welche mit 15 Zahlen geben, damit da keine Begehrlichkeiten geweckt würden. Und das war natürlich ein Ding. Also da war mir erst mal klar, also wir können uns überhaupt auf gar nichts verlassen, wenn es um solche Profitinteressen geht.
Mit anderen Worten, wir können gar nicht vertrauen.
Also jetzt haben Mafaalanis und so immer, die sagen jetzt Vertrauen ist voll gut, der Staat, wenn wir uns alle vertrauen, ist viel besser und so. Ich sage, wow, haben wir eine Vertrauenskrise. Wir vertrauen den Banken viel, viel, viel zu sehr. Ja, das ist die eigentliche Vertrauenskrise. Wir kriegen ja immer diese Aufschlüsselung, Bürgergeldbetrug nicht relevant, Steuerbetrug 100 Milliarden. Das ist die Vertrauenskrise. Ich will kein affirmatives Grumhampel mit irgendeiner Scheißsemantik zum Thema Vertrauen mehr haben, sondern unsere Vertrauenskrise sind 100 Milliarden Euro Steuerbetrug pro Jahr. Damit kann man alles finanzieren, auch die Rente. So, das ist eine Vertrauenskrise, aber genau andersrum, als hier immer behauptet wird und wir machen es explizit, es geht um diese fundamentale Differenz zwischen Arm und Reich. Vertrauenskrise, wie Mafaalanis meinte, ja für arme Leute. Vertrauenskrise, wie ich sie sagte, für reiche Leute. Nun brauchen wir aber eine Soziologie, die beides und das geht nicht. Deswegen einfach nicht vom Vertrauen reden.
Aber es ist ja so typisch, als wenn wir jetzt darüber nachdenken, warum wird darüber geredet? Warum ist das so ein beliebtes Talkshow-Thema? Warum kann man jetzt gerade damit Sachbücher füllen, in die Bestsellerlisten kommen? Weshalb ist das auch im Fernsehen das große Ding? Und dann bekommt man auch eine Einladung vom Bundespräsidenten. Naja, weil es ein Diskurs ist, der niemanden stört, der gerade Macht hat, sondern man kann endlos weiterreden. Ein anderes Beispiel wäre, da gehe ich noch mit Ohle drauf ein, Hannu Sauer schreibt ein Buch über Klasse und spricht nicht einmal über die Leute, die arbeiten gehen müssen, sondern redet nur von Konsumenten. Redet nur von Konsumenten. Die meisten Menschen können kaum konsumieren, wie wir wissen. Also wir haben ganz viele dieser Deckdiskurse, die mitunter sehr eloquent oder sehr nachdenklich vorgetragen werden. Wir haben das ja gerade von Schirach erlebt, mit welcher Langsamkeit man simple Gedanken vortragen kann. Aber all das führt eigentlich nur dazu, dass die Gespräche, die geführt werden müssten, nicht geführt werden. Beziehungsweise sie finden dann woanders statt. Und wenn sie dann woanders stattfinden, dann sagt man naja bitte so aber nicht. Und das sind diese komischen alternativen Medien.
Also dazu hat die Soziologie gute Antworten, gute Aufklärung. Denn das sind einfach Wertediskurse. Ja. Salopp würde man sagen. Sonntagsrede.
Ja.
Thema Gerechtigkeit, Frieden, Zukunft, ja irgendwas, der ganze Kram. Das sind halt Werte. Und bei Werten, das ist das Besondere an Werten, können sich alle einig sein, egal welche Interessen sie haben. Und auch wenn die Interessen sich komplett widersprechen.
Ja, denn die beiden.
Was aber nicht geht, ist widersprechende Interessen haben und trotzdem gute Laune.
Ja.
Und darum, man muss die widersprechenden Interessen diskutieren, weil die Werte sind immer Gerechtigkeit. Man kennt niemanden, der sagt, ich hätte gerne eine ungerechte Welt.
Ja. Und von daher, auch Schirach und so, wenn die immer zu groß werden, zu abstrakt, das sind einfach diese Wertediskurse. Auf der Bühne stehen und sagen, fuck AfD. Ja, okay, gut, da ist man auf diesem Wertekontext. Also da kann einfach jeder sagen, genau fuck. Das sagen aber dann auch die, es gehen halt sächsische Schweizer. Die sagen auch fuck AfD. Denen ist das nicht radikal genug. So, wir bleiben hier noch ein bisschen beim Thema. Vertrauen, Recht und Geld.
Es scheint, dass wir in eine Art, ich weiß nicht, Post-Law-Society kommen.
Post-Law-Society, eine Nachrechtsgesellschaft. Nach dem Recht. Was kommt nach dem Recht?
Jeder Mann für sich selbst. Jeder Mann muss seinen eigenen ehemaligen Mossad-Agent sich zu verteidigen. Zu verteidigen sein Zuhause und zu verteidigen sein Jewelry. Und zu deinem Punkt, kann das eine Investmentszene sein? Ich glaube, das kann. Es ist eine sehr klinische Investmentszene, aber es ist eine echte und das könnte etwas zu diskutieren sein. Wir haben ein paar Namen, die wir nennen können. Aber zuerst, lass uns deine Reaktion zu diesem Nummer machen. Mehr als 1 Mio.
Stopp, stopp.
So, also Ed Aysen im ProfG Market Podcast, den ich ja auch sehr gut finde. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum wir jetzt am Anfang das nicht drin kamen, aber ich rede jetzt darüber. In Amerika gibt es jetzt mehr private Bodyguards als Lehrer. Und wenn das nicht meine Bilanz ist.
Bodyguards in Amerika.
Das hat mich überrascht. Mehr Bodyguards als Lehrer. Das ist die Erosion einer Gesellschaft, aber es ist ein weiteres Schlafen.
Müssen wir gar nicht zu Ende hören. In Amerika gibt es jetzt mehr private Bodyguards als Lehrer. Und mittlerweile, Scott Galloway beschreibt das hier mal, in New York City fühlen sich die Leute betrogen um ihre Lebenschancen. Aber da sind es nicht mehr nur die Armen.
Mamdami ist wahrscheinlich die Mehrwertsrunde einer Stadt zu gewinnen.
Das war am 27.10., also noch vor der Wahl, am 4. November....
das eine größere GDP hat als, ich denke, alle, aber zwölf oder vierzehn Länder, auf die Notion von Eingangsteigung und Unbefugnismäßigkeit. Die Leute sind wütend. Die Ingenieureinhalte sind nicht nur um die Poverten und die sehr Reichen. Es klingelt auf. Was meine ich damit?
So, wir haben jetzt ein Trickle-up-Problem der Armut.
Es gibt so viele Leute deiner Generation, die in New York leben, die die Regeln spielen. Sie haben sich in der Highschool gebrochen. Sie sind gute Leute, sie sind in tolle Schulen gekommen. Sie haben ihre Eltern für sie Geld gebraucht, um in diese Schulen zu kommen. Sie haben hart gearbeitet und Schauspieler bekommen. Sie sind ausgewandt, sie haben tolle Jobs bekommen. Und sie können sich immer noch nicht in New York oder San Francisco erwerben. Ich meine, sie können sich immer noch nicht erwerben. Als ich in New York gerannte, hatte ich zwei Schwerpferde, aber ich konnte in New York leben, und damals arbeitete ich in Morgan Stanley um 50 bis 55 Gramm pro Jahr. Du musst sowohl in Technologie, mit Meta oder Google, an JP Morgan arbeiten, oder dich mit richen Eltern in New York und San Francisco erwerben. Es sind nicht nur schwere Menschen, die sich in einen Jewelry-Store bewegen, oder in ein Verbrechen, oder in ein Verbrechen verabschieden. Es gibt generelle Verzweiflung zwischen New Yorker Votern, die sagen, fuck, ich habe die Regeln gespielt, ich mache ein großartiges Leben, und ich kann hier nicht leben, aber ich sehe diese pornographische Wohlheit in meinem Gesicht, 210 Mal pro Tag, und ich sehe Leute, die die GDP der latinamerikanischen Nation aggregieren, die ihre niedrigsten Kosten bezahlen. Also diese Revolution ist wie eine Art auf und runter gescheitertes Wettbewerb. Die Leute sind nicht zufrieden, die sechs Figuren machen.
Das wird ja ständig im Diskurs jetzt über Mamdani übersehen. Da wird, wenn es um diese Supermärkte geht, so getan, als wäre das so ein bisschen wie die Tafeln in Deutschland. Nein, es geht hier wirklich um Menschen, die zum Beispiel Richter sind, also eine super Stelle haben, aber darüber nachdenken müssen, wie sie sich eigentlich die Wochenendeinkäufe leisten können. Das ist kaum vorstellbar, aber das ist die Realität dort. Bedeutet also, das ist eine Gruppe, die da anspricht, bei der man wirklich sagen kann, man da nie redet dazu den unteren 90 Prozent. Ich habe heute auch schon mal von den unteren 90 Prozent geredet. Und das ist etwas, was ja tatsächlich nach oben migriert ist, beziehungsweise ja, da gibt es einen Trickle-Up, dass man sagen kann, das geht immer mehr genau in diese Richtung. Und dass man dann noch so ein Post-Law-System hat, in dem eigentlich dann nur noch jeder versucht, sein Eigentum zu schützen oder sich sicher zu halten durch private Bodyguards, müsste ja eigentlich jetzt besonders gut zeigen, dass also das Einhalten von Verfahren, dass das Vertrauen auf den Rechtsstaat im Sinne von, wir müssen jetzt nicht mal alles nur Vertrauen über Vertrauen regeln, das sagen wir, wir holen die Gesetze raus und machen es nur noch so auf Zuruf. Man müsste eigentlich sagen, wo das so fest eingehalten wird, da scheint das ja doch ganz gut zu sein. Denn wir haben aber, glaube ich, hier wieder so eine Denkfaulheit. Also eigentlich ist ja diese Bürokratiekritik, die heute so geäußert wird, die sehr diffus ist. Meistens noch eine, die sich auf die Ruckrede von Roman Herzog bezieht, dass man eigentlich möchte, dass jetzt mal so schnell agiert werden kann. Wir vertrauen jetzt mal allen und dann wird das schon. Schon damals hat das seine Probleme gehabt, aber es ist ja zumindest zu einer Zeit aus den USA importiert worden als Gedanke, als man dort eine Bill-Clinton-Regierung hatte. Bill Gates seine Riesenerfolge feierte und man sich überhaupt keine Frage stellte darüber, ob das System als solches funktioniert oder ob der Präsident ist, der wird sich das Recht aushebelt, wie ihm gerade lustig ist. Jetzt aber, wo wir ja sehen, wie diese US-amerikanische Politik ist, jetzt zu sagen, wir müssen uns daran mal auch orientieren und manche dann nach einem Durschministerium rufen, das machen noch so Leute wie Frank Thelen vielleicht. Und Gabor Steingart. Oder Gabor Steingart. Aber im Prinzip gehen ganz viele der Äußerungen, die werden nur dann ein bisschen vornehmerdezenter vorgetragen und da finde ich geht jetzt auch ein Schirach und bisweilen auch dann Mafalani in eine Richtung, wo man sagt, ja, sollen wir uns das jetzt alles über Vertrauen regeln? Oder wären wir nicht eher ganz gut bedient dabei, wenn wir sagen, es sind diese Prozesse, die wir haben und liegt es vielleicht nicht einfach an den finanziellen Mitteln, die nicht möglich sind? Denn oftmals ist es ja auch gar nicht das bürokratische Problem, sondern es sind einfach finanzielle Mittel. Wir haben Debatten darüber. Also wir haben Zahlen bekommen, dass häusliche Gewalt zunimmt in Deutschland. Also Gewalt vorwiegend gegen Frauen, Femizide, ein Riesenproblem. Ich las in der Rheinzeitung, das ist die Zeitung, die auch in Koblenz erscheint, auf der Titelseite war diese Meldung über häusliche Gewalt, alles was dazunimmt, Frauen also werden gewalttätig angegangen. Zugleich war da eine Meldung aus Neuwied, das ist direkt bei Koblenz, dass dort Geld gestrichen wird für das Frauenhaus. Dann habe ich nachgelesen, um welchen Betrag handelt es sich. Und das ist noch verrückter, als die Tatsache überhaupt, dass was gestrichen wird. 500 Euro. Es geht um einen 500 Euro Zuschuss, der jetzt offenbar nicht mehr geleistet werden soll. Und da reden wir nicht über Bürokratie oder so, sondern wir sind in einem Bereich, wo wir über finanzielle Mittel reden müssten. Und sobald irgendwo eine 500 Euro Debatte geführt wird, merken wir, wo das Problem liegt.
Ja, es ist einfach alles schräg. Auch schräg. Wir gehen mal kurz drauf ein. Also Mamdani wurde gewählt. Jetzt haben wir gerade darüber gesprochen, dass sich das ganze Ungleichheitsproblem Amerikas in diesen Ballungsräumen nochmal wiederholt. Und zwar nicht zwischen allen 100 Prozent, sondern nur zwischen Top 9 und dem Top 1 Prozent. So, also Leute, die wie du jetzt meintest, Richter, Lehrer, Hochschulprofessoren, was auch immer, laufen über die Straße und begegnen anderen Leuten, die tausendmal reicher sind als sie, was eben auch dazu dann führt, dass die Netto-Mietrendite, die zu diesem Wohlstand führt, eben bedeutet, die eigene Wohnung kostet 7.000 Dollar im Monat. So realistische Preise da. Sascha Lobo erklärt jetzt oder beide Lobos erklären jetzt kurz, warum Mamdani jetzt diese Wahl gewonnen hat.
Was ist passiert? Soran Mamdani wurde mit deutlicher Mehrheit zum Bürgermeister von New York gewählt, als Kandidat der Demokraten. Übrigens war sein erfolgreichster Gegenkandidat nicht etwa von den Republikanern, sondern der ehemalige demokratische Bürgermeister Cuomo.
Aber Soran Mamdani war natürlich Gouverneur. Der hat mit der Stadt jetzt gar nicht so viel zu tun. Deswegen gab es da eh, naja, Vibe-Probleme.
Mamdani hat wohl auch deshalb gewonnen, weil er einer dieser Politiker ist, bei dem man das Gefühl hat, da passiert gerade wirklich was Neues. So vom Look and Feel, von dem Gefühl der Öffentlichkeit vor allem, hatte das teilweise so ein Obama-Charakter, wenn man 2008 oder 2012 gesehen hat, in welche Richtung das gehen kann?
Ja, also das heißt Feel the News dieser Podcast. Deswegen gefühlt kann man jetzt nicht eine Abrede stellen, aber es hatte genau nicht den Obama-Charakter.
Ja.
Weil es war ja gerade nicht dieses, ich schwebe mal drüber, ich mache eine bessere Stimmung und ein paar Ideen habe ich auch, sondern es war gerade, nein, nein, nein, jetzt ist nicht die Zeit für irgendwelche Schnapsideen. Wir bauen jetzt Supermärkte.
Ich zeige euch, wo er hinkommt auf der Karte, dahin. Und dann, das zeige ich euch nicht, aber das werdet ihr dann im Fernsehen sehen, die Schlange wird fünf Kilometer lang hier diese Straße entlanggehen.
Ja.
So, das ist ja das Kalkül irgendwie. In der New York Times wird es auch so beschrieben.
Und er war auch sehr viel ein Beispiel dieses tiefen progressive Wings der demokratischen Partei. Ich meine, wenn man sich nur an seine Message auf Gaza und seine pro-Palästinische Stimme denkt, die er nicht kompromisse, obwohl, du weißt, es waren jüdische New Yorker, die von ihm verletzt wurden.
Ich meine, das fühlte sich so wie die Stöße der Kandidatität in der Primärität an. Es war nicht die Emphasis seiner Kampagne, sicherlich in der Generalwahl. Ich denke, er hat einen großen Pivot gemacht, um den jüdischen Gemeinden und den jüdischen Votern zu erreichen, besonders als Andrew Cuomo ihn auf diesem Thema beherrschte. Es war also nicht, dass er von dem Thema weggeflogen war, aber ich denke, es war weniger sein Fokus und mehr der Basis seiner Kampagne am Anfang.
Du sagst, er hat nicht den Zentrum seiner Kampagne gemacht, und auch nicht die Frage, ob Trump ein Threat an die Demokratie war. Es waren diese ökonomischen Sorgen, die er einfach immer noch auf den Kosten der lebenden Probleme handelte, Ein einziger Tag.
Das war sein Fokus.
So, das Erfolgsrezept ist die Miete ist zu hoch und im Supermarkt ist zu teuer. Weitere politische Themen?
Keine. Wie schätzt du das Zusammentreffen zwischen Mamdani und Trump ein? Das war ja doch sehr interessant.
Ich wollte den Clip überspringen, aber wir hören jetzt nochmal die Lobos.
Okay.
Mit folgender Vermutung am 9.11. Mittlerweile sind ein paar Wochen ins Land gegangen.
Und jetzt geht es um eine Stelle, wo er sich auf sein Muslimsein bezieht und sagt, ich weigere mich.
Sie zitieren kurz aus seiner Siegesrede.
Mich dafür zu entschuldigen. New York werde eine Stadt der Einwanderer bleiben, betonte er. Und um an einen von uns zu kommen, müssen sie an uns allen vorbei. Da ist ja ganz viel zum einen, glaube ich, so in eines Politologentalk drin. Super Antrittsrede. Aber ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht, ob es nicht ein David gegen Goliath Spiel ist, wo die Achilles-Ferse nicht so richtig gefunden wird, weil Trump einfach mehr Macht hat. Also dieses Land ist ja einfach auch so aufgebaut, dass es von oben nach unten einfach leichter ist, Macht auszuüben, so dass ich sagen würde, ich fände das Herz der Reisen, vielleicht gibt es dazu in 50 Jahren ganz viele Filme, und es ist die eine Geschichte und es ist dann eben doch dieser eine David, der die Achilles-Ferse des Goliath gefunden hat. Ich habe schon auch Angst, weil der Richtlinienüberschreitung, die Trump teilweise einfach gerade auch durchgezogen hat, dass da wirklich in zwei Wochen die Nationalgarde in New York steht und da bürgerkriegsähnliche Zustände ausbrechen.
Also Nationalgarde definitiv?
So, Nationalgarde auf jeden Fall und Bürgerkrieg mal sehen, haben sie am 9.11. gesagt innerhalb der nächsten zwei Wochen.
Also nicht geschehen, aber man da nie war im weißen Haus.
Genau, das ist geschehen. Und jetzt bewerten wir das kurz. Ich habe ja schon ausführlich gerade dargelegt, wie ich finde, dass der ganze mediale Betrieb in einer Krise ist.
Ja.
Was bedeutet, man schickt den deutschen Bundeskanzler dahin und freut sich dann über einen Rederanteil von vier Minuten, von 45 Minuten und man übersieht völlig, dass es an diesem konkret in dieser Pressekonferenz im Grunde einfach nur darum ging, dass amerikanische Journalisten wollen, wie jetzt der Break-Up mit Musk verlief, weil das war ja genau an dem Tag. So. Er kommt also wieder zurück und wir sagen, oh puh, das ist nochmal gut gegangen im Weißen Haus. Jetzt steht Deutschland bestimmt voll gut da. Und man, so fünf Minuten später, na, ne, wir sehen doch keinen Effekt, da war einfach nur so ein Treffen. Ich glaube, man erinnert sich gar nicht mehr, wer da da war und so, ja? So. So ist das ja hier auch. Diese Leute, die derzeit im Weißen Haus vorstellig werden, um dort nicht Trump in die Fresse zu hauen, sondern ihm einfach ein Stück Gold auf den Schreibtisch zu legen, die sind alle sehr klug. Die Schweizer haben ihm diese komische Rolex Stelluhr hingebracht, zack, Zölle von 39 auf 15 Prozent. Tim Cook kam da mit diesem riesigen Gold irgendwas und so weiter, da steht ein Apple-Symbol drin, zack, Ausnahme für iPhones, die in Wisse zurückgeholt werden, also die einfach geliefert werden aus China. So, es haben also alle Erfolg, damit im Oval Office einfach Trumps Spiel mitzuspielen, auch wenn medial etwas transportiert wird, bei dem wir dann immer sagen, aber warum hat er da nicht Haltung bewahrt und Trump mal richtig Kontra gegeben und so. Ich habe das schon zu Scholz-Zeiten gesagt, wir beenden nicht das transatlantische Verhältnis, wir sagen immer, wir sind die größten Freunde Amerikas, Trump beende das. Gleichzeitig bereiten wir uns aber bitte darauf vor und kaufen keine F-15 für unsere Billionen Euro in Amerika. Ich finde, das sieht man, also ich sehe das auch. Ich bin zufrieden damit, wie das organisiert wird, weil um Trump kommen sie ja nicht drum herum.
Ich bin damit nicht so ganz zufrieden, aber das ist nochmal ein anderes Thema, dass sie damit nicht so weit gehen, wie sie eigentlich sein müssten. Aber Mamdani hat das Spiel ja verstanden.
Genau, Mamdani war jetzt da. Und das, was ich bemerkenswert fand, ist, Mamdani trägt diesen schwarzen Anzug mit einem roten Rollkragenpullover. Und Trump ist Tage später genau in dieser Klamotte auch zu sehen, weil er so beeindruckt davon war, wie Mamdani das steht.
Aber der war ja im Oval Office nicht mit Rollkragenpullover.
Nein, nein, aber es gibt so Videos, wo die Mode verglichen wird, dass sich Trump dann doch sehr dafür interessierte, wie so Mamdani rüberkommt und so. Und das Mamdani jetzt durchzieht und sagt, im Oval Office wird derzeit keine Politik gemacht. Da wird einfach nur, naja, was man dazu macht, so, ne?
Na schau.
Genau. So, Politik wird in New York gemacht. Er ist noch nicht Bürgermeister, das beginnt erst im Januar. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass in New York so was abläuft wie in Portland oder Los Angeles.
Kann ich mir jetzt auch wenig vorstellen, um man noch diesen Auftritt zu bewerten. Es ist ja so, dass wir von Donald Trump wissen, für ihn ist das alles Entscheidende die Show. Wir haben ihn immer wieder in Pressekonferenzen erlebt, in denen er sogar die Zeitung hochhielt und sagt, so viel Presse hatte ich noch nie und so gut kam ich noch nie in der Washington Post weg. Es waren immer genau diese Vorgehensweisen. Nun ist Trump jemand, der Showmenschen unglaublich liebt, weil er dann etwas Abglanz abbekommt, wenn sie dort bei ihm stehen. Deswegen lädt er Ronaldo ein und und und. Jetzt hat er gesehen, Mamdani ist ein genialer Redner, ein Showmensch, der alles Mögliche beherrscht, der auch noch wahrscheinlich im Musical auftreten könnte, problemlos und denkt sich, aber nur mit seinem Rap. Scheiße, JD Vans wäre vielleicht gerne so wie Mamdani, ist es aber nicht. JD Vans hat ja nicht diese Entertainer Qualitäten. Mamdani hat sie und dass Trump davon fasziniert ist. Das muss man sich eher so vorstellen, wie wenn früher Dean Martin und Frank Sinatra beschlossen, zusammen ein Konzert zu geben. So ist die Herangehensweise in dem Moment im Oval Office, dass das gut funktioniert, weshalb dann ihr auch direkt über die Inhalte hinausgegangen wird. Mamdani wird gefragt, ja sie haben ja den Präsidenten immer wieder als Faschisten bezeichnet. Und Trump geht sofort dazwischen, lässt Mamdani das gar nicht beantworten, sondern sagt, ist okay, dauert jetzt auch viel zu lang, irgendwas zu erklären, ist okay. Das heißt, er sagt, jetzt gilt hier Show. Und eigentlich ist ein großer Neid da. Also Trump hätte, glaube ich, am liebsten gesagt, lieber Mamdani, können wir vielleicht doch irgendwie zusammen. Und ich habe ja diesen langweiligen JD Vans, aber hier, sie sind ja eigentlich noch mal besser. Und das meine ich jetzt, und bitte nicht falsch verstehen, ich weiß, wie schlimm Trump ist und was er da alles fürchterliches macht. Das weiß auch Mamdani, der muss das nicht dreimal sagen da. Aber ich will noch einmal doch betonen, Trump macht ganz viele rechte, schlimme Sachen. Aber er ist am Ende auch ein post-ideologischer Präsident, im Sinne von, am Ende geht alles über die Show. Das funktioniert aber bei dem Umfeld, das er sich geschaffen hat, bei den Wählern, die er hat, und bei den Seilschaften, die er pflegt, zumal er ja auch mit Korruption und einiges zu tun hat, mit Autokraten und all denen besonders gut. Und deswegen ist das so. Aber wir haben es hier nicht mit einem JD Vance zu tun. Das stimmt. Das ist noch mal ein Unterschied, womit ich nur sagen will, ist diese flexible Haltung interessant, weil ein JD Vance wäre auf einen Konfrontationskurs mit Mamdani gegangen oder mit Josh Hawley oder wer auch immer. Die hätten das gemacht. Bei ihm ist in dem Moment zu sagen, funktioniert das als Duett? Kriegen wir damit Applaus? Dann machen wir das so. Und das meine ich mit postideologisch. Ich meine nicht, dass der sonst einfach ideologiefrei Politik macht. Oder ich meine auch nicht, dass er nicht rechte Politik macht. Nein, er macht sehr rechte Politik.
Ich möchte es aufgreifen, aber auch kritisch unformulieren. Trump ist postideologisch, weil er einfach doof ist. Und Mandani ist sehr klug. Und er weiß, ich habe zwar gerade ein Foto-Opt mit Trump, aber eigentlich werden die kommenden Kämpfe gegen Stephen Miller, gegen JD. Vance und so weiter geführt. Weshalb es, finde ich, richtig gut gelungen ist, wie er dieses weiße Haus-Ding da absolviert hat, sich niemals zu Trump runterzubeugen, sondern da zu stehen wie eine Eins, mit den Journalisten zu reden und so weiter und so fort. Also dieser ganze Kram. Das war sehr, sehr, sehr gut.
Und die im Hintergrund von Trump werden Mamdani dafür jetzt richtig hassen. Und die werden auch sauer sein auf Trump, weil die hätten jetzt gehofft, dass Trump möglicherweise Mamdani so begegnet, wie er Zelensky vorgeführt hat. Und dass das nicht geschehen ist, das wird sie ungeheuer wurmen.
Ja, also das war wirklich ein geniales Ding. Wir steigen aus diesem Podcast demnächst aus, in dem wir jetzt über die Wirtschaftsweisen reden. Das Herbstgutachten ist da und das wird ja von den Vieren oder sind es fünf vorgestellt. Jeder hat so sein eines Kapitel. Nur mal ein paar interessante Werte.
Ja, vielleicht bevor wir das gerade sagen. Also es gibt dieses Gutachten und in der Vergangenheit war es ja häufig so, dass die gewerkschaftlichere Seite oft so ein Sondervotum hatte. Also hat dann noch mal eine eigene Anmerkung in diesem Gutachten gemacht. Also das wäre zu den verschiedenen Themen. Das wäre jetzt also nach alten Zeiten wäre das so gewesen, das wird vorgestellt. Aber dann gibt es immer noch die Sonderinterventionen von Achim Trugat. Das wäre eigentlich so gewesen. Die Welt hat sich aber gewandelt. Die Ökonomen verändern sich, die Blickweisen verändern sich. Bedeutet jetzt gibt es eine große Einigkeit. Also bei Achim Trugat und den anderen Monika Schnitzer, die ja auch dabei ist. Man hat sich also da geeinigt. Es gibt jetzt plötzlich von der anderen Seite immer eine extra Wurst. Und diese andere Seite vertritt Veronika Grimm. Und wenn man mal in dieses Dokument, ich glaube es sind knapp 800 Seiten, wenn man da reinschaut, dann sieht man da immer nochmal abgesetzt, was Veronika Grimm zu den einzelnen Dingen meint.
Genau. Diesmal hat sie, es gibt ein richtiges Minderheiten-Wofo, irgendwo zu einem spezifischen Punkt.
Zu mehreren hat sie das gemacht.
Also hier geht es gleich um eine der inneren.
Also bei Vermögen macht sie das, aber sie hat auch bei anderen Bereichen dann. Also sie ist kaum noch einzuhägen scheint mir.
Genau. Also man wollte so ein Novum unterbringen. Wir nähern uns dem mal zum einen zahlen zu Europa. Ich war ein bisschen überrascht.
Leider verschenkt Europa jedoch bisher sein Potenzial. Denn nach wie vor erschweren Handelsbarrieren den grenzüberschreitenden Verkehr von Waren, Dienstleistungen und Kapital. Der dadurch entstehende Aufwand ist enorm und entspricht laut Schätzungen des Internationalen Währungsfonds hypothetischen Zöllen in Höhe von 44 Prozent. Bei Dienstleistungen sind es sogar 110 Prozent. Wenn also Europa als Wirtschaftsraum global wieder eine größere Rolle spielen will, muss sich die Europäische Union auf ihre Gründungsidee besinnen und den Binnenmarkt deutlich stärken.
Also 100 Prozent, aber haben wir wirklich noch hypothetische Zölle von noch 100 Prozent im europäischen Binnenmarkt bei diesen Dienstleistungen und Sachen, weil da ist ja dann doch noch einiges Potenzial. Ich dachte, wir sind hier ein bisschen, aber wer weiß, sie hat ja auch die Zahlen nur zitiert aus anderen Quellen. Lösung.
Wir unterscheiden uns jedoch von anderen Appellen, indem wir erstens nach der Priorisierung konkreter Maßnahmen zu konkreten Zeitpunkten in der nahen Zukunft fragen, nicht nach neuen groß angelegten Strategien. Zweitens bedarf es einer Reform der Entscheidungsfindung in der EU. Um Herausforderungen schnell zu adressieren, kann nicht nur die EU der verschiedenen Geschwindigkeiten genutzt werden, sondern auch kleinere Koalitionen der Willigen, idealerweise unter Führung größerer Mitgliedsstaaten.
Ich frage mich so ein bisschen, an was ihr da gerade denkt. Welcher große Mitgliedsstaat soll jetzt mit welchen kleineren irgendeinen zweiten Geschwindigkeit EU-Intensivierung machen? Deutschland mit Niederlande? Weil das noch so die zwei Vogalisten waren, aber jetzt auch nicht mehr so richtig. Oder Frankreich mit, na die sind eh mit sich selbst beschäftigt. Soll Meloni das jetzt machen? Diese Sonntagsreden mittlerweile sind auch so ein bisschen, Europa ist gar nicht mehr in diesem Zustand, wo man sich so denkt, ja der deutsch-französische Motor oder irgendwas. Ist mir ja ein bisschen aufgefallen. So, Veronika Grimm zum Thema Unternehmenssteuern ist natürlich ihr Lieblingskapitel. Sie nennt eine Zahl, möchte uns danach sagen, das ist ganz schön viel. Ich sage, what, das ist ja wirklich brutal wenig.
Der Sachverständigenrat hat sich auch mit dem Thema Unternehmensbesteuerung fast in diesem Jahr unter dem Titel Unternehmenssteuern reformieren, Verzerrungen abbauen. Bei den Unternehmenssteuern steht die Politik ja in einem Spannungsfeld. Einerseits tragen die maßgeblich zu den Staatseinnahmen bei aktuell im Jahr 2024 12 Prozent der gesamtstaatlichen Einnahmen. Andererseits ist Kapital mobil und steuerliche Rahmenbedingungen beeinflussen natürlich Investitionsentscheidungen, Finanzierungsentscheidungen der Unternehmen und eben auch die Standortentscheidungen, wie wir schmerzlich merken müssen.
Wir übersetzen, dass das Kapital, wisst ihr doch alle, ist das Steueree und jetzt braucht ihr zwar Einnahmen, aber das kann doch gar nicht sein, dass wir jetzt noch mehr steuern wollen, weil die doch schon 12 Prozent zahlen und dann denke ich auch, 12 Prozent scheint mir nicht besonders viel zu sein.
Ja, das ist ja gar nichts.
Bei dem Steueraufkommen 12 Prozent ist nicht viel.
Genau, da muss auch wirklich radikal ungedacht werden. Hier muss man doch wirklich Arbeit komplett entlasten, also wirklich fast keine Einkommenssteuer mehr machen und komplett die Produktivität abschöpfen.
Interessant, ja.
Und auch bei der Mehrwertsteuer.
Denn wir haben ja schon jetzt gehört, das letzte Mal bei unserem letzten Podcast, als wir über Rürup und Hüter sprachen, wie die das einordnen. Sie haben ja auch gesagt, es ist ja interessant, dass die DAX-Konzerne Rekordgewinne machen und dass die deutsche Wirtschaft so lahmt, also dass wir in einer Rezession sind. Nun, naja, was haben sie gesagt? Die nehmen das Geld und investieren es ins Ausland. Das war die Antwort. Aber Veronika Grimm will eigentlich den noch mehr Geld zufließen lassen, damit sie noch mehr Geld ins Ausland fließen lassen können.
Also 12 Prozent der Steuereinnahmen des Staates, also der gesamtstaatlichen Einnahmen, kommen von den Unternehmen. Und ich denke mir so, das heißt, 88 Prozent kommen, woher denn eigentlich? Also wir haben ja jetzt kein riesiges Zollregime.
Wir haben auch nicht eine Vermögensteuer. Wir haben auch kaum Erbschaftssteuer.
Das heißt, wir beide zahlen quasi Arbeitseinkommen über Arbeitseinkommen und Konsum.
Wer wird Steuer und all das?
Also hier würde ich sagen, wir bräuchten mal einen deutschen Intellektuellen. Vielleicht Fridolin von Schurach, der mal im Fernsehen die Idee vorschlägt. Wir entlasten uns jetzt alle mal ein bisschen davon und sagen, ne, die Unternehmen machen jetzt bitte nicht billige Produkte, damit dann im Supermarkt 19 Prozent Mehrwertsteuer drauf geschlagen werden kann, sondern schieben das mal direkt alles in Produktivitätsbesteuerung, weil wir dann viel Feintuner umstellen können, welche Produktivität wollen wir eigentlich besteuern und so. Weil das ja einfach eine Pauschale auf mich und dir und uns allen liegt und die Unternehmen so, naja, wir steuern auch mal 12 Prozent bei. Ich meine, Deutschland sind wirklich nur die Unternehmen. Wer bewegt denn hier Geld, wenn nicht die Unternehmen?
Ja, die Leute verdienen Bruttow, also jetzt mal eine Euro-Summe gegriffen, 5000, dann zahlen sie 2000 Steuern, haben 3000, dann verkonsumieren sie einen großen Teil und müssen darüber Mehrwertsteuer zahlen, dann kommt das halt zusammen.
Also mir ist 12 Prozent wirklich, ich bin schockiert, zu wenig. Veronika Grimm sieht es natürlich anders.
In diesem Kontext haben viele Staaten in der jüngeren Vergangenheit ihre Unternehmenssteuern gesenkt.
Ja, nehme ich von 12 auf 9, weil das ist dann besser.
Allerdings hat Deutschland, ist Deutschland dann nicht mitgezogen mit derzeit 28,5 Prozent der effektiven Steuerbelastungen der Unternehmen. Also Kombination aus Körperschaft und Gewerbesteuer ist Deutschland aktuell verglichen mit anderen großen Industriestaaten oder mit europäischen Nachbarländern auf einem relativ hohen Niveau.
Ich will das nochmal durchsagen. Arbeitseinkommen können bis 45 Prozent besteuert werden. Aber bei Unternehmen sagt sie jetzt schon mal 28 Prozent, das ist zu viel.
Ich bin jetzt hier Team Rürup Hüter, wir wundern uns. Und dann bin ich Team Nicht-Veronika Grimm bei Wir ändern das. Truger.
Darf ich ihn abschließen?
Das ist natürlich, hört genau hin, das ist nur zum Abschluss. Darf ich noch kurz was zur Vermögensverteilung sagen?
Darf ich Ihnen abschließend kurz die Ergebnisse unseres Kapitels zur Vermögensverteilung vorstellen, das heißt Vermögensaufbau stärken, Erbschaften und Schenkungen gleichmäßiger besteuern. Gemäß unserem gesetzlichen Auftrag analysieren wir regelmäßig die Verteilungsentwicklung.
Es ist schon ganz interessant, dass Sie jetzt den gesetzlichen Auftrag haben, Einkommen zu beobachten und jetzt auf Vermögen umschwenken, weil Sie da ein Problem sehen und Veronika Gremiums Aufgabe ja wirklich nur ist zu sagen, dieses Gremium handelt bitte nach staatlichem Auftrag. Ihr kommt nicht auf eigene Föllefanz-Ideen und macht jetzt plötzlich was zu Vermögen. Die Droga, also Ihr Kapitel Vermögen.
Diesmal steht seit Längerem einmal wieder die Vermögensverteilung im Mittelpunkt. Sonst immer Einkommensverteilung, diesmal explizit Vermögensverteilung. Die Ergebnisse sind wie folgt, die Vermögensungleichheit in Deutschland ist hoch. Sie hat seit der deutschen Einheit zugenommen und ist seit den 2010er Jahren in etwa konstant. Während die untere Hälfte der Bevölkerung nur über 2% der Nettovermögen verfügt, verfügen die obersten 10% der Verteilung über etwa 60% des Nettovermögens. Die Ungleichheit ist auch im Euro-Raumvergleich hoch, nur in Österreich liegt sie noch etwas höher.
Ja, denn Österreich, wir wissen es, haben gar keine Erbschaftssteuer.
Ja, das ist auch sehr gut für die Österreicher. Damit führen sie Europa an. Wir sind dann schon auf Platz zwei. Das ist natürlich wirklich nicht gut. Und ja, Trugar stellt uns jetzt mal da, wenn wir doch so schön reich sind, die Deutschen. Wo kommt der ganze Geld her?
In der unteren Hälfte gelingt der Vermögensaufbau kaum, weil die Haushalte kaum Möglichkeiten haben, zu sparen und das Ersparte eher als Notgroschen und daher renditisch schwach anlegen. Für einen grundlegenden Neustart des Vermögensaufbaus schlägt der Sachverständigenrat daher die Einführung eines geförderten Vorsorge-Depots, insbesondere zur Altersvorsorge, vor. Die bisher fragmentierte staatliche Vermögensförderung, also es gibt da Arbeitnehmer-Sparzulage und so weiter, sollte vereinfacht und in diesem Vorsorge-Depot gebündelt werden. Hiermit kann gezielt die Sparfähigkeit von Haushalten mit geringem Einkommen gestärkt werden. Wir sehen da auch einen Zusammenhang zur Frühstartrente. Und wenn Sie da zur genauen Ausgestaltung Fragen haben, dann fragen Sie meine Kollegin Ulrike Mahl mit dir, deren Spezialgebiet das tatsächlich ist. Genau, so. Am oberen Rand spielen insbesondere Erbschaften und Schenkungen eine wesentliche Rolle für anhaltende Vermögensungleichheit. Für Deutschland wird der Anteil der Vermögen, der allein auf Erbschaften und Schenkungen zurückgeht, auf 30 bis 50 Prozent geschätzt.
50 Prozent?
Absurd.
50 Prozent des Vermögens, also Leute gehen in der Straße, man sieht sie in der Stadt, sie gehen einfach shoppen. 50 Prozent des Geldes, das da ausgegeben wird, kam einfach über Schenkungen. Aus der Geschichte. Die Norweger holen es wenigstens noch aus dem Boden und zünden es dann an. Das sieht wenigstens noch cool aus. Wir generieren das einfach aus der Geschichte. Das ist halt altes Vermögen.
Altes Geld.
Das ist brutal. So, jetzt ein ganz wichtiger Punkt. Wir haben in Deutschland immer wieder das Problem, dass dann irgendwelche Leute sagen, ja mein Haus, die Familie, wir müssen jetzt irgendwas verkaufen, um die Erbschaftssteuer zu bezahlen. Der linke Diskurs muss sein, mitleiden. Diese Leute haben Mitleid verdient.
Wer in Deutschland ein Haus erbt und dann irgendwie in Schwulitäten kommt, in schwierige Gefahr, Fahrwasser, weil die Familie hat ja sonst nichts, außer dieses Haus und plötzlich muss es irgendwie so liquidiert werden, keine Ahnung, wie auch immer. Wir haben jetzt Mitleid mit diesen Leuten, die ein Haus vererben. Wir haben aber kein Mitleid mit den Leuten, die tausend Häuser vererben. Das ist die Trennlinie. Die Trennlinie ist nicht, man hat überhaupt etwas zu vererben und ist gleichzeitig, ah ja gut, dann bist du ja fein raus und so, weil ich als Ossi kriege ja nichts geerbt und vererbe nicht so wie auch immer, sondern nein, es geht um kleine und große Erbschaften. Die müssen jetzt hart unterschieden werden und man muss die kleinen Erben mit ins eigene Boot holen gegen die großen Erben. Das ist die fundamentale Unterscheidung.
Eine Reform der Erbschaft- und Schenkungssteuer sollte für eine gleichmäßige Besteuerung sorgen, die sich stärker am Leistungsfähigkeitsprinzip orientiert. Bislang verhindert dies die drastische Begünstigung von Betriebsvermögen. In der Vergangenheit wurde die Begünstigung bereits vom Bundesverfassungsgericht als unverhältnismäßig beurteilt und aktuell ist dazu auch wieder eine Klage in Karlsruhe anhängig, wo das Urteil wohl in Wälde erwartet wird. Die Begünstigung führt dazu, dass gerade die höchsten Vermögensübertragungen besonders niedrig besteuert werden. So liegt der durchschnittliche Steuersatz für übertragendes Vermögen zwischen 100.000 und 200.000 Euro aktuell bei 13 Prozent. Bei Riesenvermögen oberhalb von 20 Millionen Euro, aber nur bei 8 Prozent. Eine so umfassende Begünstigung ist immer halt des Betriebes und der Arbeitsplätze nicht erforderlich.
Ja, also wenn man ja noch um...
Und wir wissen ja, was zu dem Betriebsvermögen auch dann dazugehört. Das sind dann 30 Wohnungen oder 300 Wohnungen.
Ja, also ab, es gibt ja eine Zahl, der das drin steht, absolut so viel. Also wir haben eine falsch rum georganisierte Progressivität. Ja. Beim Einkommen ist völlig klar, man bezahlt jetzt mal gar nichts und dann immer mehr bis zu diesem Höchststeuersatz. Und das brauchen wir bei Erben auch genau so. Niemand darf mehr als 300 Millionen erben. Wenn jemand drei Milliarden erbt, ist das 90 Prozent Erbschaftssteuer. So würde ich es bauen, aber mich fragt ja keiner. Und Trugger kriegt jetzt hier eine Nachfrage, die Journalisten schon so, ah, Konflikt, ich würde auch sagen Konflikt, das haben wir gestern schon vorbereitet. Ja, wir wussten ja, was kommt.
Ja, Frage an Herrn Trugger zunächst. Ich verstehe jetzt Ihre Position bei der Erbschaftssteuer als neu. Also falls es zutrifft, warum kommt jetzt diese neue Positionierung? Und es gibt dazu ja auch ein Minderheitsvotum von Frau Grimm.
Huh, da hat aber jemand richtig investigativ schon mal vorab gelesen, hat dann von der Redaktion, komm hier, frag mal so und so. Trugger natürlich, ja, so neu.
Ja, vielen Dank. Also ich weiß gar nicht, was daran genau neu ist. Es ist so, dass der Sachverständigenrat verschiedenste Beiräte und ganz viele Juristinnen, Juristen, Finanzwissenschaftlerinnen, Finanzwissenschaftler eigentlich alle die extreme Begünstigung des Betriebsvermögens moniert haben.
Ja, aber du hast ja eben selber gesagt, Achim, das ist jetzt bei uns auch mal nach langem Wiederthema, also es ist schon neu, aber ja, kann man natürlich in, sagen wir mal, hauspolitischer Art und Weise so kurz weg moderieren. Grims Minderheitenvotum, sie muss natürlich selber noch mal kurz hier anmerken.
Vielleicht zu meinem Minderheitsvotum kurz selbst was sagen.
Ja, ist auch witzig, sie wurde gar nicht gefragt.
Vielleicht zu meinem Minderheitsvotum kurz selbst was sagen. Also in dem Kapitel wird natürlich als erste wichtigste Botschaft herausgestellt, dass die Vermögensverteilung im europäischen Vergleich hoch ist. Dabei würde ich denken, müsste man eigentlich die Funktion der sozialen Sicherungssysteme mit berücksichtigen und auch im europäischen Vergleich analysieren, weil Deutschland natürlich ein Land ist, das über das Umlagesystem in der Rentenversicherung eben relativ hohe Rentenansprüche hat im europäischen Vergleich.
Ja, sehr schön. Da können wir noch mal wunderbar dran anklopfen. Das ist eine Umverteilung innerhalb der arbeitenden Klasse. Die Rente ist eine Frage von denjenigen, die in die Rente einzahlen. Das ist nicht eine Frage von die Vermögenden geben irgendetwas da ab. Das mag sein, dass man hier eine bisschen bessere Rente als irgendwo in Europa in anderen Ländern bekommt. Aber das hat ja erst einmal was zu tun mit einer Solidargemeinschaft zwischen denen, die ihre Arbeitskraft verkaufen müssen. Das jetzt so rückzukoppeln, um zu sagen, wir haben ja einen besseren Sozialstaat und deswegen brauchen wir die Vermögen nicht entsprechend so in den Blick zu nehmen, ist ja unsinnig.
Ich sage mal so, sie haben ja nicht von der Rente, sondern vom Rentenanspruch gesprochen, was ja bedeutet, jemand, der heute mit 65 Jahren in Rente geht, kann einfach null Vermögen haben, aber er hat trotzdem Anspruch auf monatlich, sagen wir mal 1500 Euro, das mal zwölf, das auf 20 Jahre Leben im Schnitt.
Aber aus seinem eigenen Geld ja dahin geht.
Genau.
Jetzt kann man sagen, dann gibt es da ein bisschen, also sie tut jetzt so, als sei das eigentlich wie die Sparquote zu behandeln.
Ja, aber den Rentenanspruch gar nicht zu behandeln, wäre ja auch falsch. Von daher stimmt das schon.
Man kann das machen, nur...
Da muss sich halt dann erst materialisieren. Es kann auch sein, dass man in 66 stirbt. Dann ist natürlich, dann haben die ein Recht gehabt, die gesagt haben, wir haben es mal nicht reingerechnet, weil du eh schon früh stirbst, wünschen wir aber keinem. Aber man kann die statistische Größe, 21 Jahre Rentenbezug, da sind wir ja heute angekommen und die Rentenhöhe, die zu erwarten ist, schon mit reinnehmen, warum die das nicht gemacht haben, okay, so.
Gut, aber wenn wir jetzt so rangehen, also das kannst du natürlich machen, also die Frage ist ja eh.
Wenn jemand die Wart vorgesorgt hat, wird der Geld auch mit reingerechnet?
Genau, der wird mit reingenommen und bei den anderen wird er nicht mit reingerechnet. Jetzt kann man sagen, ja die Rente ist in anderen Ländern anders organisiert und deswegen, und vielleicht auch nicht so hoch und deswegen verbieten sich, so ist ja ihre Argumentation, Vermögensvergleiche, die sagen ja innereuropäisch ist Deutschland das Land mit der größten Vermögen zur Ungleichheit. Nur haben wir ja gerade die Zahlen gehört, dass die Progression ja nicht stattfindet bei den Vermögen. Also das ist ja das interessante Ding, dass die Progression, also die Umverteilung mit anderen Worten, findet ja statt bei den Arbeitseinkommen, aber sie findet ja nicht bei den Vermögen statt.
Also beim Erbschaftsstall.
Ja und auch sonst bleiben Vermögen bleiben, und da ist die Ungleichheit so hoch.
Wir haben ja keine Vermögensteuer, aber wir haben einen Erbschaftsstall.
Und das kann man schon für sich stehen lassen, nur will sie ja jetzt quasi darauf hinaus zu sagen, höhere Vermögen sind gar nicht jetzt unser Problem, weil die Leute ja die tolle Rente bekommen.
Ja, das ist nämlich der Punkt.
Von der wir aber wissen, das ist ja keine tolle Rente. Es mag sein, dass es in anderen Ländern noch ein bisschen schlechter ist. Das wollen wir hier auch gar nicht in Abrede stellen. Nur das ist ja die Verbindung, die sie da macht. Und jetzt sagt sie einfach, ja wenn die weniger im Umlageverfahren einsahen müssten und hätten die das Geld auf die hohe Kante gelegt, dann würde sich doch im Vergleiche eigentlich zeigen, dass die europäischen Länder gar nicht so weit auseinander liegen. Und da würde ich sagen, ja, das kann man natürlich jetzt so durchdiktinieren, dann ist aber die Frage, also die, wegen mir können wir die Kritik teilen an Veronika Grimm an diesem Vergleich. Ich brauche den Vergleich aber auch gar nicht mit anderen europäischen Ländern. Ich sehe einfach, dass die Vermögensungleichheit so gestaltet ist, dass für die meisten Leute, das bedeutet, dass sie im Alter nicht irgendwas als Rücklage haben, während die anderen steuerfrei oder zumindest zu geringen Steuern vererben können.
Ich will mal so sagen, ich weiß ja nicht genau, wie die Juristen und Ökonomen das so machen, aber ich frage hier, ist ja, wenn jemand eine Lebensversicherung hat, die bei seinem Todesfall 500.000 Euro auslöst und er zahlt dafür jeden Monat 17 Euro oder was, keine Ahnung. Wie verrechnen wir diesen möglichen Todesfall in einer Vermögensverrechnung für die Ehefrau, die dann davon profitiert und so? Ja. Also ist das jetzt Buchgeld oder nicht und so? Das ist ja alles schwierig. Von daher würde ich sagen, Deutschland bezahlt jedes Jahr 350 Milliarden Euro Rente und dieses Geld ist zumindest auszahlerseitig sehr zweckgebunden, kann man schon so eine Rechnung mit aufnehmen. Mal grob, einfach um uns Orientierung zu geben. Von daher, ich verstehe das. Ich finde es unter zwei Sachen abyssant. Das eine ist, Veronika Grimm kämpft gerade um ihr Leben. Denn wir wissen ja, dass hinter ihr so Leute stehen, die auch Resultate dafür haben wollen, dass sie da in diesen Kreis aufgenommen wurde. Und wenn dann in der Bundespressekonferenz plötzlich eine Erbschaftssteuer diskutiert wird, ist es ein absoluter schlechter Tag für Veronika Grimm. Weil dann muss sie das abends ihren Kumpels erklären und es geht nicht gut.
Und dann schiebt sie das jetzt auf hohe Rentenansprüche.
Genau. Und das finde ich so gut, dass sie hier einfach von exorbitanten Rentenansprüchen redet, obwohl die ja im internationalen Vergleich gar nicht so sind. Also wir haben das mit Niederlande, wir haben das mit Österreich, wir haben das mit Dänemark. Die haben ja alle 500 bis 1000 Euro mehr pro Monat als ein deutscher Rentner. Und dass die Unternehmensseite über Veronika Grimm, jetzt plötzlich so ein Grimmsmärchen von der hohen Rente, die man ja berechnen könnte, das ist ja auch amüsant einfach. Grimm wirft jetzt ihren Kolleginnen hier mal Fahrlässigkeit vor.
Und letztlich ist es so, dass natürlich bei der Die Erbschaftssteuerung und Erschenkungsbesteuerung. Jetzt könnte man natürlich alle möglichen Gründe anführen. Und natürlich wird das diskutiert. Es fragt sich aber, ob wir in einer Schwächephase, wie der aktuellen, Herr Trugger hat ja auch gerade gesagt, wenn dann Mehreinnahmen resultieren, dann könnten wir damit das Bildungssystem finanzieren. Ich bin sehr dafür, das Bildungssystem zu stärken. Aber eine Anpassung der Besteuerung, indem man die Verschonung von Betriebsvermögen abbaut, in einem Ausmaß, dass dann Mehreinnahmen bei der Erbschaftssteuer herauskommen, das führt dazu, dass man sich eigentlich die Frage stellen muss, wie belastet das denn die Investitionen und die weiterbefehenden Entscheidungen der Unternehmen?
Ja, haben wir uns ja angeschaut, gar nicht.
Das ist zum Gutachten überhaupt nicht analysiert worden. Also ich finde diese Empfehlung relativ fahrlässig vor dem Hintergrund der aktuellen Wirtschaftslage.
Also selbst Rührup und Hüter sagen, die legen das Geld im Ausland an.
Genau, die fahren damit Ski in Japan, die kaufen sich Kram.
Das sind ja oder oder haben wirklich einfach Depots im Ausland. Ja, irgendwo haben wir Aktien in US-amerikanische Unternehmen und damit ist gut. Das ist die Investition.
Also Scott Gelberl beschreibt in seinem Podcast, in diesem, was wir eben gehört haben, er hat selber, er weiß nicht mehr wohin mit dem Geld, also mit seinem eigenen Geld. Und seine neue Anlagestrategie ist Wohnhäuser für wirklich super Reiche, für den nächsten Milliardär, weil er weiß, Leute, die irgendwann in zehn Jahren oder so Milliardäre werden, durch irgendwelche Techniksprünge, irgendwas, irgendwer hat wieder profitiert. Den Leuten sind ihre Wohnkosten dann wirklich egal. Also ob deren Haus dann 50, 80 oder 120 Millionen kostet, ist einfach egal, gerade wenn sie neue Milliardär wurden, weil 15 Prozent fürs Wohnen ist ja eigentlich normal, oder? Und dann kauft man halt für 150 Millionen, was für ihn bedeutet, ja, ich investiere jetzt 30 Millionen, dann habe ich 50, so, oder? Und darum geht es hier, um solche Leute, die also bei uns immer, die Familienunternehmer, ne, das sind einfach Familien, die haben ein Portfolio mit 800 Investitionen, 800 verschiedene Positionen, so wie Julia Friedrichs das beschrieb. So, wenn man da sagt, wir ziehen da jetzt was ab, wenn das Portfolio da vererbt wird, bleiben am Ende nur noch 30 Prozent da an, der Rest muss liquidiert werden, verschwindet dieses Geld nicht aus der Welt, es wird nicht von diesen Unternehmen abgezogen, in Unternehmen fehlt das Geld nicht für Research und Development. Es gibt nur jemand anders dann aus. Es wird halt bei jemand anderem im Portfolio verbucht als Rendite später. So, also dieses ganze Szenario hier von ihr gibt es einfach überhaupt gar nicht. Aber sie stellt es so dar, als müsste man auf jeden Fall und hier, und es ist ja ganz fahrlässig, Truger im ersten nur schwach, finde ich, in der ersten Antwort.
Ja, genau, ich würde gerne ergänzen. Also an Fahrlässigkeit kann ich bei uns da jetzt nicht viel erkennen.
So, Monika Spitzer lacht auch.
Fahrlässigkeit kann ich bei uns da jetzt nicht viel erkennen. Wir sprechen die Probleme an und wir sprechen auch darüber, dass es natürlich vom Steuersatz abhängig ist, dass gegebenenfalls es niedrigere Steuersätze im Rahmen einer Mindeststeuer oder sowas geben könnte. Das machen wir alles. Ich möchte aber vielleicht noch mal sagen, es gibt auch noch ein Leben nach der Rezession irgendwann. Und wir machen uns hier grundsätzlich konzeptionelle Gedanken. Und da sollte man über diese Dinge, glaube ich, ganz vernünftig und ruhig nachdenken.
So, ein bisschen schwach vorgetragen, weil der letzte Punkt sehr wichtig. Wir haben ja noch ein Leben nach der Rezension. Da finde ich so ein bisschen, ja, lass die Rezession einfach durchlaufen, keine Ahnung, jetzt zwei, drei Jahre, was auch immer, du hast es sehr bescheiden. Wir sollten uns gar nicht mehr von irgendeiner Krisensemantik wie vorhin schon betrachtet. Wir machen jetzt einfach Politik, als wäre keine Krise. Und wenn Karim Mioska und Herr Schirach behaupten, ihr seid ja überall Krisen, dann sagen wir, ja, habe ich auch gehört, aber ich habe mein EC-Konto noch nicht gekündigt, das mit dem Geld funktioniert noch ziemlich gut, ich habe nur zu wenig.
Man hat ja davor, die 10, 15 Jahre, auch die ganze Zeit Politik so gemacht, als hätte man eine Krise.
Ja, es ist einfach immer Krise.
Es war ja nie der Punkt, dass man sagt, 2016 ein super Tag, heute erhöhen wir die Unternehmensteuer oder so. Das hat es ja nie gegeben.
Genau, wenn Veronika Grimm sagt, nein, wenn wir die Unternehmensteuer erhöhen, dann geht das ja auf Grunds Kosten der Investition.
Vor allen Dingen kann man ja auch direkt sagen, die Krise ist ja bei den DAX-Unternehmen schon mal nicht da. Offenbar nicht.
Genau, da ist ja gar keine Krise. So, jetzt hat Trugha aber ein bisschen Anlauf genommen, um noch mal beim Kapitelvorstellung Veno-Obenika Grimm reinzuschießen. Wir kennen ja alle, sie heißt Grimm, dafür kann sie nichts, aber es sind nur mal Grimmsmärchen, die sie dann erzählt. Dafür ist sie ja berühmt. Im Grunde greift Trugha das jetzt auf. Er unterstellt ihr jetzt Grimmsmärchen.
Ich würde gerne auf das Thema Unternehmenssteuern kommen. Das haben sie gesagt, sie machen da Vorschläge für eine neutrale Besteuerung und verschiedene Ansätze. Herr Trugha, können Sie das einmal einordnen, für wie realistisch Sie diese Ansätze halten? Ist das das, was die aktuelle Bundesregierung auch noch umsetzen könnte? Oder wie schauen Sie darauf?
Wir haben ja sozusagen zwei Arten vor Vorschlägen. Das eine ist eine Senkung der Körperschaftsteuerung, die 5-Prozent-Punkte, und das andere ist das, was die Bundesregierung gemacht hat. Und dann eben diese eher akademischen Sachen aus dem Lehrbuch, Cashflow-Steuer oder zinsbereinigte Steuer. Und für mich ist das tatsächlich eher eine Lehrbuchvariante und ein hübsches Rechenbeispiel. In der Realität würde ich dem Ganzen ehrlich gesagt nicht besonders trauen. Also kein Modell der Welt hat jemals eine solche Steuerreform gesehen. Das gibt keine empirischen Erfahrungen damit. Und wenn man sich mal anschaut, was das Modell ausspuckt, dass es sozusagen diese Übergangsfahrt in dem Zerwerfungen gibt, dann ist, obwohl er schon geglättet ist, er ist ja schrittweise, stürzt die Ökonomie erstmal in eine Rezession. Und die öffentlichen Haushalte haben 77 Milliarden pro Jahr Mindereinnahmen zu bewältigen. Und das bedeutet für mich, dass der Vorschlag, und wenn man sich mal anschaut, was das Modell ausspuckt, dass es sozusagen diese Übergangsfahrt in den Verwerfungen gibt, dann ist, obwohl er schon geglättet ist, er ist ja schrittweise, stürzt die Ökonomie erstmal in eine Rezession und die öffentlichen Haushalte haben 77 Milliarden pro Jahr Mindereinnahmen zu bewältigen.
Klingt nach einer richtig guten Idee, Frau Grimm.
Und das bedeutet für mich, dass der Vorschlag tatsächlich aus der Welt ist. Und das ist ja auch der Fokus dann zu sagen, es gibt da andere Dinge, Forschungszulage, vielleicht eine Sparvariante in der Umsetzung dieses zinsbereinigten Grundkapitals oder so. Das erscheint mir realistischer, das andere ist eher für die Galerie, fürs Lehrbuch. Und schön, dass es mal simuliert wurde. Aber da würde ich der Politik sehr von abraten, ernsthaft in diese Richtung zu gehen. Und ich glaube, bei den Zahlen, die ich jetzt gerade genannt habe, muss man der Politik das so gar nicht raten. Das versteht ihr dann schon von selbst, dass hier nicht die wirtschaftliche Rezession stürzt und die öffentlichen Haushalte killt.
Rückfrage, teilt die Runde diese Auffassung über das Kapitel?
Normalerweise hört man das nur aus der Politik. Das sei jetzt eher aus dem wissenschaftlichen Lehrbuch. Aber ich glaube schon, dass das extrem wichtig ist.
Ja, lassen wir es dabei die anderen schmunzeln so in sich hinein. Achim Trugert zerstört Veronika Grimm, sehr schön.
Ja, wirklich schlimm. Okay, du hast noch drei Clips, sehe ich hier.
Ja, wir müssen jetzt noch was Schönes uns angucken.
Dann habe ich noch was ganz, ganz, ganz gruselig. Ich habe wirklich gedacht, das kann nicht wahr sein. Wir haben einen Krieg in Europa, in der Ukraine. Ja. Es ist immer ganz wichtig, dass man sagt, der Putin-Angriffskrieg usw., das ist alles richtig. Nur, es ist halt auch nüchtern betrachtet, erstmal einfach ein Krieg in Europa. Was bedeutet, manche Leute sind doch ein bisschen abenteuerlustig. Wir haben ja schon darüber gesprochen, dass Leute so da auch hinfahren. Die fühlen sich angezogen von irgendwelchen Sachen. Wir kriegen heute eine Aufarbeitung aus dem Bosnienkrieg, also 30 Jahre her. Und ich dachte mir so, liebes Heutejournal, bei manchen Sachen vielleicht, keine Ahnung, die kommen doch ein bisschen unvermittelt und so. Wir hören mal hier Geschichtsausarbeitung.
Auch der Begriff Katastrophentourismus ist nicht neu. Betrieben von Menschen, die es genau dorthin zieht, wo andere um ihr Leben und ihre Existenz kämpfen, etwa nach Naturkatastrophen oder in Kriegsgebeten. Denn auch Kriegstourismus gibt es, den kann man sogar organisiert buchen, quasi als Pauschalreise mit speziellen Nervenkitzeln. Doch das, was jetzt ein italienischer Investigativjournalist nach mühevoller Recherchearbeit an die Öffentlichkeit gebracht hat, hat noch mal eine ganz andere unfassbare Dimension. Die Kurzfassung? Während des Bosnienkriegs in den 1990er Jahren sollen reiche Europäer auf Kriegs-Safari gegangen sein um zu schießen. Auf Menschen. Michael B. Warunge berichtet.
Es ist diese eine Frage, die Stana und Samir Cicic auch nach 32 Jahren nicht aus dem Kopf geht. Warum? Ihre Tochter Irina war nur ein Jahr alt, als sie einen Scharfschütze mit seiner Kugel tötete. Im Sarajevo von 1993, alltäglicher Wahnsinn, die Lust am wahllosen Morden. Ich weiß nicht, wer mein Kind ermordet hat. Ich wusste auch nicht, dass so etwas überhaupt im Krieg geschehen kann. Dass es, wie soll ich sagen, Monster gibt, die so etwas aus Spaß tun. Wir können nicht wissen, wer der Täter war. Wenn wir es wüssten, würde ich keine Rache wollen. Aber wenn ich ihn sehe, würde ich ihn eines fragen wollen. Warum hast du das getan? Ist dir klar, was du getan hast? Damals wusste kaum jemand, dass offenbar nicht nur serbische Scharfschützen Jagd auf Männer, Frauen und Kinder machten. Sondern mortlustige Touristen aus Europa auf Wochenendurlaub in den Krieg fuhren. Vor allem aus Italien. Summen von 100.000 Euro und mehr sollen für ein Wochenende Menschenjagd gezahlt worden sein. Edin Subacic erzählt auf der berüchtigten Sniper-Allie in Sarajevo Ungeheuerliches. Er bekam schon 1994 erste Hinweise. Damals verhörte er als Geheimdienstoffizier einen Gefangenen. Der berichtete von Italienern, die für das Töten von Menschen zahlen. Ihre Ausrüstung und Jagdgewehre brachten sie wohl gleich mit. Das waren Leute mit sehr teurer Kleidung, fast so ähnlich wie Uniformen, aber am Ende stellte sich heraus, es war Jagdkleidung. Und auch ihre Waffen waren ganz und gar untypisch, so gar nicht militärisch. Subacic informierte die italienische Armee, stellte später Anzeige in Bosnien, doch nichts passierte. Erst die Zusammenarbeit mit dem italienischen Journalisten Gavazzini und weitere Recherchen führen nun zu Ermittlungen. Gavazzini spricht von hunderten Fällen. Wir reden hier über reiche Männer, Menschen mit einem guten Ruf, sozial arriviert. Doch sie alle haben eine Gemeinsamkeit. Sie lieben Waffen und sie lieben die Jagd.
Also vielleicht doch nochmal Steuer erhöhen?
Ja.
Das Geld ist da nicht gut aufgehoben. Das ist ja wirklich, und wirklich das ist in der Ukraine, das würde mich wundern, wenn das gerade niemand im Angebot hat.
Es gab hier im Salon ein Roman, den ich empfohlen habe, als Trophäe von Egea Schulters. Und dort geht es ja auch in eine solche Richtung.
Ah ja.
So, einen anderen Clip noch. Ich hatte ihn dir schon mal geschickt. Das amerikanische Militär hat kurz nach Trumps Amtseinführung vier Mitarbeiter aus dem Silicon Valley zu Lieutenant Colonel ernannt. Sehr hohe, also wirklich ranghohe Menschen, die quasi Befehlsgewalt haben. Und einer davon ist, also einer kam von Meta, einer von X, Google, Palantir oder so, keine Ahnung. Aber der von Palantir heißt Shayam Sankar. Er ist dort CTO, also Geschäftsführer, Technik-Officer. Und ist im Podcast von dem Do That, oder wie heißt der New York Times hier, Interesting Times. Und ich höre das so und denke mir, das hat jetzt eine komische Wendung genommen. Also er ist zuständig für Technologie, von der wir sagen, also Alex Karp und Peter Thiel ist nicht über den Weg zu trauen. Wenn die Bücher schreiben, lauten die mein Kampf.
Ihr wollt das jetzt hier noch gerade erwähnen, dass ja die Grünen in Baden-Württemberg für Palantir Technologie gestimmt haben.
Das ist wirklich ganz schlimm, ganz, ganz schlimm. Liebe Grüne, damit seid ihr unwählbar. So geht es gar nicht. Wir können nicht an so eine Hitler-Firma, die sagt, und das ist eben dieser Punkt, weshalb wir diesen Clip jetzt spielen, wir haben diesen Schirmacher-Satz noch im Ohr, die Ideen kommen auf zwei Arten in die Welt, entweder per Buch oder per Technologie. Und also Palantir, Palantir ist mein Kampf, aber nicht als Buch, sondern als Software. Darum geht es da.
Und der Chef schreibt dann noch mal ein Buch, das in dieselbe Richtung geht, nämlich The Technological Republic, da haben wir im Salon Toller gesprochen.
Genau, ganz schlimmes Buch. So, und jetzt hören wir diesen Sankar, also den CTO von Palantir hier im Podcast.
As I keep sort of pressing on, Palantir is in this position of having this incredibly powerful technology that you have to keep making moral and political judgments about. Who do you sell it to? Who do you work with? Who do you trust with this technology? Right. And it's in your interest in a way to convince yourself that the moral stakes of your work is always going to be somewhat constrained. But you're not worried that you or anyone else is in the position of building Skynet, building the system that yields true disaster. No, I'm not worried.
We're explicitly not building Skynet. The thing I'd say is, I'd offer a little bit of evidence, which is, for the Frontier Labs to be successful, they've all started to have to build software around their models. You can think about ChatGPT as the software interface to a model. You can think of all the coding assistants as software interfaces to the model. And I think in the general public, there's a lack of clarity of what is the software and what is the AI. And the more and more advanced uses of this stuff really require better models, sure. But they require more software. So I, you know, yes, maybe you could say no conflict, no interest. The facile view of this would be like, well, you're incentivized to believe it, but I suppose.
Das ist ja das, was Palantir an sich im Angebot hat.
Ja.
Einfach diese Software, mit der die KI so richtig genutzt werden kann, um den großen Datenreaktor anzuschließen, bitte einfach alle Daten aus dem Melderregister, aus dem Polizeiregister, aus dem Schulregister da rein, damit so ein Polizist einfach mal so orakel fragen kann. Da hab ich gerade diesen Wolfgang M. Schmitt angehalten, hat er irgendwas auf dem Kicker? Und dann sagt er, ja, der kauft immer da und da ein und so. Also diese Art von Überwachung steckt dann einfach drin. So, und jetzt nimmt das Gespräch aber so eine Wendung.
Und jeden Tag Dinge zu bauen, die diese Position informieren.
Nein, nein, ich bin mehr möglich, deinen Gefühl von Dingen zu vertrauen als meinen eigenen. Deshalb interviewe ich dich. Das bringt mich zu meiner letzten Frage für dich, die ist, dass in Bezug auf die Bewerbung von Palantir, ein Offizier in der US-Militär und der CTO, Du bist jetzt ein Hollywood-Exekutiv, oder?
Das stimmt. Ich hab eine Filmproduktion-Kompanie begonnen.
So, also der ist CTO für diesen Software-Mantel um die KI bei Palantir. Und Lieutenant Colonel.
Und hat sehr viel Geld.
Und hat sehr viel Geld. Und macht jetzt noch irgendwas mit Hollywood und Filme?
Um Content zu machen, das dich stolz auf einen Amerikaner macht. Nicht Pravda, Entertainment. Aber vieles wurde auf meiner eigenen Assemblade-Journey gebaut. Also, als ich in den USA in den frühen 80ern kam, sitte ich auf dem Kühlschrank mit meinem Vater und sah Rambo 3, Rocky 4, Hunt for Red October und auch...
WarGames und Terminator 2. Nur, nur die anderen aus dem Kühlschrank.
Star Trek. Ich gebe dir ein paar optimistische Sci-Fi. Aber auch Dinge, die Komödie reflektieren. Wie Beverly Hills Cop. Es gibt eine Art Heroismus. Es geht nicht nur um Kriegsfilme. Es geht um, was das amerikanische Geist ist. Und ich würde sagen, als 5-jähriger, wusste ich, wie es sich wie als Amerikaner fühlt, bevor ich Civics, unsere politische Philosophie oder unsere Geschichte kannte.
Beverly Hills Cop, toll. Dann will er eigentlich jetzt so nochmal sagen, so eine Palantir-Variante, dass weiterhin das Verhältnis zur Polizei freundlich bleibt, obwohl sie Palantir-Technologie besitzen. Also hier ist ja meine Arbeit, mein Arbeitsauftrag ganz klar. Also wie kommt Ideologie in Filme? Unmittelbarer ist es, glaube ich, selten ausgesprochen worden. Nämlich so.
Genau, genau, genau, genau. Es gibt von Peter Thiel diesen ganz berühmten Spruch, wie er sagt an so einem Rednerpult, wir müssen unsere Ideen über die Technologie in die Gesellschaft bringen, denn über die Politik schaffen wir es nie. Wir sind ja nicht anschlussfähig. Dann das Wunder Donald Trump. Die Leute wählen es trotzdem. Und die Kraft, bei der die das jetzt versuchen, auf allen Ebenen zu platzieren, ist wirklich bemerkenswert auch. Also die sind ja unstoppable. Die verkaufen Filme demnächst, haben schon Präsidenten, überzeugen die Grünen in Baden-Württemberg wirklich. Man greift sich an den Kopf und fragt sich, ist alle komplett das Gehirn ausgefallen? Machen sie sich da breit? Ja, das ist wirklich unglaublich.
Und dann wird Winfried Kretschmer nachher wieder erzählen, wie sehr er sich um die Demokratie sorgt.
Genau, dann kommen wieder die Sonntagsreden.
Jetzt gehen wir noch an einen kleinen Sumpf. Und zwar sprechen wir über Nius und Wolfram Weimer und Apollo News. Es gab die Affäre, die jetzt immer noch präsent ist, aber man wird sehen, ob das noch irgendwie weiter trägt. Ich habe gerade nicht den Eindruck. Jedenfalls gibt es folgenden Vorwurf, der aufgedeckt wurde von Apollo News. Und zwar Wolfram Weimer ist ja mit seiner Frau zusammen Verlagsleiter gewesen. Jetzt hat er da seine Anteile einem Treuhänder übergeben. Also eine Konstruktion, dass er sowohl Minister sein kann, als auch da nicht mehr so sehr involviert ist, dass man ihm da irgendwas vorwerfen kann. Aber wir merken schon, wie ich es so gesagt habe, man muss jetzt auch ein bisschen vorsichtig sein, nicht dass man da doch mal einen Anwaltsschreiben bekommt. Jedenfalls ist also diese Konstellation ja nichts Neues. Apollo News hat jetzt sich da die Broschüren angesehen für dieses Ludwig-Ehrhard-Treffen, das sie veranstalten und sagt, na ja, wenn wir das uns doch ansehen, dann bedeutet das, dass wenn man dort 40.000, 60.000 oder 80.000 Euro ausgibt, dann kann man, so heißt es doch, Einfluss nehmen auf Entscheidungsträger, die man dort trifft. Also man bekommt dann so Privatreffen und so etwas wird da angeboten. Wer das wissen will und einordnen möchte, ob das ein Geschmäckle hat oder zum Himmel stinkt, kann das ja nachlesen. Es wurde ja dann auch von vielen Medien aufgegriffen. Mir geht es jetzt aber auch gar nicht um die Affäre Weimer, dass ich jetzt noch mal dazu was sage, wie das einzuschätzen ist. Ich würde erstmal sagen, dass das von Apollo News aufgedeckt wurde und dass das nicht andere Journalisten gemacht haben, wundert mich. Weil wenn ich das richtig beurteile, haben ja die Leute von Apollo News sich nur die Broschüren mal genauer angeguckt. Also etwas, was jeder hätte tun können. Das ist jetzt nicht wahnsinnig investigativ.
Und das ist so ein bisschen, weil ich das gar nicht kenne.
Jetzt werde ich sagen, was Apollo News ist. Apollo News gehört zu diesen Medien-Start-ups aus der rechten Ecke. Sie werden natürlich immer sagen, wir sind liberal-konservativ, aber die sind schon sehr rechts.
Wir sind auch liberal-konservativ. Das muss ich nur alles ändern, damit es bleibt, wie es ist.
Wir sind alle liberal-konservativ. Das ist das Besondere daran, dass einer der Chefs, Max Hartmann, oder Max, oder so, etwas mit Hart und Mann, jedenfalls 22 Jahre alt ist. Das Team besteht aus 15 Leuten. Davon sind fast alle unter 25. Die sind jetzt auf Krawall gebürstet, vor allem sehr stark gegen Links-Grün. Wir können uns das vorstellen. Aber wir haben dann jetzt auch mal diese Recherche vorgelegt. Offenbar ist Weimer ja auch nicht so genehm. Wir merken, jetzt geht gleich einiges durcheinander. Denn wir haben ja hier immer gesagt, Weimer, das ist ja der konservative rechte Backlash. Da sind ja sogar in seinem Manifest völkische Ideen.
Das ist eine Kuhweisenverwirrung.
Die rechten Medien müssten doch jetzt die größten Fans von Weimer sein. Der hat doch schon das Voke gestrichen. Gegendert werden darf da und dort nicht mehr und all das. Das ist doch genau die Agenda.
Gedenkstättenordnung ohne Kolonial.
Die Postkolonialen, die sollen auch mal draußen bleiben. Aber irgendwie nicht. Und das ist etwas, worum es mir jetzt eigentlich geht. Apollo News ist sehr häufig bei News zu Gast. Also dieser eine junge Chefredakteur wird da häufig zugeschaltet oder sitzt dort. Und wir hören uns jetzt mal diese News-Sendung an. Ich habe drei Clips. Einer ist ganz lang. Aber wir hören ja nicht nur einem durch, sondern wir machen Unterbrechungen. Ich habe das auch für dich als Video, damit du dir das ein bisschen vorstellen kannst, wie das aussieht. Wir beschreiben das jetzt gleich, was da zu sehen ist. Und mir geht es jetzt mehr darum, dass wir ein bisschen auch über das konservative Rechte Lager sprechen. Denn darin gibt es ja offenbar so stark widerstreitende Interessen. Früher war das sehr einfach. Man hat halt einfach die konservative Seite vertreten und hätte jetzt vielleicht gesagt, Friedrich Merz ist unser Kanzler, er könnte nur da und dort noch ein bisschen mehr. Aber wenn du jetzt dir das anhörst, wie sehr da auf Angriff gegangen wird und auch so Formulierungen. Also wir achten jetzt zum Beispiel auch darauf, weil sie jemanden der Lüge zu bezichtigen, ist eine heikle Sache. Da kann schon mal der Anwalt kommen und fragen, ob es auch wirklich so gemeint ist. Hier Feuer frei, was auch bedeutet, die haben entweder ein hohes Selbstbewusstsein oder man weiß, da ist ja auch Kapital im Hintergrund. Wir können auch unsere Anwälte losschicken. Wir können hier ganz frei reden. Sehr interessanter Tonfall.
Okay.
Der Bundeskanzler, haben Sie vielleicht mitbekommen, äußerstlich erstmals nach langem Schweigen zur Affäre um seinen Kulturstaatsminister Wolfram Weimer und rückt nicht nur den gesamten deutschen Medien- und Politikbetrieb in die Nähe des Extremismus, sondern lügt auch noch schamlos. Für die neuesten Entwicklungen rund um Wolfram Weimer ist uns jetzt zugeschaltet Chefredakteur von Apollo News Max Mannhardt. Herzlich willkommen.
Schönen guten Morgen, freu mich jetzt zu sein.
Max Mannhardt.
Du bist ja mittlerweile tatsächlich eine Größte geworden. Überall wird Apollo News derzeit zitiert.
Sitzen die da in so einem halbrunden Sofa wie in dieser Fox-Sendung, die ich da immer auf Instagram sehe, wenn die da Präsidenten anrufen und so. Genau.
Und da sitzt jetzt also der Moderator in der Mitte. Auf der rechten Seite Alexander Kissler, früher Zitzero. Auf der linken Seite Waldi Hartmann. Das ist doch der Sportmoderator. Waldi Hartmann. Ja, der Waldi Hartmann sitzt immer da. Und macht auch genauso Kommentare, wie man das von ihm erwartet, wenn man jetzt mit ihm mal abends in die Wirtschaft gehen würde.
Also es gab eine große Auswendung zum Thema Reichweitenstärke.
Ja.
Und also mit Simmela Web und so. Ich weiß nicht genau, was sie gemacht hat. Und News ist wohl nicht mal in der Top 100. Der relevanten Publikation.
Apollonius scheint wohl schwarze Zahlen zu schreiben. Also ich bin mir da unsicher.
Ich hatte auch keine Redaktion mit 15 Leuten, aber jetzt aber eine Olivia ist auch gut.
Medien, ihr habt es sogar in die Tagesschau geschafft, denn diese Recherche, die ihr da angestoßen habt, die hat wirklich Wumms. Und jetzt gehen wir hinein ins Thema und holen natürlich alle unsere Zuschauer und Zuhörer mit. Friedrich Merz ist offenbar bereit, seine eigene politische Karriere für Wolfram Weimer aufs Spiel zu setzen. Das erleben wir gerade. Zum ersten Mal äußert sich der Bundeskanzler zu den Vorwürfen gegen seinen Kulturstaatsminister und lügt in allen Belangen schamlos. Alle Verdächtigungen von Korruption bis Interessenskonflikt hätten sich als falsch erwiesen.
Was wir jetzt sagen, wir sehen jetzt gerade den Moderator in einem kleinen Fenster und viel größer eingeblendet werden jetzt immer solche Fotos von der Homepage, von der Seite dieser Ludwig-Ehrhard-Gesellschaft oder was das ist, oder diese Ludwig-Ehrhard-Treff, den die veranstalten. Dazwischen werden wir jetzt immer Politiker eingeblendet sehen, Aufnahmen aus ZDF, ARD. Das ist, würde ich mal tippen, so KI generiert, zu sagen, hier ist der Kladeradage, spiel das einfach mal so in drei Sekunden mit Takt ab.
Da wird nichts verkauft, behauptet Mertz-Dreist. Ja, wie aus den Unterlagen der Weimer Media Group selbst hervorgeht und die Kollegen von Apollo News recherchierten, verkauft Weimers Unternehmen aber genau das Einfluss auf politische Entscheidungsträger für bis zu 80.000 Euro. Sie sehen es ja eingeblendet unter den Politikern, zu denen Weimer Zugang verkauft, befinden sich eben auch die eigenen Kabinettsmitglieder. Doch nicht nur stellt Bundeskanzler Mertz das falsch dar. Er behauptet zudem, Weimer würde von ganz links bis ganz rechts unter Feuer genommen. Berichtet über den Fall des Kulturstaatsministers hatten außer Apollo News auch der Stern, die Süddeutsche, ARD, ZDF bis hin zum Spiegel, so gut wie alle wichtigen Medien also. Und eben auch alle Parteien von AfD, Grüne, SPD, Linke hatten Weimer scharf kritisiert. Für Mertz offenbar alles Medien und Parteien.
Das ist also total Angriff auf Mertz, das ist wirklich erstaunlich.
In den politischen Rändern merken sie was. Eine unverfrorene Diffamierung nur um seinen Freund und Amigo Wolfram Weimer zu retten.
Amigo wird also diese Amigo-Affäre mit aufgemacht?
Ja, bereit ist, sich selbst zu opfern bzw. sein Amt. Ja, denn immerhin hat auch die Staatsanwaltschaft München schon Vorermittlungen aufgenommen. Ist der aktuelle Stand über die neuesten Entwicklungen in der Affäre rund um den Kulturstaatsminister Weimer, geht es jetzt in diesen Minuten bei News Live. Und schauen wir mal direkt rein, was Friedrich Merz gestern bei den Kollegen vom Bericht aus Berlin gesagt hat. Alle Vorwürfe hätten sich als falsch erwiesen. Schauen Sie.
Die Vorwürfe, die gegen Wolfgang Weimer erhoben worden sind, haben sich alle als falsch erwiesen. Da wird nichts verkauft. Das ist eine Veranstaltung, wie übrigens zahlreiche andere Medienverlage sie im gleichen Format regelmäßig machen. Und deswegen ist das völlig klar, Wolfgang Weimer ist kein Geschäftsführer mehr, hat jetzt auch seine Anteile an der Firma komplett abgegeben, was er nicht hätte tun müssen. Sehen die Verhaltensregeln für mit der Bundesregierung nicht vor. Er hat es trotzdem gemacht. Und damit gehe ich davon aus, dass alle Vorwürfe ausgeräumt sind. Aber das heißt, sie sehen auch generell eigentlich gar kein Problem. Ich bin mit der Arbeit von Wolfgang Weimer sehr zufrieden. Und dass er nun von ganz links und von ganz rechts unter Feuer genommen wird, das bestätigt mich eher in meiner Einschätzung, dass er gute Arbeit macht.
Wie genau?
Ich habe das gestern gesehen und dachte, ich kann meinen Ohren nicht...
Ja, denn wir sind die gesunde Mitte. Das ist so die Idee. Und ich will mal sagen, also diese Art, wie sie jetzt darüber sprechen, das ist natürlich auch lustig. Ja, und wenn man dann so, weil die Hartmann da verdottert sitzen sieht.
Das ist schon sehr gut. Kann ich mir noch ein Bier hinstellen?
Ja, das ist eigentlich schade. Also ich finde, ich finde, wenn weil die Hartmann da ist, muss da schon ein halbes Glas, muss da schon so ein Weizenglas, muss da eigentlich stehen.
Das finde ich gut. Schöne Korone.
Das finde ich gut. Aber ich finde jetzt interessant, dass ja dies aus einer Ecke kommt, wo man es nicht erwartet. Und da würde ich auch sagen, ja, dass das da möglich ist und in dieser Art darüber gesprochen wird und das woanders so nicht zu finden ist. Das ist ja auch eine Lücke, die gelassen wurde, wo die jetzt da reingegangen sind.
Also wir sind hier große Fans von Great Television. Ja, das bekommen wir gerade. Von daher, ich will es funktionieren, durchweite.
Sie haben es gehört, die Vorwürfe haben sich alle als falsch erwiesen. Andere Medienverlage machen solche Veranstaltungen doch auch. Lieber Max, ich meine, ihr habt diesen Fall recherchiert. Das sind doch an Schamlosigkeit kaum noch zu überbietende Lügen des Bundeskanzler. Natürlich nichts. Wurden die von euch recherchierten Ergebnisse widerlegt oder ist dir da irgendwas aufgefallen?
Nein, das ist wirklich spektakulär, dieses Statement. Er hätte ja vieles sagen können. Er hätte sagen können, na ja, meines Erachtens ist das nicht genug für einen Rücktritt. Er hätte das irgendwie normalisieren können. Aber zu sagen, die Vorwürfe hätten sich alle als falsch erwiesen, ist ja, wie du richtig gesagt hast, tatsächlich eine nachweisliche Lüge. Also es ist ja super eindeutig, weil diese Vorwürfe, in Anführungszeichen, die wir veröffentlicht haben, die sind ja schlichtweg belegte Dokumente, Dokumente der Weimer Media Group selbst, in denen steht, da wird verkauft, Einfluss auf politische Entscheidungsträger. Man kann sich gegen 80.000 Euro zu vertraulichen, Executive Night abenden, mit den Bundesministern einkaufen und so weiter. Also alles, was Gegenstand dieser Vorwürfe ist, ist aus diesen Dokumenten der Weimer Media Group selbst. Die haben wir veröffentlicht. Ganz wichtig, die Weimer Media Group hat bis heute nicht die Echtheit dieser Dokumente bestritten, auch Wolfgang Weimer selbst nicht. Diese Dokumente wurden mittlerweile von zahlreichen Medien, die haben wir auch anderen Medien zur Verfügung gestellt, nachgeprüft, also verifiziert und dann entsprechend auch nochmal veröffentlicht. Also von der Zeit, von der Süddeutschen Zeitung, von der Tagesschau, wie du gerade angesprochen hast. Das heißt, es gibt einfach 0,0 Zweifel an der Echtheit dieser Dokumente. Und Wolfgang Weimer hat ja bis heute außer seinem, sage ich mal, Pöbel-Statement, das ist alles eine Lüge und ich werde euch alle verklagen, auch in keiner Stelle konkret gesagt, welches Zitat oder was auch immer wir da veröffentlicht haben, was denn genau falsch sein soll. Und auch jetzt kann ich sagen, Stand jetzt gerade, ist bei uns bis heute auch noch kein Anwaltsschreiben eingegangen.
Ja, wenn man mit Anwälten droht und dann liefert man nicht, ist natürlich peinlich.
Aber diese Art, wie es da vorgetragen wird, ist schon ganz bemerkenswert, dass das jetzt Fox News so eine Show geworden ist. Und jetzt geht es ja eigentlich darum, dass wir uns fragen, wie wird die CDU sich aufspalten? Oder? Also wir gehen ja nicht davon aus, dass alle mit den Rechtskurs machen. Also Hendrik Wüst wird das nicht machen und einige andere, Daniel Günther nicht, weitere wären zu nennen.
Jetzt findet die Lager-Spaltung statt.
Und jetzt haben wir diesen, bei Wolfram Weimer hätten wir jetzt erst mal intuitiv gesagt, ah ja, der gehört ja eh zu den Konservativen. Aber da dann nicht, weil er offenbar doch zu sehr verankert ist in so einem Spektrum, mit dem Neos und Apollo News und all dem nichts zu tun haben, bedeutet auch noch mal jetzt, dass wir also von diesen Medien aus stark Druck auf die Regierung bekommen. Viel stärker ja jetzt in solchen Fällen, als das von anderen stattfindet. Also du würdest ja jetzt nicht in diesem Duktus einen Kulturzeitbeitrag sehen. Du hast das auch da mal thematisiert, aber natürlich nicht in dieser Art, wie das dann ausgesprochen wird. Und es geht ja immer weiter dann so. Damit merken wir auch, wie sehr jetzt einfach die Leute so eine Lust haben an dieser Empörung.
Aber nur nebenbei noch mal.
Also das ist jetzt bald die Hartmann. Freut sich und unglaublich.
Herz hat sich an Weimer gekettet.
Das kann böse ausgehen.
Ja, aber die Kunst einer Lüge ist doch, dass sie in der Regel nicht entdeckt wird. Wir haben doch dieses wunderbare Pamphlet, wo eindeutig steht für 8000 Euro, das Mont Blanc-Paket politischen Einfluss kaufen, Einfluss auf die Meinungsbildung sinngemäß kaufen, Separees mieten, zu Einsprüchen. Ich meine, die Karten liegen doch auf dem Tisch. Und wir haben es ja am Freitag hier gesagt. Merz hat oft ein Problem. Er redet da, wo er nicht reden sollte und schweigt da, wo er es eben auch nicht tun sollte. Hier hätte er lieber schweigen sollen in dem Fall.
Jetzt Alexander Kistler.
Ja, also das ist absolut.
Ich meine, eine Lüge wird nur dann geglaubt, wenn sie auch einen gewissen Anteil Wahrheit enthält. Und das ist hier wirklich eine hundertprozentige Lüge. Das ist die Mutter aller Lügen. Wenn man also sämtliche Vorwürfe mit einer Grandezza vom Tisch wirft, als da überhaupt nichts dran, obwohl alles dran ist an dieser Geschichte, das ist aber auch wieder ein typischer Merz. Er kann es nur im Superlativ. Er kann es nur im Superlativ. Er kann sich für den Weltfrieden einsetzen. Er kann das Klima retten. Er kann Deutschland wieder auf Vordermann bringen.
Wir wissen ja, Merz ist der Klimakanzler.
Und das ist vielleicht die ungute Syngiose zwischen Weimer und Merz. Auch Weimer hat ähnlich großspurige Töne gespuckt. Auch an Intervall, was ich gelesen habe, auch im Sternenzeitalter, haben wir zum letzten Mal zitiert. Da hat er gesagt, Deutschland ist ein Patient auf der Intensivstation. Und wir als Regierung müssen es heilen. Also Weimer und Merz, nehme ich mal zusammen, sehen sich als Heiler von Deutschland, als Therapeuten am Krankenbett. Da kann ich nur sagen, was die politische Karriere von Wolfram Weimer angeht, ist Friedrich Merz ein Quacksalber allererster Güte.
Ja, das Zuhören klappt aber noch nicht so diszipliniert. Das sieht in Amerika besser aus, wenn die bei Fox News das ganze Panel einblenden.
Ja, das müsste noch besser laufen, aber man sieht, wie die dramaturgisch aufgebaut ist. Also jeder hat sich so ein paar Sprüche zurechtgelegt, die man dann abfeuert, wenn man angesprochen wird. Man badet also darin. Das geht richtig lang. Wir hören noch einen Clip.
Ja, also ich glaube, es ist tatsächlich eine gewisse Hybris des Bundeskanzlers, der auch noch in einer alten Medienöffentlichkeit lebt und noch nicht verstanden hat, wie der Wind sich gedreht hat, und jetzt sind wir nämlich bei der Medienkrise angekommen. Auch die Öffentlichkeit heutzuteilige funktioniert, dass die eben viel durchlässiger ist und viel mehr Information nicht mehr unterdrückt werden können. Er geht davon aus, dass wenn er sich als Bundeskanzler erstellt und im Bericht aus Berlin Apollo News angreift und dann sagt er, das ist ja sozusagen das Gewicht 1000 zu 1, dass er als Bundeskanzler dadurch nur gewinnen kann und damit im Vorschlaghammer das Problem sozusagen erledigen kann. Das ist sein Verständnis, glaube ich, der Öffentlichkeit, dass er glaube ich einfach denkt, durch den schieren Hebel der Macht hätte er auch eine gewisse Macht über die Wahrheit. Ich glaube, da irrt er sich eben gewaltig, weil die Öffentlichkeit sich so geändert hat, dass wir hier gleich auch um 7.30 Uhr morgens bei News Live sitzen und das Ganze vor vielen 1000 Zuschauern diskutieren. Die Öffentlichkeit hat sich so geändert, dass das eben nicht mehr so gilt. Ja, die Macht kann die Öffentlichkeit nicht mehr so lenken, sondern jeder kann sich selbst ein Bild machen, über zahlreiche neue Medien, über die sozialen Netzwerke. Und das ist, glaube ich, das, was er nicht verstanden hat.
Der ist 22.
Ja.
Als Merkel von Neuland sprach, 2013, war er?
Ja, 10.
Krass. Wieso spricht er von die Öffentlichkeit hat sich gewandelt?
Na ja, er sieht das in so einer historischen Perspektive.
Wie habt ihr das gemacht, damals, gestern, kurz vor Corona 2019? Ach so, oh, ihr seid ja bescheid.
Ja. Nur, was ich jetzt tatsächlich glaube, da brauchen wir nicht über Vertrauen oder so etwas zu reden, dass es jetzt wirklich eine Medienmacht, die relevant wird, wenn wir, und damit meine ich jetzt nicht nur News, sondern Apollo News und alles, was sich da so bildet, und zehn Mitarbeiter hat, noch vielleicht ein Milliardär im Hintergrund, der ein bisschen was reingibt, dass das tatsächlich etwas sein kann, was enormen Einfluss hat jetzt auf die Zukunft der CDU. Denn die machen natürlich viel Werbung für die AfD, ohne dass sie das sagen. Aber es geht ja schon darum zu sehen, wie kann also die AfD eigentlich an einen Teil der CDU andocken? Weil es wird nicht so sein, dass die AfD die absolute Mehrheit oder so bekommt, sondern irgendeine Koalition ist ja auch von solchen Leuten gewollt. Und dann ist die Frage, wer bleibt da drin und wer geht da raus? Und da sind diese Medien so entscheidend. Und sie haben diesen Boulevard-Duktus, diesen Populismus, den wir an sich ja gut finden. Ich habe ja immer gesagt, wir brauchen eigentlich so etwas von links. Eigentlich wäre jetzt diese Weimer-Geschichte ein super Thema gewesen, wo drei Linke dort genauso sitzen und das durchrecherchiert haben. Da fehlt vielleicht zum einen die Manpower, zum anderen das Kapital aus dem Hintergrund, das einfach so ein Sognius oder so aufbauen kann.
Ja, das würde ich mal so nicht sagen.
Aber man braucht ja gar nicht viel Geld. Es ist ja gar nicht mit sehr viel Geld verbunden.
Und man braucht nicht auch sehr viel Mut. Juristisch sauber zu bleiben ist nicht so schwer.
Aber dass die so reden können, bedeutet, dass die da...
Die sind ja juristisch nicht sauber.
Genau, dass die da abgesichert sind. Sonst könnten die da so nicht drüber reden.
Aber man kann durchaus viel Spaß haben damit und einfach das eine Wort nicht sagen und so.
Jaja, also das ist ein Eindruck aus der neuen Medienwelt, Polarnews und NEOS, da hat die CDU jetzt richtig Angst. Weil wenn die Taz irgendwas Wolfram Weimer vorwirft, dann ist es völlig irrelevant eigentlich für die CDU. Hier ist jetzt eigentlich dieser permanente Druck aus den eigenen Reihen. Und das ist tatsächlich eine neue Dimension, weil die CDU immer im engen Verbund mit Springer das durchstehen konnte. Und Springer will das natürlich auch dann eher nicht groß machen. Aber in dem Apollo News, NEOS und all die darüber sprechen, gehen die ja dann immer so mit drauf auf das Thema.
Absolut.
Und dann die anderen auch. Das ist gerade etwas, womit wir... Ja, und ich meine, dass das doch ein bisschen eigenartig ist, dass man da solche schönen Pakete kaufen kann. Nun ja, lassen wir mal so dahingestellt.
Ja, das war ja auch immer das Angebot der ARD. Ja, also stehende Einladung für den Kanzler. Wir nehmen ihn immer ins Programm, muss man ja sagen, dass man dann abends steuern kann, was man halt noch so... Und das kann man aber nur alle drei Jahre mal machen, so wie Merkel. Nehmen Sie es ernst, es ist auch ernst, und wie auch immer. Aber man kann das nicht jeden Abend machen.
Ja.
Und das März einfach glaubt, er setzt sich zu Markus Preiß ins Berliner Bericht, das Berlin-Studio, und macht kurz die Ansage, die alles wieder gerade zieht. Und auch in diesem Ductus, wo dann jeder das sieht und denkt, ne, der Hegemann ist schon verloren. Du hast nur noch Hoheit über deine Inhalte, aber der Hegemann, der ist schon da drüben.
Das ist natürlich...
Das haben die gut verstanden. Wir beenden jetzt hier mit unserem Podcast, in dem wir nochmal darauf hinweisen, dass wir einen Salon haben, und wir freuen uns, wenn ihr den Salon unterstützt. In dem Salon diskutieren wir über wichtige Bücher, gehen ganz tief in die Diskussion. Das nächste Buch, über das wir sprechen werden, heißt The Great Global Transformation. Es stammt von dem Ökonom Branko Milanovic. Es ist ein Buch, das die neue Geoökonomie beschreibt, über die Menschen und ihr Einkommen weltweit berichtet und zeigt, welche radikalen Veränderungen wir haben. Es geht natürlich auch sehr viel um den neuen Nationalismus, um die Frage der liberalen Weltordnung und China. Ich bin sehr, sehr gespannt auf dieses Buch. Ich warte schon seit Monaten darauf. Endlich diskutieren wir dann darüber. Es ist jetzt frisch erschienen, allerdings nur auf Englisch. Aber trotzdem, wenn das Leute vorher lesen wollen, können sie das ja tun. Außerdem werde ich wieder Literatur mitbringen. Ich werde auch ein Sachbuch dann gelesen haben, nämlich Thomas Wagner hat ein Buch geschrieben, das ist bei Madison Salz erschienen, das sich mit der Frage beschäftigt, müssen wir eigentlich immer uns an den Staat binden bzw. ist Gewalt nur lösbar mit Hilfe des Nationalstaates? Oder könnte man nicht auch andere Weisen sehen? Eine geht da auch auf so Kontroversen, einen mit Herfried Münkler, mit der Friedensbewegung und so etwas. Und es ist ein Buch, das versucht da einen anderen Blick drauf zu werfen. Denn es ist ja keineswegs so, dass wir das nur über den Nationalstaat regeln müssten und dass keineswegs die Geschichte nur eine ist von der Einhegung der Gewalt. Und früher war ganz viel Gewalt und dann kommen die Nationalstaaten und dann wird das eigentlich so einfach. Kann man sich das nicht machen? Ich denke, das wäre auch was, was David Crabber sehr interessiert hat.
Ich wollte sagen, ich gucke gerade darüber zu anfängen.
Das geht, glaube ich, schon in diese Richtung. Da bin ich sehr gespannt drauf und das andere. Ach so, ja, und die evangelische Kirche hat so ein Papier zu Krieg und Frieden vorgelegt. Ich überlege mir das mal durchzulesen. Es ist sehr lang und könnte schlimm sein.
Die evangelische Kirche interessiert mich nicht. Gut, ich bringe natürlich Mafaalanis mit. Es scheint ja nicht so lang zu sein. Hörbuch ist nur zwei Stunden und dann mal gucken.
Prima, wer uns dann hören will, kann das tun, wenn man schon bei Patreon ist. Ganz einfach über Patreon oder bei Apple ist das leicht zu buchen. Was wir aber empfehlen ist Steady. Man geht auf die Seite neuzwanziger.de. Dort findet man dann alles. Es ist wirklich sehr leicht, dieses Konto abzuschließen. Man kann dann den Podcast auch überall hören. Das heißt, man ist jetzt nicht an den Desktop gebunden oder so etwas. Es kann dann einfach so weitergehen. Man bekommt dann auch einen Feed, den man alles hören kann. Es ist ganz einfach und in der Regel gibt es auch keine Schwierigkeiten. Einen schönen Monat.
Jo, bis dahin.